What does that free kick is Dan?
Oh No,
I meant to wear at the panel yesterday.
Uh,
I actually,
I was late and I forgot what we're
talking about here folks is he has a
free Keka Stan shirt.
And I just learned about this very
recently from Jordan Peterson.
Yeah.
He loves it.
I had no idea.
I didn't know what the deal with the
frog was.
And do you know that you can't have the
frog now.
What does it on itunes?
Apple Itunes won't let you use the frog
is great.
What the fuck people what?
What is apple doing?
It's a frog.
It's a cartoon frog.
Hillary Clinton denounced it.
So she did now to Rog.
Oh yeah.
She said something about deplorables.
What'd she say about the frog?
Oh,
it was part of um,
uh,
an article on a website.
Oh,
they were saying how this causing frog
is a hate symbol and so you're a fucking
idiot.
He come home with him.
This is the best bit about the incident.
We can make them,
well,
they look ridiculous on their own.
Every means day.
It's just we're saying they were already
like doing the bad thing,
lumping people into these groups.
But it is a weird thing that they don't
understand.
Like whoever gets upset at this does not
understand how preposterous it is to
freak out about a frog.
And who the fuck is over at apple?
First of all.
What about the poor bastard that made
pepe the frog for totally non Keka Stan
Oh nine incident red pill reasons.
This poor bastard just had this cartoon
frog did.
He made feels bad man.
You know?
And then all of a sudden that poor guy
has to say,
I'm killing off.
Pepe did in the inner is like,
bitch,
you not kill him off shit.
Nobody knows who you are,
but everyone knows who pepe is.
You can't kill off something like that.
That's so crazy.
It's silly to think that he could have
achieved as well.
Everybody's so it's almost like they
have to denounce it.
Yeah.
You know?
Otherwise they'll get lumped in with a
supporter.
Like he probably does think that he's a,
people think he's a supporter maybe.
Well,
I don't think they do.
I think he's like,
Oh,
you know,
I don't know what's going on.
SONA.
Stan of it.
I haven't,
when he looked in stuff too much.
It's weird man.
Because like,
you know,
um,
people think there'd been shadow banned
like a Scott Adams had a big post the
other day.
We're city's been shadow banned phobias.
Yeah.
And He's put,
he said he talked to Jack at twitter and
Jack said there's no shadow banning.
I talked to Joe Shuts Up Jack.
We know this show.
This is Sargon speaking just full of
shit.
We know Jacksonville.
Holy Shit.
Why the fuck it was like a nice guy.
Jack.
Tell me,
Jack,
why haven't I been verified?
Well,
he's probably super busy with the 400
billion people that are on twitter.
Probably super full of Shit.
And so if you tried three times and
every time that just denied why,
I mean,
what is it then have enough?
How many followers do you have?
200,000
that's supposed to Claudia accounts by
me.
My friends need to know who I am on
twitter.
Don't you think that's the reason that
for verification Jag,
isn't that
interesting?
Because if you were on a television
show,
it would be expected that you would be
verified by now with that kind of
following.
That's a giant following and your 30,000
on Youtube.
So yeah,
that's a lot of people.
Seems worth firefighting before,
but it's not,
it's a badge of status,
which is one of the verified Milo.
I mean,
that's the most ridiculous one.
D verifying.
So you can't do that,
but verify someone and then not milo
anymore as it jack like the guy.
Yeah,
you're a fucking lie.
You know,
it's a badge of status.
you're doing it to create some sort of
privileged class on twitch.
I mean,
they even get like a different function,
don't they?
Well,
you can only see some of the verified
hell.
Every account on twitter should be
verified thing you do.
Right?
You're allowed to only see a counselor
verified.
Yeah,
it's a privilege.
And he took it away from mine to punish
him for being a dissident.
And he won't verify me to punish me for
being a dissident.
And he knows it.
This is a stranger.
You're fucking balls deep in this dude.
You feel it?
You're like very emotionally invested.
Oh yes.
Oh yeah.
That's,
cause I've,
I've never,
I've never had to play the game.
I'm,
I'm where I am now entirely on my own
merits.
I've never,
I've never had any industry connections.
I've never been,
I've never been to America before.
I've never spoken to any of these
people.
They all knew who I am and they're all
afraid of me because I think because if
I can do it,
anyone can do it.
But why,
why do you think it's fear?
Why do you think is,
well,
we definitely don't need them.
No one needs anybody anymore.
But that's a good thing.
But you can't create a system of
privilege without interdependent
connections.
There is no system of privilege if you
don't have to rely on other people to
maintain a privilege class.
If you don't have to maintain the
privilege class and you can't,
you don't have to rely on other people,
then their status goes away.
Let's break this down for people who
don't know what the fuck we're talking
about.
Okay.
Your,
um,
may I call you Carl?
That's your actual name,
right?
I that cool.
He dead naming me.
He doxing.
Doxing.
But you've already been doxed we were
discussing this.
Yeah.
Now I'm your youtube account.
You have great videos.
Really great commentary.
Very smart guy.
And how did you get involved?
I mean,
are you like,
what,
is this a you and outright guy?
No,
you're not right.
Yeah,
they,
they'll ride is an identitarian movement
for white people.
They're,
they're heavily nationalist,
protectionist,
anti interventionist.
They're not like laissez faire free
market capitalist.
I'm a liberal.
I am,
I'm like an English liberal as in I want
universal rights.
Laissez faire,
capitalism.
I don't mind.
I mean socialized health care and a well
a welfare state.
I'm happy with as long as it's
universal.
It was all done.
Just applied some as long as anyone
could access it if they needed to.
Um,
just universal rights rule.
I don't,
I don't see the,
I can't see a reason to discriminate
against someone when it comes to dealing
with rights.
Well,
who's,
um,
like defining outright is it been
clearly defined now because it's so new,
it's actually relatively well defined
now because the old right have asserted
themselves.
I said,
look,
no,
we're for white people.
You know,
Wipro while saying that,
which,
which guys like,
he knows I'm like Ramsey pole as soon as
expensive,
but as soon as someone like that says
they're all right,
then everybody else just assumes that
they like allows them to define it
because I think there's probably a lot
of people considered the cells all
right.
Where they were right wing,
but they weren't racist.
They weren't,
or white supremacists,
they just didn't like this old man.
Right.
That was in there for four,
I think they call themselves the ultra
lights.
I don't know.
I don't know whether that's at a time of
disparagement or not.
Um,
but I over new rights or something like
that.
But the thing is I don't run in the
circles.
So actually I actually don't really know
very much about those guys out of the
pool.
Jessie Watson's incentive itches.
I don't find that particularly
offensive.
I just find them to be like a modern
form of conservatism.
I think Paul Joseph Watson is a very
reasonable guy and he's very articulate.
He seems pretty smart.
He,
he,
he does the opposite of what the media
does,
but the end,
it's it.
That's not,
that's not a criticism.
Two points.
Yeah,
exactly.
I thought a lot of things,
absolutely.
I think it's necessary for him to exist.
You know,
he's like,
you know,
cause they both create narratives and
the,
it's not that these narratives aren't
true,
it's just that sometimes these
narratives sometimes leave things out.
But always,
this isn't like a condemnation of either
side by saying this,
this is just what they do and that's
okay.
You know,
everyone's entitled to create their own
sort of,
and I'm going to use the word
propaganda,
but again,
I'm not using it in a derogatory sense.
Right.
It's,
I mean,
you're like,
look,
I want to make this point.
I'm not,
I don't want to make your point,
you know,
because you're making your point.
I'm going to make my point and the these
two points,
we'll both stand in existence and we'll
both be true at the same time.
Hmm.
And so it's okay if Paul Joseph Watson
to exist,
you know,
it's fine.
I don't have a problem with them.
I don't have,
I don't really have any criticisms of it
to be honest.
Otherwise,
you know,
I,
I mean I wouldn't do what he's doing,
but what is he doing that you wouldn't
do?
It gets a bit harder than I would and he
didn't.
I don't think he is as objective as I
would prefer having a new source.
I prefer someone more like Philly d,
You know,
isn't that an interesting thing?
The objectivity is a,
this is a real,
real problem when it comes to left
versus right or any of these groups.
You get lumped into these categories and
then you start defending your turf.
And uh,
that,
that seems to be a huge issue today.
Yet,
everybody just started digging their
heels in the sand and decides this is
who I am.
And those other p and you start using
they and them,
which is what I try to avoid that the
bad guys.
Yeah,
they and they,
what they want,
what the left wants.
And it's,
it's,
it's really tough actually because,
um,
that I've,
I'm actually done like channel.
Uh,
I've actually pulled my subscribers and
stuff and I've got like,
it was a bit like a year ago,
but I'm a content hasn't really changed.
Tena and I got like tens of thousands of
responses,
so it was a really good sample size.
Uh,
most of,
most of my subscribers are center left
liberals who just lost,
you know,
then identitarian is,
they don't want to sit there and go,
you know,
I mean,
I was at vidcon and they had so many
panels and they're like,
let me about me being a Latin x.
Let me talk about me being in a Latina.
And it's like,
what a Latinex lots of next year.
Nonbinary loveliness.
I'll come over and I'm not,
I'm not making this up.
And I'm joking.
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't make anything up and I won't
lie to you.
Right.
I'm absolutely serious.
This sort of,
but the thing is what really annoys me
about identity politics,
right?
Um,
when they're like,
Yo,
let me tell you about my identity.
So I look,
dude,
that's none of my fucking business.
I don't care about your fucking
identity.
Do not tell me how you identify.
It's not my problem.
It's not my business.
It's not political.
And if you want to make it political,
I'm going to tell you shut up and fuck
off cause I don't care.
Hey Joe,
let me say,
yeah,
of course it is.
Let me tell you about my white identity.
We do this.
Yeah.
See I told you Tino pay versus Latin x
versus Latin II.
Which word best solves Spanish gender
problem?
Really addressing the hard hitting
issues here.
Jesus,
Rachel,
Richard Reichard,
Rick,
when I say your name,
Gray card.
Right card,
right?
Yeah.
What are the best Spanish has gender.
What?
Gender problem.
Exactly.
I've made up.
Well it is.
It's talking about themselves.
They're not to point real problems.
Is this what happens when you have too
many vaccines?
I,
I think it's what happens when you have
too much money.
We have people that are just too,
it's too easy to get by.
This is a sim money,
food lenzer thinking,
hey,
people give a shit what I care what I
think of my genitals.
No,
ready.
Get Out.
Yeah.
Unless you're sticking him in my face,
I really don't give a fuck.
Yeah,
exactly.
But then that's an interpersonal thing.
It's not like a political problem.
No,
it's not a political problem.
Well,
I mean what I mean,
the politics of human interaction,
I guess.
Yeah.
It's a little bit of that knows me most
is when they say,
let me tell you about my blackness and
like,
what the hell do you mean by your
blackness?
And they're like,
well,
meet me as a black person.
You're going to,
you're going to start stereotyping
yourself.
You're going to tell you,
you're going to give me a stereotype of
black people,
and then you're gonna say this is
somehow representative nothing to you
but other people.
But then you're validating Richard
Spencer when he says,
Hey,
can I told her about my whiteness?
What's your argument saying?
They're not allowed to do that.
Well,
I know what's wonderful.
Why not?
You'll talk to me about your blackness.
I'll talk about my whiteness and all of
a sudden we're going to both realize,
you know,
we're just talking about ourselves,
which is talking about ourselves.
Why don't we talk about something real
it did you see that woman,
the Delaware professor who,
um,
was talking about that kid that got
killed in North Korea,
the kid who stole the propaganda poster
know about the kid.
I haven't seen the professor talking
about,
Oh man.
Each fall she just got fired today,
which is nice.
It's a good sign.
Yeah,
but what,
what she had said is essentially he had
it coming and that she's tired of rich
and blamers rich,
clueless white people who come to her
class and then she just goes on these,
this series of Straw Mans,
I'll have to do coke and have no problem
raping a girl at a Frat party.
Whoa.
Where'd that come from?
This guy just got beaten to death in
Korea and he shouldn't have raped girls.
He didn't rape anybody.
He did coke like this bitch.
No one should go fine.
Well,
she's apparently,
you know.
Yeah.
It's just racist.
She's racist towards white people.
I mean,
you can be that and that's an oh yeah.
That's one of the wonderful things about
the social justice warrior movement is
that they've made it so it's impossible
to be raped,
racist towards white people.
They believe they believe it.
Yeah.
This is a real belief that if you are a
white person,
you're personal privilege and racism is
something that a person of privilege
does to a person and a compromise group.
Yeah.
Do you know he's pretty funny about it.
Is they by saying it's a power plus
prejudice.
They make it,
they say rice institutional and is that
okay?
But that means you're taking away the
word for interpersonal racism.
So if like an Asian guy goes up to a
black guy and says,
hey,
enwood that copy racism,
because he doesn't have institutional
power and there is no word for racism
between individuals.
Now you've redefined it to be
institutional.
So what is the word for interpersonal?
Yeah,
it's,
I thought it will Chris rock bit about
February.
Black Dude thinks he's tough as a native
American white and kick his ass.
I'm more marginalized group.
It says it is one of those things where
it's like people are seeking problems
and there's,
they're also seeking to clearly identify
themselves as being from a more
compromised group.
Politics.
A victim.
Yeah,
exactly.
I'm the victim here at me.
Some special treatment.
It's like,
dude,
I don't want to be a victim.
You feel about the Trans racialism I
think there's no logical argument that
Kingston can identify as an Eskimo as
far as I can send you.
Can they,
there was a big Hoohah or in academia
recently because someone published a
paper,
I'll come in the name of the person
published papers saying,
well look,
what's the argument against this?
If you can identify as another agenda,
why can't you identify as another race?
St Logic is applied to a different,
not necessarily because the argument of
you identify with another gender could
be based on some sort of a hormonal
issue or um,
some neurotransmitter misfire there.
There could be some something that could
be physically that could be,
if any of their arguments were hinges on
the idea that that mattered,
but it's not,
they say,
well you can identify as anything you
won't cause it's all the social
construct so you can do whatever you
want with that.
Yeah.
That's where it gets slippery,
right?
Yeah.
Where it gets really slippery is that
sex and gender are social constructs.
It's like,
well look,
clearly that's not true in in it
actually a district,
they all social constructs.
But the thing is they're not sexy.
It's not a social construct to say let's
go.
Sex is based on your chromosomes and
your agenda is a group of constructed
behaviors around them.
Constructed for a good reason.
Men have got,
you know,
clinical,
superior,
natural advantage and things like
strength and speed of women and women
need protection when they all say
pregnant.
You know,
when they're looking after kids,
they need society to look off to them
because they have something that the
needs protecting.
And so we've got a whole and Inca
society.
The reason you can tell that these are
actually social constructs,
it's because every site is different.
I mean,
in Saudi Arabia,
the men walk in front,
the women walk behind and they keep
their heads down and get and then they
shut the fuck up.
That's a social construct.
And that's agenda role,
you know?
Right.
But that's a cultural,
that's a gender role.
And that's my point.
You know,
for us,
we don't do it.
But it's not just necessarily,
I mean it's not like a,
so like a social construct,
meaning that this is something that
occurs all the time.
Even in primates.
I mean there's a lot of behavior that
males exhibit in nature.
Not saying there's no relation to
biology,
but saying the they,
is it a social construct?
Well,
it's,
it's a behavior that we have.
It's,
it's not like something that's
consistent,
like,
you know,
oh,
the old man [inaudible] the Dicks is not
a social construct.
Right,
right.
Every,
every man on earth does this,
but not every woman on earth has to walk
behind her man,
suddenly 10 paces back because she's
female in the West.
It's actually know the other way,
you know,
the amount of opens door,
the wind goes,
Whoa,
there's agenda role,
but it's not the same.
So it can be changed.
It is a social construct,
but that doesn't mean that that isn't
agenda role.
There is always a gender role.
It's always informed by biology because
men and women are fundamentally
different and they always will be.
Well,
that's where people get slippery with
you,
right?
That's where they want.
Are they like in that way,
they like it in that way.
What is that?
Who's the one feminist?
There's one really nutty young lady who
was saying that,
um,
even physical strength is just because
men are encouraged to do physical
things.
Are you referring to um,
uh,
one and suck he's in?
Is that her?
Did she?
She's definitely said that.
Did she say that?
Yeah.
Oh,
come on.
I know she's loony,
but did she go that far?
There is a school of feminist thought
that thinks this they the the,
Oh,
that's a fun one.
They really believe that the physical
strength differences between men and
women are just because of the way
society treats women and as men are
socialized to do sports.
I'm thinking,
come on,
that can't be real.
She just thinks that she said it.
I didn't know whether she believes and
see if he can find that.
She'd say she's from a video from like
2013 or something.
She seems quite the opportunist.
Wow.
She on the trust and verify galactic
counsel,
what she seth and he was,
which was probably one of your wives and
reasons Jack and then as she sent any
wells,
which is probably one of the reasons
Jack,
that I'm not verified you say she
certainly was.
She was still a,
I don't know whether she's still,
but I know that she's sending was a,
at least a contact for them.
But there's been a bit of an interesting
development with ms sockies in if you'd
like to hear about it.
Well,
tell people who she is.
Uh,
it doesn't even need no if I need to,
but most people don't know.
You'll live in a very insulated world.
Like straight ass.
My mom.
Oh yeah.
You momondo but with them at the
incident.
Yeah,
yeah,
of course.
You're mumbling.
Uh,
okay.
And he's stuck.
He's in is an internet feminist who
decided the off the off the making a
bunch of videos on our youtube channel
and late 2009 through to 2010 or
something,
uh,
12,
um,
she ended up getting a favorable
reception with the progressive
intelligence.
Yeah.
We're very feminist,
very pro social justice.
And they liked her patter because it's,
um,
pretty stock,
pretty,
pretty stuck in trade and it's,
and she was,
she came across as being very
respectable.
You know,
she's well presented,
she's attractive.
She's well spoken.
She,
she knows
her pastor.
And so they promote her.
They,
they made a big deal over,
she sounds like a total bigot when she's
talking about anything big it,
yeah.
Also because she'll just say,
well this is men.
I mean the whole premise of feminism is
that men are oppressing women and if men
aren't oppressing women than feminism
has no argument and they also have a
sort of thing they say to each other,
you have the rights to hate,
your oppressor is right to do this.
And it's like,
okay,
but I don't think it's have a right to
hate even if you want.
But this is something that she said
personally,
personally over there.
She probably has said it personally,
but this is the,
the sort of ideological thought.
I mean if you read their papers,
if you read that,
if you read the new one that they them
thing again.
Right.
Okay.
They're talking about hardcore
feminists.
We are talking about like a specific
sphere of academic feminists in her
case,
sex negative.
Xix neg.
What?
Yeah,
they don't,
they don't like objectification or they
don't like sexy women in titties.
Sex negative.
Yeah.
They don't like sexy women.
And the male gaze is oppressing women
Croft Tomb Raider.
Gotcha.
Yeah.
That was the,
that was part of the big issue,
right.
It was like sexist because of Lara
Croft.
Terrible,
terrible oppression.
I don't know how women can get over it,
but a,
and he suck.
He's in stepped up and was like,
you know,
it's wrong to look at these tits.
And everyone was like,
she's wearing a really tight top for a
reason and she's not real.
Yeah.
Uh,
but yeah,
so basically any psyches and comes from
a school of sex,
negative feminism.
And she decided that she would take
advantage of all this.
Now in 2010 there was a video,
I think it was 2010 that the video was
recorded in black and white of herney
university giving a speech where she
says,
I'm not a Gamer.
I had to learn a lot about gaming to get
into all this and then come 2012 I mean
that that video wasn't released until
after she did her tropes versus women in
gaming.
Kickstarter 2012 May,
2012 she starts as kickstarter.
And when I was in within the first few
days,
she starts posting updates on that I'm
being harassed and said,
well yeah,
people generally react negatively to
phenomenal bigots on the Internet.
They don't like it.
People don't like him.
I mean like when you say men are
oppressing women and everything she says
is a variant of men are oppressing women
in it is the male gaze is highly
oppressive to women.
Toxic masculinity is highly or preston
women's.
Okay.
When,
when come in legitimately look at women
in eater,
no answer.
What is,
what is non toxic masculinity?
There's no such thing.
So what you're saying is masculinity and
men checking out chicks is just bad and
you hate it and the men are all bad for
doing this and there are pressing the
women when they do miss well.
That's why I said it seems like she's a
bit of a fight.
She's got an angle and she realizes that
there's a lot of attention that goes
towards that angle and she runs with it.
I mean if I turned around and said,
well women,
a bunch of miniature manipulative slags
who will take your money and run,
they be like,
you're a fucking massage,
but I got to stop you there.
Cause I don't think she's ever said all
men.
I don't think she said that she doesn't,
she just uses the term men.
I don't think she does.
I mean I really don't think says she
had,
that guy is her fucking head guy writes
for what Mecca is sad.
I know I'm just doing now nothing
basically the,
this,
this terrible thing.
But I want to,
I want to set the record straight if you
thinks,
because this,
this is something that really annoys me.
So,
um,
I went to vidcon recently and vidcon.
Yeah.
What does that youtube convention in
Anaheim sounds a good time.
It was a really good time for me,
but it wasn't,
it wasn't for them that their panels
look like a bloody death march when they
spot a sing in the car.
Their life faces like,
oh God.
I was like,
why did they get upset at you?
Yeah.
Just cause we sat there,
listened to what they had to say.
In fact,
if you heard about this dude,
I'm insulated.
Oh dude,
this is crazy.
So it's like easy.
And uh,
she spots me sitting in the audience and
then she starts freaking out.
Freaking out.
Yeah.
She starts,
she starts saying things like,
there's a constant harasser of mine
called me,
you know,
she called me a shithead.
It,
she called me a garbage human,
a garbage human.
I did nothing to her.
I didn't say a word.
I just sat in the audience while she's
there cussing me out on the stage.
And I mean this,
now she's on the stage with a
microphone.
She's just calling you a shithead and
the garbage human.
And this was because you have made
videos about her.
Is that what it is?
Because I've made videos debunking her
points and she,
she's under the impression that all of
my videos are about her.
And I actually on the ride over,
I got people to like count up for me.
Uh,
I've,
I've made around 30 videos and about
four years referring to,
and that's a lot.
No,
no,
no.
It sounds nice.
Did it sounds like a lot,
but that's less than 4% of the videos
I've made.
I've made 780 videos.
I work hard.
I'm sure you do.
But that's still 30 videos.
I don't care if you've made 100 million
videos,
you still make 30 videos about her.
That's a large number.
Maybe it's a large number compared to an
Ito who hardly does any bloody work.
But,
but that's,
that's another interesting point.
But what's,
what's interesting about it is if
someone puts something out there,
you know,
you going to get,
expect that someone is going to come
along,
especially a guy like you that is very
opinionated.
And if someone has very different
opinions in yours,
you're going to have a contrary point.
Of course,
there's definitely not harassing but
can't be.
We're in a scary position if that's
exactly what fine.
So how are we,
how will you harassing?
Like what,
what was the,
and that's the thing,
the worst thing you've ever said about
her,
that she's wrong.
Yeah.
Well.
Yeah,
I mean,
she,
you will never find someone who says
she's a,
she's a good critic.
She's a terrible critic,
and she always has been.
She's always been,
it's always been rightly pointed out to
her that she's cherry picked every time.
No one stands by her work.
She's become like a symbol of feminism
because will the harassment she's
received now that is a part of the
problem.
Right.
Okay.
Tim Culture,
it's very strange.
It's like you don't get any props unless
someone's sending you horrible messages.
And then,
because a lot of people have been caught
doing it to themselves,
which is really fucked up,
Eh,
loads like the black lives matter
activists and whatnot.
But yeah,
so basically she's,
her work sucks.
It's,
it's just bad.
I mean,
nobody in the
video game industry will turn around
say,
you know what?
That's great criticism.
Need to only,
only like the progressive press.
What black lives matter.
Oh,
he's just got a protest.
They basically run around and to the
university's compute system logged into
a fake twitter account or something,
send themselves a bomb threat and the
police tracked it down and they're like,
we have the video camera footage if you
yeah,
it was,
it was actually really funny.
Um,
but yeah,
it's so funny with their need to be a
victim.
Well it validates them.
It renewed just when you don't have an
argument and you need to be a victim.
Well does she expect that or know that
she's going to be able to put these
points out and not have anybody dispute
these points?
Well,
I'm guessing so.
And she always,
she always conflates all criticism with
harassment.
She's never addressed the critic.
And the first time she was dressed as a
critic,
it's me and she's calling me names.
Yeah.
That's how I go.
That's not sounding good level.
Yes.
Not,
not very good.
Good luck.
She said,
she says,
I'm responsible for all of the
harassment now.
All of it.
Well at least definitely not hers.
That's not her fault.
And then it's a controversial opinion
and someone disputes it.
That person disputes it.
Is responsible for all the restaurant.
Yeah.
Well basically I've,
I've always,
I've always said right from the get go,
don't have a contact them.
Don't ever contact them because for a
start,
I mean,
they don't want to listen.
She's not interested in hearing your
fucking opinion so that we're both,
she's got nothing but contempt for you.
But secondly,
don't send a harassment because a,
it's immoral and b,
she's got the victim card that gives her
money when she,
when you go,
when you send her a message saying,
Hey,
neither,
I think you're a bitch.
She goes,
Chich Ching,
you know,
and then she runs off to the next
interview.
We'll that she gets paid some of her
speeches at university.
She's been paid 20 grand a speech.
That's hilarious.
I'm not joking.
Right.
And it's just,
and for her to go,
the Internet is being mean to me.
Well,
maybe if you want to be in a bigger
online,
they wouldn't be.
Maybe if you actually did some solid
work and didn't say video games are
making everyone's sexist,
which that obviously not,
this wouldn't be happening to you.
But the,
the thing that pisses me off most about
the accusations towards me of
harassment,
apart from the fact that I've never
harassed her,
and if there was any evidence,
I'd harassed that it'd be all over the
Internet right now.
You know,
I mean you,
it would be nothing but twix bars
because they trying to paint me as a
harasser when I'm actually just a critic
oppose.
And I've always been completely against
it.
But what really annoys me is that her
kickstarter,
if you look at it now,
if you get go to it,
you can pull it up now and you can see
tropes versus women and like,
you know,
she's got to spill and then,
oh,
the terrible messages,
the harassment,
the harassment.
That was in May,
2012 I didn't make a video on Youtube
until July,
2013 this has been happening to her her
whole career.
It's nothing to do with me.
It's to do with her.
It's because she's a dick.
Everyone can see it.
Like God Guy Pussy.
Yeah,
I'm culinary Dick.
You're a dick.
And he said,
Dick,
he looked into the cam.
Do you know?
Do you want to know something?
I've spoken to a lot of interesting
people recently since I've been here,
lots of people who know you personally,
an eater and they say everyone hates you
because you're a dick.
Oh,
this has getting mean Dj.
You shouldn't see she put up about
me today.
Another one.
Oh yeah,
it's calling me harassing,
calling me all this stuff.
It's like,
no,
you're a dick.
Anita.
It did you find a video of her saying
that there's no biological difference
between the sexes and that strength will
be buried in the middle of this,
that he really,
I really think that it was her,
now that I'm thinking about,
I've,
I've looked at it as like maybe she took
it down with something,
so I remember seeing it.
I wish I'd saved,
someone's got to save it somewhere.
Someone on the Internet will be able to
tweet to ass or something because it's
so hilarious because it's so contrary to
biology,
just actual science.
Everything she says is contrary to
reality.
I mean,
she'll sit there and she'll pick out
like,
like the game hit man in her video she
said something like,
uh,
you're incentivized to,
to kill the woman then then stuff a body
in the trunk and the footage she's
using,
she didn't take herself obviously and
didn't credit whoever took it in the
footage she's using.
You see the guy go up and kill the go
and you see them lose points.
I just don't know.
That's a disincentive realization.
You know,
that they're not incentivizing you.
They're saying penalizing you for this
Anita Uj.
I mean,
I thought my very first video was two
and Easter as well.
You know,
you very first in like July,
2013 and I ice the,
the soulless started off because of her.
We were inspired,
well,
kind of,
but there was a lot of things that kind
of,
you know,
that were going on.
I was like,
you know,
I,
I feel the need to say something just a,
but apart from the quality being
terrible,
I'm bewildered at her.
I listened to it the other day and I was
just like,
wow,
I had no idea what was going on.
And I was just like,
look.
And he said,
I think you're just wrong on this.
I think you,
I don't think you understand like the,
there is a lot to this that you,
you've left,
you've left out.
I should've said Cherry picked,
but you know,
and that's,
that's something that's dogs are hell
creek because that's all she's ever
done.
Her Christmas was terrible and everyone
knows it.
Nobody likes it because she's a divisive
bitch and all she does is play the
victim.
She's got nothing she has nothing else
does.
As long as it's not talking about hurts
specifically because we're,
we're kind of beating her down here.
But it's hard to think of anything
genuinely good about her talking about
her.
I mean what I'm saying is about this,
these ideas instead of concentrating on
her as a person that had been debunked a
million times all over the internet by
everyone and their mother at this point.
I do.
I,
well,
why I want to get to what's interesting
to me is like what is causes?
What causes these people to group up to
these weird sort of echo chambers
reiterating things that don't really
work or make sense.
Like there's no biological difference
between men and women,
especially when it comes to strength and
then the tropes about video games and
also like,
here's the other thing,
like when that Gamergate thing happened,
yeah,
it was,
it was really fascinating to me that
everybody wanted to absolutely.
To lump people in one or two categories
and the two categories of people that
are appalled to it,
appalled by it,
and that think that,
you know,
sexism is a boren and all this stuff is
terrible.
And then the other people who supposedly
if you,
if you wanted some sexy images in video
games,
you had to be a piece of shit.
Oh yeah.
Like you sex negative feminists.
Yeah.
Well that it got into this weird
category where people like,
Hey,
we don't want you meddling with,
with art.
And whether it's a Frank Frazetta
censoring it.
Yeah.
I mean,
look,
if you look at some of Frazetta stuff
with the girls in the bikinis and
familiar,
but I mean how famous fantasy artists,
oh well we sold like talking about like
the [inaudible] earlier,
beautifully painted.
It's like these oil barbarians.
It's a celebration of the human fizzy
cause there's first perfect zenith.
Yes.
Yeah,
yes.
It's all Robert Howard's book on Conan.
And frazetta was like the most famous of
the,
yeah it was.
But it's very cartoonish depictions of
women,
you know,
like with giant tits and Brian blood all
over the place.
And it's,
it's silly.
It doesn't make you hate women.
That's what's gross.
Like just like looking at Fabio and the
cover of a romance novel doesn't mean
you hate men.
Yeah,
right,
right.
In fact,
it seems you're kind of lionizing and
look,
this is,
this is the perfect depiction of what
the artist wanted.
See like a man look like in a huge
rippling hero carrying the median or
whatever.
But it becomes this weird thing when
it's a man.
People don't have a problem with it.
No one says that.
It demonizes the male figure and that
you know that you have set these
unnatural standards so you fucked with
the self esteem of all these young men,
but you absolutely have and the same way
you do it with women like body shaming
or you know,
having ridiculous standards for bodies
for females that works with men too.
It's the same claims.
Yeah,
of course does.
But they don't care because feminists
dichotomize the world is women being
oppressed and the oppressors and it's
okay,
take your oppressor.
That's the,
that's the root of old feminist tool.
But that's why I want to talk about this
in terms of the ideas because I think
it's kind of the same thing as the right
versus the left.
And I think it's all like a symptom of
human psychology.
The right versus the left is tribalism,
tribalism.
But so it's female versus male.
It's,
it's these,
when you look at this blind allegiance
towards anyone with a vagina,
it's very similar to someone who was
blind allegiance to is anyone who is in
a red state.
I mean that's true,
but the,
the people in the red site,
do they say that the blue states were
oppressing them?
Oh yeah,
absolutely.
I'll do that for sure.
Oh yeah.
Well maybe it is.
Hey Obama,
he's a communist.
He came from Kenya.
He wants to ruin America.
He wants to kill it from the inside.
I mean,
that was the big narrative forever.
It's not them saying he's holding them
down.
Well,
there was always like a thing that he
was holding him down with the economy or
that he was holding them down with
obamacare and he was ruining so many
different factors.
It takes in America,
he hates America.
It doesn't sound exactly the same to me
because the,
the,
the feminists are essentially what was
called Neo Marxist and they take the
sort of Marxist dichotomy of the economy
with the bourgeoisie personally
proletariat through the American systems
and their wealth and apply it to men
being the bourgeoisie and women being
the proletariat.
Right.
Which is highly ironic given the
evidently privileged status in society.
Women hold,
well,
that's when it got weird when everybody
repeating that fucking wage gap thing.
That was one of the most frustrating
talking points.
Even Obama,
the Goddamn president of the United
States on tv reiterating something that
he knows is not true.
Yeah,
that was very frustrating.
because I just,
I feel like human beings are inclined
very naturally to form a group to stay
tribal and then I think it works with,
I think that is a part of what's
happening,
whether it's Neil Marxism that's collect
connected to it or what,
there's something that's happening with
feminism versus masculine people.
Yeah.
I'm an enemy,
but there's no like masculinist so he's
have to say masculine [inaudible] silly
though.
Yeah,
that'd be funny.
Yeah.
This apparently a feminism is,
what would you have mechanism that
sounds dumb,
doesn't it?
And they're like,
yeah,
well then that's how feminism sounds to
us.
Well,
it's the most amazing thing that it's
taken so long for male feminists to die
off.
Like that's finally like rotting away
after a few of them have been outed as
being creepy.
I was going to say that it's a honey.
I mean,
thank the baby Jesus.
They got caught because look,
man,
there's nothing wrong with being male.
And just because you're a human with a
Dick doesn't mean you're a bad person if
they think there's something wrong with
being male,
well,
we only do because they want to fuck
those girls and they don't have any
other way to fuck us.
Well,
I mean that's probably the roots of it,
but that's 100% of the,
ultimately you see male feminists,
yes,
they're going to win any fights.
No,
I know what I'm saying.
They gonna do they even need to shave?
Some of them do.
They're going to be,
they're going to be receding hairlines
and Fedoras and they'll like molesting
all over the place,
Jordan,
because instead of the best,
he said they're sneaky.
They had definitely not.
But they're afraid.
They're afraid of like men like you,
you know they're never going to compete
with you.
Yeah,
yeah.
But they don't have to compete with
themselves.
That's what they don't see that right
away.
They got fucked by genetic,
some of them love and got fucked by
genetics and so they're taking the only
evolutionary strategy they've got.
You can hardly blame him but they need
to do is get to the lab and figure out
crisper.
We're work on re reengineering yourself
to look like for the fucking gym.
That's what they to do.
Seriously.
If you're a male feminist,
just shut up.
Stop talking about feminism on the
Internet.
Look at yourself going to die.
It got on the gym and in a couple of
years time you'll be a bit bigger.
You'll be a bit,
if she's five foot one and you weigh 80
pounds on us,
you're fucked.
Keep eating sprouts.
I've got,
I've got a friend,
he's a quite short guy.
Do you know what he did?
He did.
Muslim is a nippy little guy and he's
quite strong in nippy.
Yeah,
no,
you can get around.
He can get around.
He's an amazing that we got to like a
boulder climbing.
He's amazing at it.
You would not believe how unbelievable
his,
his girlfriend is so attractive I
believe here and he's so self confident.
I should host a seminar mean this is how
I did it.
Yeah,
he should.
It's just self improvement.
You will kill yourself and then things
work out for you.
That,
I mean,
absolutely think that that's a good
thing.
Absolutely.
But I understand the motivation wipe
someone becomes a male feminist.
[inaudible] the word allies,
one of my favorite ally,
ally,
I just love that they are now synonymous
with creepy harasser.
Well,
you kind of knew it all from the
beginning that that was what it was
going on.
Everybody knew it.
Like especially heterosexual men.
You're like,
I know what you're doing.
You fucking weasel.
You know you're putting women above all
else.
One guy read his twitter profile and he
was talking about,
he goes,
oh,
in his twitter post.
Rather he said,
I'm going to stop calling myself a
feminist until feminists decide that I'm
doing feminism right.
I'll make women respect you.
But the fact that he put it out on
twitter like you,
you put that at like,
this is just like this giant white flag.
It's,
Oh yeah.
That's the thing.
You know,
people in general,
women being people respect boundaries.
There's the people who will enforce her
own boundaries.
This guy's literally said,
hey,
I have no boundaries.
You tell me what to do,
I'll be a slave.
No one's going to respect that.
You know,
I'll be a willing servant and keep
showing.
And there was just finding nice Douche
bag,
you have to say,
I'm going to stop saying I'm a feminist
until feminists telling me I'm doing
feminism.
Right.
There's a reason that they call them
cooks.
What does,
it's a good word.
It is.
That's a good word to know what it
meant.
I thought it always meant like a cock
hold like a porn film.
I mean,
you kinda did originally,
but now it's just kind of being someone
who wants to end up themselves.
Yeah.
And that's really good use for it.
Well,
it's also subtle.
It's not just someone who won't stand up
for themselves.
Someone who is pandering.
Well yeah,
like you're pandering to the laughter
pant.
You're trying to paint yourself out as
being very sort of hoping that the
person you're selling yourself out.
So we'll treat you linearly.
See,
so instead of talking about individuals,
what I'm,
what I'm really fascinated about is the
psychology behind what's going on now in
this culture of free expression.
Yeah.
The fact that a guy like you can not see
anything wrong with you,
but I mean the guy was just a gentleman
from England who doesn't have a
connection to the media owner can just
by virtue of your ability to communicate
and put out some youtube videos and have
some really good points,
you can have this massive,
massive following.
This is an n the these ideas that people
are spreading back and forth.
Even the weird ones like the Kec Stan,
the frog and all that shit.
It's just a Jag,
but it's interesting to me.
It's interesting to see what happened.
Like,
like what,
what I feel like is like Fox News and
CNN and even major networks when
especially all the ones that are trying
to portray narratives.
All the ones that are talking about the
way life is and you know,
they seem to me to be like these,
these huddled up executives at the top
of like a giant pile of crocodiles
snapping at them.
It's like they've completely lost
control over what people talk about.
They were on the spire of rock and it's
the oceans slowly eroding.
It's snapping.
It was nothing there.
There was no water,
there was no crocodiles.
The only information that got away,
I mean that was the only information got
out,
was through mass media.
Mass media was controlled by
corporations and we like for the
longest time,
that was the only way.
And they still operate like that's the
only way.
It's really quite fascinating narrative.
Hedger mooney social media has
demolished them and we're not going
back.
No,
this is not going back.
It's not going back.
And the,
I think the only companies that truly
understand that or uh,
Internet based companies that are trying
to manage it,
like whether it's youtube or google or
even Netflix,
yeah,
they understand it,
but you know,
they're trying to manage it in some
weird ways that like,
I'm really bummed out about Netflix.
Thumbs up versus thumbs down.
Like what do you know what you should
have?
You should have 100% thing.
So give them one to a hundred the more,
more range you give someone,
the better.
But up and down,
it's just fucking silly.
If I were going to review things,
oh,
do it.
Recommended not recommended and it would
be quite subjective to my personal
taste.
It,
it'll be able to see,
look,
if you've been following me for awhile,
you know what I like and I'd give my
reasons.
And I tried to explain it as accurately
and concisely and as objective as I
could.
So the,
the,
the largest sweep of people watching the
video could understand why I felt the
way I did.
And so the end of [inaudible] would,
would I recommend it?
Yeah.
And you know,
your mileage may vary or yeah,
you've got to watch this or something
like that,
you know,
but I,
I hate the star system.
It's like,
wow.
I mean,
you know,
it's,
it makes it sound objective when it's
not really,
you know,
sometimes it's objective,
you know what I mean?
It can be,
I mean,
he's not perfect though.
I agree with you.
It,
again,
with a lot of this little stuff,
it's about aesthetics and tastes.
So for sure,
I mean,
I loved the movie hardcore Henry.
I,
I like,
and I realized that I irrationally love
this note was the single person who had
the first,
first person.
Yeah,
there was a lot about it.
I've said that.
Oh,
you'll love it.
And I'm sure like it looks like guy like
crazy,
but it's,
it's not for everyone.
It's for,
it's for the sort of guy.
He's got a lizard brain who likes
violence,
lizard brain.
That's what you think about me.
You were an MMA fighter.
I'm a fighter.
I kickbox I did taekwondo and there was
no mma when I was okay.
But did you enjoy finding other people?
Um,
that's a very complicated question
obviously.
I know.
And did you enjoy for many years?
So I know,
I mean it's complicated in that I did,
it was important for me,
but I don't necessarily know if I
enjoyed it.
I definitely enjoyed winning.
But uh,
it is,
uh,
it was such a like how call him,
it was a task,
you know,
you'll like it when you get,
when you get past the sort of,
uh,
maybe the beginning of it is more
shaking the rest of it.
But,
um,
when you get past the initial sort of,
this is weird to look at,
you'll,
it,
it's fast paced,
it's action packed,
and it definitely taps into that sort of
lizard brain,
whether it's the male desire to fight
this guy at the end of the film that
he's,
he's literally in like a fist brawl with
like 30 other dudes and it's,
it's the most insane and he's just,
you know,
it's all coming at him and he's just
Bam,
Bam.
It's how get,
get stoned and watch it and get drunk or
watches.
It's just the best thing if you're into
that sort of thing.
But if you're not into that,
you weren't like it at all.
You wouldn't anytime an inch that
like,
I like John Wick,
he's not always,
you know,
but like,
John Wick two,
how about that?
I've never,
it wasn't even that good.
But,
uh,
the,
you know,
it's,
it's for a certain kind of person in a
certain kind of mood,
but when it hits,
right,
I mean it was the first film in a long,
long time that I was just sat in the
cinema,
just enjoy it with a smile on my face.
I was just enjoying this.
This was great fun,
you know.
But I,
I presented it,
it was just like tapping into the
primordial desire to defeat your
enemies.
I just thought it was interesting.
They shot at like a video game,
like quake,
first person shooter and stuffing.
So this vidcon thing that you went to,
who puts this together?
Hank and John Green.
And who are they?
The vlog brothers.
They're famous youtubers.
And uh,
I find it very interesting when Anita
was calling me a shithead and garbage
human,
that's a direct violation of that code
of conduct.
And did they do anything about it?
No.
I know because she's a feminist because
she's a woman.
Oh.
Because she gets special cause she's in,
he suck.
He's in because she gets special
treatment because at this point she's
basically become the avatar feminism.
If she fails,
I swear to God in that.
But I mean she respected in that world.
No,
no,
no.
Everyone hates her.
Why did they still prop her up?
Because she's an,
he's in.
If she doesn't make any sense,
why don't,
I mean,
well,
there's a myth os that's built up around
her and get word.
Yes.
It's um,
and they've all propped her up.
They've all propped her up level,
said good things about her.
They've all defended her.
And if it turns out that she is in fact
an abuser,
which she did according to the Vidcon
code of conduct,
which,
what is the code of conduct?
Oh,
I,
I can't remember it verbatim,
but I read down a video.
Uh,
it's one of my latest videos.
Um,
it was just a quick message to hank and
John Green and a,
I know that thousands of people email
them saying,
hey look,
she did violate your code of conduct
from a position of institutional
privilege at Vidcon.
She was on the panel.
I didn't have a microphone.
She had a microphone,
she's calling me names,
she's accusing me of things on true.
She,
and she was doing that while you were in
the audience directly looking me in the
eye and it was like,
okay,
that's fine,
but uh,
that's not right.
And they've done nothing.
They have done nothing.
They've said nothing.
You talk.
And then afterwards,
all I got from her fans and,
and I mean like,
you know,
hundreds and hundreds of messages and I
just retweeted them all night with
exactly the same language she uses when
she's displaying.
I'll look of the nasty messages I'm
guessing of people calling me eight
garbage human,
which is what she called me.
And so she has done absolutely nothing
different.
And so I said,
right,
hank and John,
she's violated your code of conduct.
Her fans,
she's incited a submodel of harasses
exactly as she claims I do.
But she has actually done this.
Then on the Saturday,
she was due to be on a panel about cyber
harassment c but it can't be harassment
when she's a woman and you're a man
because you are the oppressor.
So it's the same thing as racism and the
black person being raised against a
white person.
It possible.
The only reason to do this then to not
to take no action is if you are highly
ideological and interesting.
So you feel like they're high Dhea.
Highly ideological.
Yeah.
Incredibly biased.
But why are they,
if they're youtube stars,
I mean aren't they like don't they
understand?
They're very progressive,
very progressive.
But you're fairly progressive too.
I'm a liberal.
I'm not progressing.
What is the difference between a
liberal,
a liberal and progressive ones?
Quality of outcome,
quality of outcomes,
complete night and day.
It really drives what the problem with
liberals and progressives.
Wow.
This is by definition is that I've
always thought progressive means that
you support gay rights,
you support a women's right comes forth.
That's the outcome of gays.
With non gays,
they won't case that non games we case
to have the same.
I said,
no,
I'm done the wrong.
I want that too.
And this is what I was gonna say.
There's a lot of open overlapping
magisterial when it comes to these
things.
For example,
they're great word magisterium and I'm
getting,
never heard that before.
[inaudible] use that.
Areas of interest,
things that they won't have domains.
The worry of sounds so much better than
areas of interest though.
So write that down.
Jamie.
What's going to start?
I'm sorry to use that one.
Magistarium oh,
so glad I'm giving you something.
Yeah.
So yeah,
basically,
you know,
liberal,
there's no real argument against uh,
gay rights from a liberal perspective.
Cause liberals want universal rights.
Of course,
if some people can get married,
gay should be up to get married.
So it's the argument,
Oh,
I'm Christine get fucked.
I'm an atheist,
not argument.
Right?
Where's the progressive they wanted
because someone else has it.
Someone else has this,
therefore they want this because they
want.
And then whose definition by there's a
yours a year defining them.
That's what they define as,
you know,
they are the ones saying all this.
I mean like affirmative action is the
uh,
or example of this.
A liberal would never ask for FM to
action because in the liberal worldview
people should be free to pursue their
own goals.
Now,
I mean the liberals and usually very
anti racist.
That's not a,
that's not a cancer in which you would
judge someone him sex.
You know,
I would never turn around and say,
right,
okay well you'll see these were the kid.
I mean,
you know,
you clean know what you're doing,
but you've got some tents so get out.
You know,
that would be ridiculous.
You know what,
that's not a,
not a reason to do that.
Um,
but the progressive we'll do that.
If you're a man,
the progressive will say,
well I'm sorry,
we've got,
you know,
we want equality and this is,
this is what we define a quality of
different years.
I call it equality of opportunity.
They call it quality of outcome.
Cause they'll turn around and say,
well,
you know what,
we've already got like a 70% men.
So I mean you'll see you might be great
but you've got a deck so we can't take
you.
We're going to take that unqualified
woman instead because we need to get to
parity because they want a quality of
outcome.
There were 50% men,
50% women.
I have a friend who was a,
a big wig at a big internet company and
they had to deal with that shit all the
time,
where going to have men who were far
more qualified,
who they were getting pressured of push
out to make room for my,
like they were specifically looking for
qualified black woman.
They were like going out of their way
because they wanted to give out the
appearance of diversity.
Exactly.
But that's because they're also scared
of criticism.
Right.
So they're scared of being attacked for
the of activists and by race pimps and
there's there,
there are a lot of race pimps,
which is like Drm,
race,
Penn Plaza.
Yeah.
It's not mine.
It's,
they use it for Jesse Jackson back in
the day.
It's a good time.
And he's been outed as a race pamper.
I mean they've talked to people's,
like famously come to organizations and
said,
I am going to give you diversity courses
and you're going to pay me a certain
amount of money or we're going to
protest to the religion,
isn't it?
And they're in the priesthood.
Well,
it's people who like criticized and they
don't want it to hurt their business.
And when you get fun,
especially if you're dealing with an
internet business,
Internet based businesses,
you know like,
like,
like Google for example,
apple,
classically liberal,
right?
You would say bluegrass.
Yeah.
So very loving in in England,
liberal actually means and liberal in,
in the United States,
liberal means progressive.
Well though I hate all these fucking
arms is a nightmare.
It's taken me a long time to really be
able to hammer out the,
you know,
the ins and outs ideologically of it.
And so I can explain it quite
efficiently now because it's difficult.
It's really dark about something like
progressive thinking into,
well not progressive thinking,
but rather affirmative action is that
you're going to create a certain amount
of racism by putting someone who's
qualified in a position just because of
their color in it is racist.
You're,
you're,
you're being discriminatory on the basis
of race white person.
Yeah.
That's racism by a racist.
But you go to the deep root of it and
you've got to realize,
well there's some people that just,
they're,
they're given a terrible hand of cards.
We've got to be able to figure out how
to fix that hand of cards,
how to make it a little bit more
balanced in our,
in our cities.
How to make,
how do you do that?
I,
that's a good question.
There's one way to do it,
but that's where it gets really crazy,
doesn't it?
I don't know about that.
But if the people that are born in these
crime ridden communities and then get no
assistance whatsoever from the very
government that sending billions of
dollars overseas to assist these other
cops helping them.
Absolutely.
Not against helping him.
I mean like the,
you know,
I'm not saying you know what you go hang
out.
So you know,
but anything you do has to start with
them saying,
I want to change.
Sure.
And if they can't stop the,
if that's not damaged,
they're going to start with,
then you can do nothing for them.
Well,
they're happy where they on how they are
right now.
Then you can't change anything.
All you'll do is throw good money off
the bat and they'll know it that,
I mean like think about people who win
the lottery.
Did they,
are they happy?
Some of them,
most days they ruins our lives,
doesn't it?
That's what they say.
Relationships feel like the people who
write those articles are always sad.
They didn't run the lottery.
So maybe you could talk to shit.
I think there's probably a lot of dudes
out there that are just straight ball
and having a great time.
It's a new thing that you will have
value.
I don't know if that's always true.
Most of the time it is.
I think it takes 100 person and it may
me if it's like a super amount of money,
what you,
maybe you just got to ease into it.
Maybe it's one of those things and she
went $100 million and you just like,
pretend you only want a hundred grand
spend that.
But uh,
I got to start slow.
Don't get a Ferrari.
I'm not saying we don't have a Camaro,
you know,
you got to help these people.
But they have to,
you have to begin from a position where
they say,
you know what,
look,
I want to help because if,
if there's something going,
I don't want to change,
well then they're not going to change.
But I understand that.
But I meet a lot of them change,
don't even understand how they would go
about changing.
And they're constantly surrounded and
reinforced by all these people around
them that are in jail or committing
crimes.
Black Youtube is occasionally in,
a lot of them are like,
you know,
they do blame a lot of stuff on the
white man.
They said the white man will keep you
down and stuff like that.
That's,
it's not,
listen,
if this was a white guy and he was at
the Black Man's,
hold me down,
you'd be like,
shut up,
shut up.
You wouldn't accept it.
And if you'll get to accept that from
them,
that's you being a racist.
Treat them like you would treat white
people.
If this was white people sitting around
going,
I'm not gonna do anything.
I'm going to join the gang.
I think what the black man's,
all the Jews are trying to hold me down
and something.
Yeah,
you didn't let me finish.
I wasn't saying that white people are in
fact holding black people down.
I was saying that idea of the white man,
like they have this mandate,
we've got to hold the black people sound
probably dressed.
That's all right.
It's a standard argument.
I don't think there's a coalition of,
I know,
I mean without,
in the hedge.
Yeah.
It's a sad thought.
This option.
I think that there absolutely was
certain times,
I mean there's absolutely neighborhoods
at black people were not allowed to buy
real estate.
There's absolutely a systematic racism
and there was still a little racist
around,
you know,
I'm not,
I'm not saying it's not justified.
That's the thing,
right?
I'm not saying it's not justified and
that's,
I think that,
I think that's where like the argument
goes off the rails because they go,
what do you mean all this stuff's
happening.
Yeah,
it has happened and they're all racist,
but you don't have to let that hold you
back.
No,
you definitely don't.
That is up to it.
Yeah,
I think they need examples.
You know,
I think more examples and more role
models in that direction.
I've actually,
I've seen,
I can't remember the guy's name,
but I remember seeing this,
uh,
of this black doctor doing a speaking
tour at,
um,
was he a real doctor or a chiropractor?
Then all of the differences then
chiropractors aren't really,
doctors just found that out recent.
Really?
Oh it's real.
Oh yeah.
They don't go to medical school.
Yeah.
And that fucking crazy.
I didn't know about that until I'm
having her on the podcast.
The woman who wrote that article,
dude,
they kill people died from that and they
died.
There was some recent thing that a red
band sent me about some playboy playmate
who died because the doctor or the
chiropractor adjusted her neck and she
fucking died.
Fuck.
People die every year.
They do it to babies,
man.
They had just babies.
There's people that do like chiropractic
adjustments on babies.
Their bones aren't even fully formed.
Their bones are soft and these assholes
are manipulating them.
I'm really glad you told me that.
Cause I got two and a half year old son.
I mean nothing wrong.
Playboy model,
Katie May's death caused by
chiropractor.
Autopsy fines.
Scroll up so I could read that.
Fucking this nonsense.
I thought they were doctors.
I thought when a doctor tells
me,
yeah,
when you say Doctor Mike,
I thought it was a doctor who died.
You went to medical school and learned
how to be a chiropractor.
No,
I can't believe you're allowed to do and
don't settle down.
Ready for this.
The guy who invented it was a magnetic
healer.
Okay.
The guy invented Cairo.
The,
there's all this like subluxation is all
these words they use.
They have cleared a total.
Yes.
Entirely fake.
Not only that,
but the guy who invented it very
possibly was murdered by his son.
That's a suspicion.
His son ran him over for sure and they
think he might've done it on purpose and
then his son ran him over with a car and
then took over the business and his son
was totally shady.
Pieces of shit.
We'll call it a fraud.
Well,
you could have been an accident,
a tragic accident and the love dad,
but the allegation is that he ran over
his dad to take over the family
business.
It is not real at all and that is not a
real science.
There's no science to support it.
There's no it's,
but the crazy thing is it's so accepted
that insurance pays for this shit.
She had some clotting and went to the
hospital where they tried to do super
cheap procedures,
but she passed away.
So this guy adjusting her her neck and
they tore her verbal,
her vertebral artery.
Did you haven't look ahead local.
So no man,
when you're adjusting you,
you to understand there's bones in there
and as violent jutting if you're a
tender person or if you have some sort
of vulnerability.
Yeah,
model.
They tore her fucking article or artery
rather than article and subsequently cut
off blood flow to her brain.
Her death was ruled accidental.
What in the fuck can we,
can we,
can we give these people stopped somehow
scared.
If a doctor does is this is what
confuses the shit out of him.
All these guys that have called
themselves doctor.
When I talked to them,
I thought they were an actual fucking
doctor.
Like I went to a place like this is
doctor Pete docter.
Pete's going to work on you,
Doctor Pete's.
Dot.
A fucking doctor.
You mean?
It's a 100% fake.
The what is the article?
Pull up that article like chiropractors
are bullshit because I want to give that
lady prop.
She's going to come on my podcast.
Oh,
so she's a,
she calls herself the science base.
Yvette.
The science babe,
don't she has the PSI babe.
She sounds awesome.
Uh,
yes.
Pro-Science I'm very excited.
Very excited to have on the article was,
uh,
it was actually synchronicity because it
was a conversation that I was having
with Steve Rinella as a friend of mine a
couple of weeks ago when he was talking
about,
uh,
his brother has got some issue with
atrophy and have his arm.
He's been going to a chiropractor.
And I said,
I think chiropractors are bullshit.
And so after the podcast,
I smoked a joint and I was thinking
about what it was.
I being too hard on Chiropractors,
I'd be in a deck.
So then I started researching
chiropractors.
Yeah.
And I found all this crazy shit about
the fucking magnetic healers and all
this stuff.
Here's the article.
Chiropractors are bullshit.
You shouldn't trust him with your spine
or any other part of your body.
And what is her name that she wrote
this.
So we can give her some how do events,
Yvette.
And here we go d at Tremont
in Trimont.
It's d apostrophe capital,
a low,
low level d.
What does his bullshit,
not American spelling or possibly
Canadian Quebec call.
Hello?
Lowercase d apostrophe large capital.
I'm in favor of banning French as well.
I like French people.
None of the language.
The food.
Do you know the French?
But we could bang up.
Sounds good.
If there's,
there's one accepted form of bigotry in
England.
This is against the French.
So fuck French.
Oh really?
Oh,
you're allowed to?
Yeah.
How come you can do that?
Because we lost the hundred years war.
Uh,
so it's an England thing.
Yeah.
We spent a hundred years kicking the
shit out of French and then God
intervened to save.
Yeah.
Frances having a Ho well you haven't let
me finish this.
Talk about the doctor cause it basically
like I know that they're there.
They were probably gonna be a lot of
blind people who sat there going,
well holy shit,
my whole life I've been like,
I know that the white man's keeping me
down and stuff like that,
but this is,
this isn't all coming from me.
That's the thing.
I'm not the fucking expert here.
This is coming.
I wish I could remember this guy's name.
It was like a couple of years ago I
watched this guy doing the speaking tour
and he,
he was,
um,
a black doctor,
but he's like a phd in business studies
or something like that.
It wasn't like,
you know,
even though a chiropractor,
um,
but he,
I was,
I was absolutely loving his speech to a
bunch of kids in school cause he was
just saying,
look,
if you drop outs,
you won't get to where you want to go.
I mean,
you've got to look at it.
Just look at sensible.
You just look at it through in like an
Aristotelian Lens.
You are what you do.
Okay,
what do you want?
Where do you want to end up?
You will end up as a scientist.
Okay,
well if you drop out of school,
that's that goal off the table.
You can't just have a scientist by
training at school.
So no matter how much you hate school,
you just got to fucking stick it out.
You've got to get,
you want to do something that's
involved.
If you want to get,
if you want to get their scientists,
so you plot it on,
get her.
Okay,
so I've got to get to college and go to
know university,
get phd.
Then I've got to make sure that I've,
you know,
I've done all the right courses to get
to the right field.
You've got to plot the sale.
If you drop out at any point.
Well,
there we go.
That's,
you screwed your life plan there.
So you're going to have to figure out
something to do know.
I know because I did exactly the same
thing.
There's just no getting around it.
No one can.
No one can give that to you.
You've got to give it to yourself.
That's what empowerment is.
If you want to be empowered,
you've just got to go,
you know what?
Let's,
let's just assume the white man hate
shit.
Let's just assume he does.
Every white men just assume we're all
fucking racist.
Why would you assume that?
That gets a foolish thing to,
sorry.
This is worst case stone.
Let's think about worst case scenario.
Every one person's racist.
They won't hold you back,
but legally they can't.
So you might be thinking,
where I came,
I was going to be some bigotry,
so well you can do,
you're going to work harder.
That's the only way you can do.
If you get what if you want to get to
where you got to go,
you've got to work kind of living in a
paranoid world where you're done,
I want person hates you.
I'm not suggesting shot really even at
hand.
I'm not suggesting you should actually
do that.
Well,
I didn't bring it up because that's the
worst case scenario for them.
That's the,
that's what let's say the White Man's
trying to hold me back.
Okay.
Let's see.
Yes,
let's just take that as a premise.
Right.
Okay.
But does he actually,
you know,
he's not,
I mean they do actually have affirmative
action for your university and stuff.
So even if we still assume that this is
somehow owe him being racist and hating
black people,
you can still go,
well I can still take advantage of that.
If what I need is these grades in the
subjects go and get those grades in
those subjects.
In fact Yuma thing.
Well Christ,
I'm actually good for the great up just
in case the white man tries to screw me
even harder.
You know,
I'm going to work even harder.
You think?
Well Christ that means you got to work
hard.
Yeah.
You've got to work hard.
I love the term the white man is,
if they're usually white man,
the white man,
they,
they're not unified in anything other
than keeping black people down.
Like there's people brother down.
Cause you know,
I mean like when he gets to the
presidency clearly are like in dispute
over everything.
Yeah.
Like everything from top to bottom,
didn't the new center,
but it's the new thing that keeps
getting the woke centrists the
centrists,
the new center,
the,
the extremes of cancer and we should
just ignore them.
Yeah.
Well that's the center.
Sounds ridiculous to every,
it all sounds ridiculous,
but ask yourself,
would you rather towards the bench Pero
of Richard Spencer Bench Bureau.
Exactly.
We'd rather talk to me or need suck.
He's in.
Well maybe not need somebody to talk to
her.
Okay.
She's bad example route me or someone
who says that,
you know,
all white people oppressing our black
people.
I always want to talk to someone who
like has these extreme beliefs.
Like I believe she doesn't mean people
that go on.
I want to know like what goes on in her
head.
I want to know why she thinks that
there's something wrong with being
mailed to the point where like every
male has toxic.
I mean I'm talking about for the plug
political candidates,
you know,
would you rather,
would you rather have two people who are
relatively moderate,
relatively close to the center you're
talking about political candidates took,
yeah.
Sorry,
I should specified you get there.
Well,
because that's the,
the whole,
the,
the center is the political sphere is
it?
I see.
I feel like it's an ideology more than
it is a political,
how you live your life more than how you
vote.
Yeah.
It's not like a,
an ideology in and of itself and you've
got like center left center,
right?
They've got similar but different
ideological traditions and I mean it's
like it's basically the,
the problem is when you say it's someone
else's fault,
that's the worst thing you can do
because you're disempowering yourself.
Except when it clearly is someone
else's.
Sometimes it is.
Sometimes it does,
but most of the time it's not.
Most of the time it's your own fault.
Yeah.
Like the victim mentality that you were
talking about when we're talking about
like hardcore feminists that are
constantly blame men for thing.
But the problem is like what is it like
being a chick?
It's probably fucking terrible.
It's probably,
and not always,
I mean in the terms when the term that
you didn't let me finish.
Fuck.
What I'm saying is when women are
constantly worried about being victims,
right?
Like women are worried.
Yeah.
You show him.
I've talked to some that talked about
like driving home,
they're scared.
They get nervous when they're walking
into certain areas at night.
And the way that a man doesn't.
This is interesting cause that's the
same opinion that Saudi Arabians,
half of the West,
the house would you mean you've given me
the feminist narrative that all women
are constantly afraid of men?
No,
I think a lot of women are though.
But I'm not saying they're not,
but like you know,
let you know when you say right,
the other women talk to women are afraid
of men.
That's also a feminist narrative.
That's also the Wahhabi narrative from
Saudi Arabia.
And that's why they have to go,
well that means all women aren't allowed
out and they go wet burgers.
They can't.
They've got to reflect.
We become invisible.
So I men aren't going to predict.
We have a very ancient culture and in
that culture,
women are treated ridiculously different
than what you need.
They don't Wahhabism arrived in the 18th
century with Abdul Wahab.
Uh,
an old 1700.
That's pretty ancient to an American.
Yeah.
And not to anyone.
I'm American man.
Okay.
But I'm not a snitch culture.
My point is old as fuck.
My point is,
okay,
the point 1776.
Yeah,
exactly.
Is this,
none of this was what like 17,
18 or something like that.
But see it's older by four years.
This country is older.
By four years,
country exist.
Not the full 70,
76.
It just wasn't worth nothing I'm saying
existed.
It's the same people here,
a bunch of fucking campers hundreds of
years before that.
Like the people that walk the
Appalachian trail.
I have so many,
but this is way newer and way more
cancerous as well.
There's a lot of great stuff about point
being there is a very different
classification of women versus men in,
in Wahhabi Islam.
Right?
It's the same theory behind it.
They say exactly the same woods.
What do you mean?
Yeah.
But some women are,
I mean like in certain circumstances,
what I'm trying to get at is that the
way women think about men,
it's very different than the way men
think about women.
A man does not walk to a group of women
and worry about being raped.
A man does not walk through the streets
at night and worry.
Some woman's going to come out of the
darkness and grab his ass,
but a woman doesn't walk into a
courthouse,
a divorce proceeding and think,
I'm gonna lose everything.
That's true.
Unless you're Roseanne and you're dating
Tom Arnold,
right?
Boom.
She's still paying that again,
one for the team,
except for that one exception that
proves the rule.
Then 90% of the time,
the woman,
I mean not,
I mean you,
you hit horrific.
So he told some of the,
you get some horror stories where,
I mean the women's men's rights
activists,
I know these terms,
I'm immersed in it all day,
but people aren't.
They listen,
people that have listened to us,
a lot of them are not getting your ass
off the sofa.
Stop watching tv or go online and just
be immersed in that world.
Now go outside.
No.
Why?
You don't have to be an,
you don't have to be knowing that Mra
thousands of pounds to come here to tell
you what an MRI.
The other thing is this thing,
right?
This is,
this is on the,
I say this with the greatest respect
from the more venerable generations,
the mine who are more used to the
television.
People don't watch TV anymore and they
won't get back to it.
Yeah,
I think you're right.
I think it's dying and we've got the
statistics to prove it.
I've done videos on it.
We've got all the stuff,
the sources in the stats.
It's only the older generations.
I mean like in Britain,
all of the TV channels,
channel full was the young hip,
cool TV channel when I was young,
the average age of the vns 44 well,
once they found out that old dude had
been fucking kids for all those years,
Jimmy savile think that lost a lot of
faith.
That's not the reason there's TV
watching.
This isn't,
that's not the reason.
The reason is it's not the real Jesus
Christ.
Sorry,
sorry.
Yeah.
You got to say,
I've been dealing with some people who
were fucking idiots.
I get it.
You know,
and I've,
I've had to be like really,
really specific because they were there.
There was a group of people online who
know that I'm right and they don't like
that I'm right.
They don't like you.
Right?
Oh No,
they hate that.
I'm right.
We're talking about Anita Sarkeesian
again,
have fun.
They hate me and I don't want to give
them anymore ammunition.
Nice.
Sorry.
Bad that she's not defending herself or
she doesn't have the opportunity to,
she when she,
when she called me a piece of shit in
the garbage human,
I had said nothing up until that point.
She yelled back,
I just want to talk.
And she was like,
oh,
whatever dude.
And it's just like I came all this way
to hear what you had to say and all you
could do is insult me.
That was the rehash this Jesus Christ.
It's a,
I've been personally slighted.
I get it.
No,
I mean,
I think I'm being defamed all across the
Internet now.
There's a,
there's a narrative going around the
progressive journalists.
Those already been debunked by an actual
journalist called Tim Pool.
And the video evidence of the event that
I personally took that the ice storm,
the stage and started screaming abuse.
Or they're saying that they'll probably,
who was saying that journalists and like
the journalists like pull up of an
actual artwork.
Tell me an actual article that said
there probably aren't any yet,
but I bet you tomorrow or going on there
articles about me and some of them will
say something like,
I abused her.
Pause some hobbies and pause.
Do you not understand the irony of,
we're talking about people labeling
themselves as victims and you are
labeling yourself as victim of a crime
that has not occurred.
No.
I'm talking about articles that are
being written by journalists and videos
that are being made,
but they have not been made yet.
And then you're saying just watch.
They're going to be made.
Yeah,
but unless,
cause I've been doing this red.
Okay.
Do you not see it?
Come on.
You gotta be able to see that a little
bit.
I mean like I'm not like a victim.
This is something that happened to me.
But do you get that you,
we're just talking about right here.
Who is saying that you were stormed,
that you stormed the stage and you tell
me journalists and I say,
where are these articles?
And you say,
just wait and watch the moment.
At the moment we're talking about like
rumors,
you know,
for example,
like a it tim pool said that a friend of
his,
I think she's an actress,
but you know it's,
it's the same sort of,
okay,
but that's a la circles.
That's someone gossiping.
Right?
That doesn't mean that someone actually,
a journalist wrote an article about the
half storming the staff.
How do you,
why do you think they would social
media?
Why would you even concentrate on that
if it has not occurred?
I mean,
isn't this sort of like a little black
guy complaining about the man holding
you back when there is no man holding
you back?
I don't think it's analogous.
I mean it is.
You're talking about being a victim of a
crime that hasn't occurred.
No,
but I knew what these people are like up
in dealing with them for long enough.
Now I know what those white people are
like,
man,
I've been dealing with them my whole
life.
Yeah.
But when we actually have a precedent
for them doing this as well.
Right.
But they're not doing it right now.
And you're saying they are,
they are their own social media right
now.
I mean like you go like generalists like
Ian Miles Chung who said,
right.
So the prevailing narrative among
journalists at the moment is that song
gone stone stage and abused.
The knees suck.
He's in one video.
Evidence says the exact,
this is something that she posted
online.
Yeah,
he posted,
there's no articles,
but there is a twitter,
you can tell that it's coming up there
at gun towers and then it was brewing
and this,
and this is how these rumors start.
And then someone starts reporting it and
then suddenly you get a narrative going
on.
I mean,
and I'm a victim of this because I've
got a large enough reach to be able to
say let's switch the video.
Cause I think people listening to this
who have no idea who the fuck I need to
start teasing is and don't even know who
you are.
They like there's a lot of people
listening to this.
I would like to get to more interesting
things.
Hmm.
Okay.
Cause I say you're an interesting guy.
I said look your,
you were a little wrapped up in this
right now,
which is okay,
I'm at the center.
I'll tell you what it was.
But you're a very smart guy and your
videos are excellent.
You know,
and you're a punk house of grain.
Thanks.
I'm,
I can't wait to Russ.
Who's Russ?
Your friend.
Yeah,
he's a huge fan of goes rusty's fanny.
I kind of wait to see you do like now
that you have this gigantic audience,
do you feel certain amount of
responsibility,
but it was half intellectual integrity
is the most important thing.
And the great thing about this and the
great thing about the way the Internet
works is that,
I mean,
look at the,
look at the people who are at the top
look like something like Cutie Pie,
man of outstanding moral character.
He who know him.
Do you hang with them?
I've spoken to him a few times,
but I don't need to hang with them
tonight.
Look at what he does.
He doesn't go around bullying people.
Doesn't go around lying about people,
right?
Doesn't he does,
you guys aren't doing charity and being
like,
Hey Bros,
you know,
and being nice to people and being
inspiration.
What happened with him?
Can you,
would you know that?
Okay,
well let's,
let's,
let's go over the actual,
this is,
by the way,
this is affected me.
It affected a lot of youtube people
where their youtube videos used to have,
um,
much freer monetization.
Meaning that for people listening,
say if Sargon puts out a youtube video,
you could have ads on that youtube video
and your youtube videos get a lot of
downloads.
Man.
I mean,
it would be very lucrative for you.
And then with us,
our youtube money was cut by more than
60% I think to retain 40% of your income
was pretty good as well.
Yeah.
Well the anything controversial,
anything having to do with anything
right wing is deemed not not friendly
for advertising.
Anything that has drugs in the title is
deemed not friendly for advertising.
It's like we've literally been able to
change the title of things and re upload
them and then they ads they that balls
just so the same content.
So what all this came from is pooty pie
who has an enormous youtube presence,
right?
Doesn't he have like 50 million
followers?
Right.
Holy Shit.
And he made some videos that the,
what is it,
the Washington Post?
Cause I would,
it wasn't Wall Street Journal.
Wall Street Journal.
Can I tell you about it?
Please do.
Because you,
I'm sure much did.
I did a bunch of videos on this and it
was the funniest thing in the world.
I love the language they use as well.
What's a scoop?
A scoop is a news story that other
people are not aware of yet.
And can you sign it?
You got it first.
So if,
uh,
if tens of millions of people have seen
something and then if I'm a Wall Street
journalist and I come along and I find
something with tens of millions of
people have seen,
can I rightly call that a scoop?
Well,
you can definitely call it a news story
and you could definitely say that people
in see that.
This goes back to what we were talking
about before,
whereas they have a hierarchy of
viewership.
Like what?
What is,
what is a,
a real network?
What does a real newspaper,
what is real journalism like in their
mind,
I'm sure the Wall Street Journal
considers themselves to be in the
hierarchy versus someone who has helped,
but they don't have 55 million
downloads.
They don't,
I mean,
there's no way if the w if no,
it's a street journal puts out a video
of a million.
Yeah.
If they put out a video,
if they got a vit,
a million hits on their video,
that would be a big deal.
Yeah,
that'd be thrilled.
If pewdie pie,
how only a million hits,
I'm one,
it'd be super depressed.
He is a much bigger entity than them,
but in their mind,
like a scoop is them the legitimate
media.
So pointing out something in the
illegitimate,
this new weird,
the city logos,
fear.
So basically pd pie,
he's a comedian and he makes jokes,
but he's uh,
like I said,
he's a man of good character and he's
parents should be thanking Pewdie Pie
for being the person he is because he's
talking to their kids and their kids are
gonna grow up being decent people
because of his influence.
But the Wall Street Journal,
Ben Fritz and Rolfe Winkler clan,
there was another one,
I can't remember his name at the moment.
They decided what they were going to do
is,
and I don't know who put them up to this
obviously,
but uh,
they were going to watch about six
months of his video,
go through and find any antisemitic
jokes that he had made.
Well,
I mean by definition is a joke.
So there's not six months.
Yeah,
six,
eight.
They sat together a video every day and
they got about and like two minutes of
footage or something with him making
jokes at the expense of the Nazis
effectively and they were like,
wow,
this guy's promoting antisemitism to see
those jokes.
Cause I've heard about them.
I don't know the actual jokes that he
said that they were saying,
but,
but here's the point.
Let's get to it.
They were saying that he is making light
of being a Nazi or pretending to be a
Nazi and that this is what's fucked up.
Like he was promoting antisemitism by
parodying.
The Nazis tried to explain to people is
that it's Hogan's heroes work.
There isn't a mel brooks a bit.
Yeah,
bit of an old antique Jesus Christ.
He must be,
oh God.
Just so you know.
Yeah.
I mean springtime for Hitler you could
say was somehow or another humanizing.
I imagine it created a lot of Nazis can
imagine if somebody made the argument
that Mel Gibson created Nazis.
That's how far we've come.
Mel Brooks,
what'd I say?
Mel Gibson.
Yeah,
he my website today.
That was clearly a fraud.
He had only ever think about when
someone says Mel Gibson drunk.
I think of him yelling about Jews and
cops.
That's all I a big bid.
And everything's crazy.
Fucking Jews.
Jesus smells the smell
poster boy,
right?
Yeah.
Well he is.
Well,
he's a serious like nine 11 conspiracies
the lever and yeah,
where's that Charlie Sheen,
I'll probably lumping them together,
but he got my pain.
The,
these,
these videos.
I'm,
one of them was the funniest thing
because they were taking,
and the,
you know,
the jokes were like,
like I'm there like 20 seconds of joke
taken out like a 10 minute video,
you know,
where he's just,
it's just like a cutaway skipped,
uh,
you know,
Wah Wah Wah.
I'm like,
you know,
one of them was a joke about how the
media takes his jokes out of context to
try and frame him as something new.
And they cut that out of context and
used it and it was just like,
well,
there it is.
Which is amazing.
It's incredible.
It's amazing that they had the balls to
do it and they would,
they would not only proud of what they
did.
They called it a scoop and then they
went to advertisers and said,
look at this hate speech,
but how do they get away with doing
that?
How did they go and collect them too?
How come no one from the Wall Street
Journal sat them down and said,
well listen,
this is definitely not him saying that
you're going to take something out of
context and then doing it.
Is it because of it is and then you took
it out of context and did exactly what
he's saying you shouldn't do.
That's kind of crazy.
It's mental.
It is mental.
It's absolutely,
but they feel like they can get away
with it because they're in the hallowed
halls of actual media and they're
putting this stuff out there.
Jvc,
do you define it?
See what,
see what you can be the terms of the
financial jokes that pooty pie said
there were supposedly the,
the funny thing though is that if you
look at their numbers,
they look like that.
The Wall Street Journal.
If you look at his numbers,
they look like that.
And what's so strange,
he's making hand gestures down for the
Wall Street Journal up for Pooty Pie.
And what,
what's so strange about it though is
that Peter Pie isn't that competition,
you know?
All right,
here we go.
Here we go.
Let's let some of them.
Great.
Let's see what we got here.
My name is Pia.
Whoa.
Okay.
So Dan,
27 year old
playing video games on Youtube.
Typical nuts.
Okay.
53 million subscriber.
You still 55 now Jesus.
The biggest star in the site by far.
If you go inside the stories,
scoop is better.
Let's get into the latest scoops.
So it's him.
This is the,
I think this is the one recently.
Some of his videos are brief,
including Nazi messages,
images of Edof Hitler,
and explicit antisemitic commentary.
So this is the Washington Post's
version.
It will follow the Wall Street turned,
or rather sorry,
following a request for from the Wall
Street Journal.
Disney said the videos are inappropriate
and cut ties to Pewdiepie who ran his
business cost of millions of dollars of
Disney subsidiary maker studios cost
pooty pie,
millions in a January 11th video,
Mr Blah Blah Blah,
feature two men holding,
assigned reading death to all Jews after
hiring them from a freelance
website.
I liked the editing.
So the joke is his reaction to it and
the fact that you could subscribe to Kim
Star who's like another big youtube,
but he was mocking it.
I don't think they would actually do it.
I feel partially responsible,
but I didn't think they would.
It might just be my sense of crude,
sense of humor,
but I think there's something funny
about that and I don't fire back in the
media for miss characterizing him about
it.
Again,
I think there's a difference between a
joke and actual like fucking death to
all Jews.
If I made a video saying,
hey guys,
uh,
Peter Piot here,
death to all Jews,
I want you to say after me,
death to all Jews.
And uh,
you know,
Hitler was right.
I really opened my eyes to why power.
And I think it's time that we did
something about it.
That's essentially how they're reporting
this as if that's what I was saying or
some shit like that.
It's amazing how popular it is with such
a shitty grasp of English.
He's Swedish apologists can camouflage
messages that may still be received and
celebrated by hate groups.
The southern poverty law center says,
yeah,
so if,
if the southern poverty law center
condemns you,
it's becoming a bit of a badge of honor
these days.
In the video since removed,
he posted a video of a man dressed as
Jesus Christ.
I love how they have like since removed
is bold and then Jesus Christ is both
really nice guys.
The Jesus guy.
Yeah.
What the F I want it to act upon.
God's will.
Don't worry though.
He stands beside God now he isn't.
That's all folks Jesus out.
And I wasn't the one who made him say it
or was it?
No,
it wasn't.
I don't think so.
He set up a go fund me page and his own
website so you can take orders from
Jesus himself.
And also can I just point out
this is not what I'm looking for.
Where,
where are the actual videos of him doing
the the Nazi shit?
That was it.
That's 100% it.
That's it.
Is there an article that led to all of
this?
Right,
but what we're looking at here,
this is the Wall Street Journal's
version of it.
Yeah.
So this is,
these are the clips and they said this
is the actual clips that they're saying
are the thing that shows him to be
antisemitic.
Holy Shit.
The W I thought it was way better than,
I thought it was just a little theo.
He got made off fiverr.
Yeah.
It's just him prancing around on the
Internet.
It's just,
it's just silly childish jokes and it's
all who see?
I mean how many Nazis do you think this
made?
Three.
Really?
That's how I got,
I think three is too high.
Just stupid.
It's like you don't,
it doesn't take a lot to like turn them.
There was the really bad thing about
this though is the fact that they didn't
put this article out until they had like
taken these clips and dobbed him in to
Disney and Disney.
Disney obviously new shit.
There's going to be a shit storm about
this.
So they tried to do this political
attack,
but why?
What is it making money?
Losing money is politics or not that
politics as well.
Yeah.
He mocks like,
you know,
he mocks feminism,
you know smocks social justice.
He's not,
he's not,
he's a liberal.
He's not a progressive.
That's the difference.
Why would they think that they could
just do that though?
Because they've got the power to do
that.
No one can stop it and you couldn't see
They did.
They cost him millions of dollars.
I'm sure they did,
but it's now costing them their
reputation.
I'm [inaudible].
Yeah,
I mean you can't just do that.
Like Eric Street journals.
They,
they took a big hit from this.
I'm sure that unbelievably arrogant.
Well actually do you know it was really
interesting,
right?
There was a off after all of this shit,
so blue over there was a bunch of polls
done of like 13 to 18 year olds and it
was really fascinating how you had like
favorability and what,
how well known things where and like
youtube was really well known,
really favorable with kids,
you know and then you had the Wall
Street Journal which was really well
known but really unfavorable with kids.
How do the,
how the kids know what the Wall Street
journalist because of Cutie Pie.
So now their strings with the Wall
Street Journal in this way,
the millions of people that are his
fans.
Exactly.
Well that's a big mistake to a guy with
a platform like that.
It's of this time when their voters and
their,
their reading you consuming news,
the Wall Street Journal will continue to
be there.
They'll continue to go down.
Beauty pounds still be doing well.
But what's the,
what's crazy is I never thought of the
Wall Street Journal is that what I
thought of the Wall Street Journal as
being like informative,
objective information about my business.
When if you asked me like what is the
Wall Street Journal?
That's how I've always thought of them.
So to see the,
see this video pretty shocking,
isn't it?
Well it is disturbing because there's
nothing there.
No.
They make the death to all Jews thing.
The fact that city did he pay those guys
to hold up that sign I $5 to write on
the side so he could go,
oh cause you know it kisses taboo.
Right?
He's just breaking it to be.
Exactly,
exactly.
If nobody had said anything,
nothing would come.
It's in poor taste and if you're
representing Disney,
you can't fuck with that stuff.
That's all that is.
That he's like,
he's been,
I understand,
but it's not,
my point is I'm defending I'm,
it's not evidence of antisemitism.
No.
Yeah,
no,
he's just saying something fucked up
because that's,
he's trying to be shocking.
Yeah.
He's just think that Hitler stuff like
Holy Shit,
there was nothing there and that's so
stupid.
It's just the stupidest thing in the
world.
And it's,
I mean this is the thing where I look at
the Keck stony flag.
What I love about this is it's a parody
of the Nazi flag,
right.
Of a swastika.
What is it in there?
It's in there.
It's silly internet stuff.
But is it a k in there?
Yeah.
Yeah,
but it's,
it's,
yeah,
it's okay.
I can't say when you,
when you have to explain any of this to
someone.
It sounds like a stupid thing in works
is Internet humor.
I love planting that you would dream
fly.
I know.
Isn't that great?
I'm,
but that's what it's supposed to be
exact.
Right,
exactly.
Cause that's how they come across to
everyone else.
It's like guys,
you,
this is how stupid you look to us.
Yeah.
To the North End.
And then we'll just see that thing that
somebody put up about,
uh,
it's a you and,
um,
Milo and a bunch of other people and
you've got a red pill and it says,
get in the car.
Normies we're going to save
civilization.
Someone's gotta do it like Watts.
First of all,
who the fuck thinks that?
That's really,
if anyone takes that seriously,
they're a fucking idiot.
Yeah.
That's basic.
But that's the,
that's the point,
isn't it?
It's about people who can't laugh at
themselves.
If you can't laugh at yourself,
then we must appointment.
But there's also so many layers to this
thing.
You have to be paying attention to it
all the time.
Like you to be able to keep up.
Like even I have to ask you questions
like,
wait,
what's that?
What's going on here?
Cause I'm not paying attention.
It's a,
it's a complex subject.
But I think the idea of this,
the thing like the southern poverty law
center of course came out and condemned
Keck,
Stan,
uh,
because they're fucking idea.
But it's not real.
I exactly,
I just check a stance supposed to.
Is that,
is that supposed to be all right though,
is no,
no,
of course it's not.
It's actually,
it's an identity for people who don't
want an identity because I'm not an
identitarian.
I didn't say it's very non binary.
Sounds like Latinex kind of.
Yeah.
Well,
that's none of,
that's,
that's exactly what it's supposed to
sound like when they say I'm a Latin X,
I'm,
let me talk to you about my work,
blackness and stuff like that.
A while to be a woke black person.
Well you can be a is donny was,
that's why this,
let me tell you about my work.
Blackness is one of the coolest things
you could ever say,
but that's the,
that's what it is though.
Cause when someone comes to you about
their identity,
is that okay?
But this isn't a conversation I want to
have with you.
It's not politics as usual and it's
like,
well I don't have an ethnicity or like
a,
like a,
uh,
an identity,
you know,
I don't play identity politics.
They played entity politics.
Keka Stan is a parody of identity
politics and every identity politician
hates it.
Everyone who,
everyone who gets into bed with identity
politics.
Yeah.
One of my blackness or Latina or white
whiteness or my Jewishness,
whatever it is.
Okay,
what am I Keka stylishness you know,
and they're just like,
well,
shut up.
That's not real well done.
You finally got it right.
I don't give a shit about your fucking
identity.
You don't give a shit about mine.
So let's talk about the issues,
the issues.
Dot,
dot,
dot.
So,
um,
where is it?
How does he stand now?
Like,
so he lost this Disney deal.
Oh yeah.
The Wall Street Journal or the
finalists.
But how many people were actually aware
of the real content?
Like what are you actually did,
but I'm,
what I'm saying is how many people are
aware of versus the magazine Article?
Oh,
it's a,
it's about the type of people who are
aware.
Because I wasn't aware,
of course I knew who he was.
I'd heard his name.
And when I heard the story,
I had heard a bunch of different
accounts.
I tried to sift between the two and the
middle seem to be that he was doing like
typical internet stuff being silly,
but none of it was really antisemitic
close.
But that's even milder than what I
thought it was.
These that's insanely milder,
especially when you're using the clips
of him saying if I was taken out of
context.
Yeah,
it's,
it's absolutely pathetic.
Um,
but it's obviously the,
the audience of the Wall Street Journal
is a,
the elites,
the intelligentsia smarts,
rich people,
people that don't have a good Internet
connection.
Yeah,
exactly.
Well now that we've got the best
internet connections,
but they're not going to live very long
because they're old PD pause audience is
coming up.
They're going to be the ones who were
essentially taking over the world.
And pewdie pie is the one who's showing
them that look at the things these
people are saying they're bad.
And you know,
because they're attacking me and you
know me,
I'm not doing anything wrong.
So you know,
you can't trust these people.
They are going to come after you.
If,
if they can go off to Pewdie Pie,
the biggest youtuber in the world,
then they can go off to anyone.
But it's really dangerous to frame
things that way because it's dishonest.
And as soon as you do something like
that and you make a dishonest
representation of this guy of pooty pie,
immediately every other thing that you
print,
I'm going to go,
well suspect guys already made that
thing about Pootie by and that was
bullshit.
Like do you add it to a lot of work to
make that like to to cherry pick that
that hard.
Oh they went through six months of video
and got like two minutes of footage and
it's hilarious.
And he does a video everyday.
So it's just like,
cause I mean you saw the quality of the
visual craft,
it's just,
yeah.
Was funded that the Wall Street Journal
funded that like that had to cost a lot
of money.
Right.
Well similar,
you're paying these guys by the hour,
they're working on that to what,
what's your bunch of youtube videos
maybe millions of people have already
watched and then go,
we look at the scope we've got and try
to find one or two Jewish jokes.
She,
if he was Jewish,
he could a mel brooks is way right to
that motherfucker and been fine.
But,
uh,
unfortunately for pd pie he's got white
male privilege so you can't do the
thing.
Ah,
well you have to recognize your
privilege.
Suture important.
Check your privilege at the door.
It's a,
it's a wonderful way for people to
control your original sin to tell you
yes it is a restaurant.
It really is.
These people are creating a new
priesthood that if you look at the
diversity officers,
I mean like in Britain and the BBC is
the prime example they've started,
I mean they actually have job positions
where they hire on the basis of race and
against people on the basis of race for
example.
Not even for like if it was like in
front of the camera,
I can understand,
you know,
I mean like,
I mean I don't like the,
we need more black people.
We need more brown people,
whatever.
But I mean I could at least go,
well I mean like you were saying that
it's good to have examples.
I,
I can,
I can accept that I don't like it,
but not the,
not because I don't want see Brown
people because it's discriminatory on
the basis of race.
But I can at least accept it for a good
conclusion.
But for this,
it's just a research position behind the
scenes.
18 grand a year,
you know,
making nothing,
but all you're doing is typing into
google and finding things and they're
like,
white people can't apply.
And I have to fund that with my TV
license.
It's crazy that white people can apply.
I know.
No whites allowed so racist and they're
wondering why the outrights are doing so
well.
Why,
why so many people just like,
you know,
get fucked.
But the idea that you could say that
like your melon content is
going to prohibit you from getting this
job.
Did you,
I'm sure you paid attention to the
evergreen state college fiasco,
Bret Weinstein.
Did you listen to Brett when he was on
this podcast?
From that time I've been busy.
He analysts,
he's a very shockingly progressive map
is,
and he's,
he's a super liberal and essentially
really Nepalese can all you man,
he's a really nice guy and yeah,
he seemed to,
he seemed to and the poor guys in hiding
now.
Yeah,
he's in hiding.
He is,
he like literally he had to remove his
family from,
from there and kind of put them in
hiding.
He um,
does the schools essentially almost shut
down?
Yeah,
they took over.
I mean the thing is chaos and now
they're voting to remove funding and
turn into a private school because
they're like,
you guys are out of your mind.
You can't,
we can't,
that's type of tax dollars.
But they told him that he should stay
home because they wanted a day of
absence where white people were not
allowed to go to work.
And he was like,
what the fuck are you doing?
I'm Jewish.
That not only that,
it's like that's racist.
And they're like,
no,
your race without the woman at one of
the women who was responsible for it
called his wife are racist.
And without saying that white,
what he called,
she called for it on a facebook post.
She called for white women to take this
racist white,
take her rice,
wait,
racist white ass out or something like
that.
Then think about this old hall or out,
maybe calling out.
The thing about all of this really
dangerous because at some point white
people go,
yeah,
okay,
but she's calling her white.
She's calling her a racist white.
Damn.
It just because someone doesn't agree
with you on something that's really
racist doesn't mean they're racist.
Of course not.
But it's dangerous to do this because I
mean,
if you're going to use this as a weapon
against the [inaudible],
this is,
this is an attack.
Yeah.
He's refusing to cooperate.
So they're attacking him.
Well,
it's a control.
It's without a doubt.
It's about control because this is 100%
about people trying to control other
people's political,
political,
and this is a political attack and if
you're going right,
you don't want to be a racist d at some
point the white people just going to go,
I guess I'm racist.
Did you see where they had the president
and they were talking to him and the
president was addressing these students.
They were being fucking completely
ridiculous.
And they told him to put his hands down
because his hands were a
microaggression.
And then a kid stood up next to him in
like a threatening manner and told him
to put his hands down and he put his
hands down.
They started laughing,
they started laughing.
It's clearly game.
They're playing ping pong.
They're playing checkers and just
bullied him knowing him.
But this,
it's not just that,
it's not just bullying,
it's like them grouping up.
It's theresa toward each other and how
he feels or he was saying that he
believes it's like a mass psychosis that
literally,
it's like a mass hysteria.
It's like people losing their minds in
this large,
losing the,
amongst all that being given undue power
that they don't deserve.
They have an end all of this pile,
but they're doing something with that
power.
If they gave you that power,
you wouldn't.
So it is some sort of a psychosis.
Absolutely.
These people,
uh,
that they've never been,
they're not being held to an account.
Right then I'll be told,
look,
when you,
when you earn power,
you Germany happiness a karate kid,
isn't it?
You,
you home power.
You have to be responsible with that
power.
And that's what a good leader is.
These people are just being given power.
They haven't earned it.
They've been given it and they are being
told they can't do anything wrong.
And so they think,
well fuck,
I'll do whatever the fuck I like them.
They're also told that like you can
always step up and talk about your
blackness or whatever and everyone has
to kind of shut the fuck up.
Like you,
you have like there's these carp launch.
Yes.
There's these subjects that you can sort
of do like intersect or,
or um,
uh,
inject your,
your race into or your gender or the
fact that you're trans or the fact that
your allies and marginalized in any way
Latino and you can kind of shut down
discussion.
And it's one of the things that you see
when this president is addressing the
students and the students step up and
they're asking,
there's this long,
it looks like a hostage negotiator.
That's what's fair.
They get up and they start talking about
their own individual identity and he
told you about the color of my skin.
That's not my business,
but whatever it is,
the my,
the fact that I have a vagina and the
fact that I would like to hear about my
exams and it's that my wife's going to
complain to be honest.
It becomes the thing,
you know,
it becomes the thing that you're
discussing rather than whatever the
actual thing you're discussing is.
That's the problem of identity politics.
It's not a form of politics.
It doesn't go anywhere.
It's designed to grind to the dialog,
to a halt and to give the person making
the argument control of everyone else
around them.
That's where it unjustly,
this person hasn't earned this.
Yeah.
That's where it is,
right?
It's like you have a total control of
the conversation now and you have set
like these very clear parameters and
there's a lot of that man.
There's a lot of that sensor.
It is not,
it's not healthy.
It's just bizarre that that would fly in
a university setting and have his lattus
or agrees with it.
Yeah,
the Dean,
some of them,
but also they don't want to lose their
jobs and students coming in,
you know they're going to change the
world or they'll click a mob that look
an enemy faction,
an Ami within these things.
And this,
this,
this is the reason that I'm so good at
identifying this cause unwell.
Really well read in like power politics.
I mean if you want to read,
if you don't know what's going on,
we need to do is read the prints,
read Lindt scan,
read Robert Greene,
that'll teach you how to understand
these people and these people are the,
I mean everything they're doing is about
power and control.
It's about,
it's about influence over what's going
on.
And at any point you can break this
influenced by just simply understanding
how the gaining it.
I think Jordan Peterson has got some
pretty unique insight into it because
he's been dealing with it for several
years and in a very high profile way.
But one of the things that he said that
he believes it's about revenge,
he says he thinks that a lot of these
people that are so active on campus and
they're,
they're in this fever pitch,
he goes,
a lot of them were bullied and pushed
around when they were younger and they
were socially awkward and not in the
good,
cool groups and now they want revenge
and this is why they want to label
everyone who plays sports as being some
sort of a massage,
Enos woman raper you know,
I mean that's really what it is.
Like everyone who's in a frat house is
a,
as a massage,
Dennis homophobic rapists like is no way
around it.
You're in a frat.
It's like the full,
yeah.
I like that woman who thought it was
okay to say that that guy who got killed
like that,
they would do coke and rape girls in a
frat party.
Like what?
Okay.
This is a caricature.
This,
I mean,
getting,
imagine if someone did a,
an equal caricature about a black man.
It's so racist counts.
Unbelievably racist.
It is racist,
but it's just,
it's also redefined racism and what this
will mean.
These guy's dead fucking got beaten to
death taking a poster.
It's all he did.
But you're,
you're putting all these straw man
definitions on this guy,
but all this guy did is andy young guys,
dumb thing.
I'm going to steal this poster.
He,
and he's dead now.
Like that's it.
It took the,
the fact that the regime,
you got no sympathy for him whatsoever.
What the Fuck's wrong with you?
Be Cool.
If he was Columbian,
if he was a Colombian American,
they beat him to death like that.
Would that be okay?
How would you feel then?
Would you,
would you come up with some sort of a
Colombian,
uh,
influenced that he's got that you don't
have,
and so he's got some sort of a Colombian
privilege,
but I mean,
how,
how is this not going,
not being hideously oppressed anyway,
he's been captured,
you know,
they'll take them by the North Koreans
had been beaten to death.
Yeah.
Then they will literally,
I'll proof that your white male
privilege isn't universal.
It's like,
oh,
you know,
if you're going to say that,
I mean,
you'd have to be a fucking moron.
Say that.
Because everything about the ideology
itself is contextual.
It's power plus privilege.
They're full.
It must have a context.
There must be more white people around
for it to work.
And therefore,
if we go to Zimbabwe,
white people are hideously oppressed by
that definition in Zimbabwe when the
white foam is getting the funds
appropriated by black African Pan monks,
it's sort,
they are.
Then of course,
they're being oppressed.
Of course.
It's not universal.
Of course,
it's contextual.
It's the most asinine thing to say,
oh,
it's not universal.
Fucking de [inaudible] also universal
what you were talking about.
I'm drinking up cause I'm really
dehydrated and don't worry about it.
I'll have to hydrate myself.
Apologize for drinking water.
I don't know why.
I mean I know I'm consistently doing it
and it's like don't worry about it man.
Yeah.
Um,
but I think it's also what you were
talking about where they want to make it
all about them.
Like here this woman has taken this
situation which is horribly tragic and
now she's talking about students that
she has to deal with that are white men
that are doing coke and raping girls at
Frat parties and just like this guy.
What is this a horrible generalization.
They can,
they keep making it the stories as well,
but she's making about her and her
classes and the guys that she had,
the clueless guy's that she has to deal
with in her classes and she's just
deciding that this guy is that without
any personal knowledge of him at all.
But she's a future.
We've gone and she's turning it on
herself and she's a victim because she
has to deal with these students and
these clueless white,
rich male students.
Fuck man.
I'm just saying.
His note twats out there.
They're a bunch of dudes who are
shitheads and for sure there are just
like there's women that suck to humans
that suck.
It has nothing to do with gender or race
or that's racist to categorize them in
that particular,
there's plenty of humans that are,
that happened to be white males that are
great,
that happened to be black women that are
that Ha.
There's plenty of people that are cool
across the board in every single gender
race of course.
How you treat people as equals and
shunts of the character.
I'm okay,
we send mean that's the right way to do
things.
That's the most disturbing thing about
this.
Is it a fucking professor who's teaching
young people is generalizing this
horrendous way and she thinks it's okay
because this kid stole a poster and what
did he think was going to happen?
What did he think was going to happen?
Jesus Christ.
When you're 20 years old,
you're not thinking,
how the fuck does this dummy not know
that?
How does she not understand?
Just just the science of the development
of the human brain,
which has been clearly established over
the past 2030 years.
20 when it finally,
step five is the frontal cortex this and
it's not even develops.
Kids do stupid things of course,
course unbelievably stupid.
And I have it.
I'm sure you have to,
especially if you have a deck.
There's something about being a dude
that makes it dumber.
My mom's like,
do dumb shit.
My missus light look,
you know,
I don't,
I don't wanna sound like a big,
but it's always men.
It's always men,
but I just want to impress women or
something like that.
It's,
well,
but let me,
let me educate you on something.
Please do at at,
and I'll put the wood.
We'll put the letters tw before it Twat.
Yes.
That's how you say it.
If you're going to appropriate a
language American now.
That's why we spelled tires and tire.
It's Twat.
Nice twins.
No,
it didn't say any way you want dude.
But I'm saying twice.
If I say it's flat and there's more of
US 12 zero view.
We stole your language.
It,
man,
it's ours now.
It's American.
Right.
Okay.
So in,
in the future,
you know,
it won't be English anymore,
but like Latin became Spanish.
So I've got like another 10 minutes or
anything else you want to talk about
anything man?
What do you want to talk about besides
our need?
Our sarkeys yeah.
Jesus Christ,
Bro.
She's going to be victimized by this
pause.
Oh,
she's,
she's already pissed.
But yeah.
Anyway,
by the way,
I need a,
I got no hate for Ya.
All right,
so I'm not,
I'm not this too.
I haven't gone,
I talked to you just about that.
Macintosh should come on.
You should come on.
Um,
Jonathan McIntosh.
Yeah,
grow up.
There's a lot of those guys.
A lot of those vampire familiars.
You ever see the movie blade member,
the vampire familiar and hangs around
with the vampires and thinks he's going
to get in and they eventually kill him?
Yeah.
Same thing with the 30 days of night,
except the,
the vampire familiars don't usually
sexually assault the vampires.
They rare those male feminist guys,
they really get that off.
I love the panels.
Will tweet.
Didn't,
he was like,
you know the,
the male feminists,
sexist,
sexual Predator is the sort of,
you know,
a Catholic priest must in children of
our generation.
It's so true.
It is fucking true and a lot of ways I
love male feminists.
That's just like the creepiest looking
mother fuckers and then it tends either
way if you're not that way
and you identify yourself as a feminist.
No,
I'm not talking about you.
I know what you're saying.
There's a lot of people out there that
really wants to,
they get locked into it because it
sounds,
it sounds right.
You know,
like,
oh are you free equal rights through him
and yeah.
Then you're a feminist.
Okay.
Then my feminist and you say it and then
people treat you differently because you
say,
because of they said,
well you've done a good job,
billy.
I'm going to pat you on the head.
You called yourself a feminist.
Yeah.
Why'd you define yourself,
man?
Are you a human like every good human
wants equality.
I'll ring good yo like many labels as
well.
You know why you're denying sexism.
Like,
you know,
like you don't have to be a pro black
ally deny,
uh,
or to,
to rather,
uh,
deny accepting any form of racism or
not.
That's a bad way.
Describe
it.
It's how they define these things.
If,
if the,
if they have a different definition,
if they say where it's structural,
it's a,
you know,
like,
um,
institution,
we'll talk about racism.
It's an easier way of framing it and you
say,
well,
you know,
I think a racism,
I don't think the structures are
actually racist.
I think that the individuals,
certain individuals within the
structures are racist.
Then what you're doing is undermining
their entire philosophy.
And if you're undermining their entire
philosophy by effectively
individualizing it,
robin collectivizing it,
then they have to consider you an enemy
because what you'll,
if everyone,
if you go,
yeah,
and then someone else goes,
you know,
that's a good way of looking at,
I don't look at that too.
And then a lot of people got,
you know,
that's a great point.
Then suddenly their philosophy is just
going to collapse.
No one's going to believe what they're
saying and they can be like,
no,
but this is what I'm being horribly
oppressed.
Never.
I was like,
well,
not really.
There are some racist,
but we deal with them.
We've got the balls,
you know,
we've got laws against racism,
we've got laws,
the affirmative action laws to bring
black people and you know,
I don't think the system is actually as
racist as you're saying.
I think that maybe there were a few bad
actors and when we see when we can spot
them and get them,
get them out,
you know,
then what,
how these people going to play the
victim when they get to play the victim.
There's real racism and there's also
real people playing the victim and
there's bolt,
of course there's real racism,
but we're vigilant.
Flat.
Where are racist?
Just tolerated well.
Oh the president now.
Exactly that.
The president,
that company's racist.
Yeah.
Well we're just going to leave him
because you know,
he's just like,
you know,
he sees all right.
You still didn't get jump and of course
he's not there.
He's going to be out of the door for
sure.
They frame Pewdie Pie as being someone
who may have been spreading
antisemitism,
which he always got some like millions
of followers though.
Well they did like two,
3 million,
but they constantly were millions of
dollars.
But I think ultimately it'll probably
balances itself out.
It's already gone in his favor.
Everyone fuck themselves.
Yeah.
But that's only because there was a
credible alternative media.
I mean like pd Pie.
Uh,
there's,
there's me and another youtube,
nickel,
crowns and TV.
Both made videos about what's his name
was talking so fast.
You want to add overall?
No,
it's just,
there's so much I need to tell you.
Oh,
I'm probably not going to be here again
and there's a lot you need to know,
man.
You coming back.
I'd love to know what I've had it been
most sleep as well.
I don't do anything.
But anyway,
a youtube called crowds and t crowds and
t,
he's a German guy,
uh,
Kraut and t o t like the,
cause he's half English,
half German.
Oh,
I get it.
Um,
and,
uh,
he did a video about this as well.
I did a video about this and p Dubai did
a video using the information as the
systems we've compiled to be like,
to do his own video and used us as
sources.
St Let the smoke got this information
and he'd swing out.
And I was like,
Holy Shit,
that's really nice of him.
But it's really interesting how we
helped him fight back because he's not,
he's a comedian,
you know,
he doesn't do all this professionally.
He doesn't know what to look for,
you know,
new one.
Why would he,
you know,
would,
you wouldn't expend too,
but luckily this was a house speciality.
We've been going,
it's the media since day one because we
know there are a bunch of liars.
We know they are.
Some of them are right.
There's gotta be not all of them.
There's got to be good journalists.
That's no excuse.
So you now have a platform where the
Wall Street Journal,
if you want to maintain your reputation,
you don't publish shit like that.
Unaccepted.
What is their response that then Kevin
don't address it.
That's why.
Should,
that seems so crazy.
That's it.
They can't,
they should address that.
Absolutely.
The ship.
I mean there's no sue them and now I
don't think he sued them.
Why?
I don't know.
I don't think he wants the trouble.
If he sued the monk back in,
I believe,
dude,
you think you would win?
Oh God.
Can't see how he could lose,
you know,
what can you prove they cost you money
easily?
Yeah.
Is this actual antisemitism?
Obviously not.
Yeah.
Did they take you out of context?
Clearly and in fact,
what are the jokes was that they would
take him out of context?
How could he lose this?
Yeah.
Well some it is possible.
What he should do is find out how much
the Wall Street Journal cost to buy and
then crowdfunded and I donate to that.
I spread it around.
Yeah.
What was the,
there was a lawsuit,
recent lawsuit that I couldn't believe
was thrown out.
God Damn it.
And I can't remember it now,
Eh.
And I remember laying a few hundred
million dollars,
but like,
I mean he's got 55 million subscribers
and he's a very influential man.
Then there are a lot of people who like
him who would love to support.
Maybe it's possible.
Maybe he could,
maybe he could speak to,
I know some nice wealthy benefactors who
are like,
you know what?
I hate these people.
Like Peter Teal Guy,
what he did with Hulk Hogan versus,
exactly.
Yeah.
Why not?
Wouldn't it just be the funniest thing
in the world?
CPD pies,
the owner of the Wall Street Journal.
Just be hilarious.
Perfect.
You know,
and it wouldn't be the wealthy
billionaires who happened to be
obviously wealthy having to be watching
this and you know what?
We could get one over on these bitches
and that we don't have to just let them
win.
We don't have to just let them when we
could.
We might feel like the New York Times
feels incredibly challenged right now.
Jenna,
we were talking about,
I know the New York Times,
just making sure I was going to say with
you,
just,
you're just so ready to go.
I am just so much words,
unfortunately.
I know you don't have much time,
but about us.
Donald Trump was going to say.
Yeah,
I wish I had.
Was there any way you could reschedule
or schedule your flight?
Do you need,
I could just,
I mean,
if you want to carry on,
I could just cancel 10 if you,
I just want to make sure you don't get
stuck here.
Well,
I can just buy another ticket tomorrow.
Are you sure it will cost me a fortune,
but it's fine.
Well,
a fortune for an hour of podcasting
seems one over it.
You've only got an hour.
I've got another hour and Japan probably
more.
It's probably a thousand pounds.
I probably shouldn't.
What's a thousand pounds?
$1,200
will take care of it.
Really?
Yeah.
We'll put it on the budget.
What the fuck am I gonna do for the rest
of the day?
We're going to hang out,
man.
You're going to go to the movies?
Yes,
there have an ice cream.
Well,
I'm going to get a decision.
I don't know what you're going to do,
dude.
If you want to do another hour of
podcasting,
we can.
We should just say we were supposed to
start at nine.
We're a little late because of traffic
here is insane.
My wife's gonna kill me.
You was going to kill if you don't come
home think,
oh man.
She'll understand that.
You sure?
Yeah.
Mixed messages.
She understand she's going to kill you.
This Sheila.
All right,
so we keep going.
So where were we?
We were wasting money by buying the
wallstreet journal with Keith teals.
Money.
Yeah.
Well,
what I was saying is that the New York
Times feels very challenged by donald
trump's dismissal of them is fake news
and all these different attacks.
And because of that they sort of doubled
down on the ethics of journalism.
They tried really hard to be better at
what they do.
Yeah,
yeah.
I saw,
yeah,
they actually,
but that's a real indictment of the
state of journalism,
isn't it?
When they have to do is a little bit,
we're going to recommit ourselves to
actually being journalists.
Good thinking.
We'll stay in Houston,
New York Times called out in a way that
they've never been called out before.
Of course they did lose.
Yeah.
I mean,
he's the president.
They became political activists.
They weren't generalists.
They rise and they were on the losing
side,
get ranked,
you know,
of course you've got to suddenly go,
well,
okay,
hold on,
hands up.
I can't,
let's,
let's try not being a lie as anymore.
What does that trickle down from?
Is it from the editors who lost sight?
Is it the writers themselves that they
hire?
Is it the ethics behind the business of
the magazine or the of the newspaper?
Unfortunate.
I don't know the ins and outs of the,
I mean if he had a Spec,
I don't know.
If I had to speculate,
I'd probably say it's coming from the
top and they're just like,
what the fuck is happening?
Right.
Like we're seeing with these tech
companies,
like we're seeing with these people that
are like uber progressive in Google or
wherever the fuck they are.
Yup.
Yeah.
It's a weird thing,
man.
We're,
we're dealing with a real,
I mean,
I hate to use the word,
but it's the real word.
Cultural War.
Yeah,
it is.
I mean that's the term.
It's the correct term.
Block culture warriors.
And this is why this is when I turn this
in,
like power politics because they all are
attacking people that you mean like
attacking pd pie that costing them
money.
I mean they didn't even publish their
article.
The Wall Street Journal didn't even
publish the rascal before they had gone
to Disney and got them to pull them
money from him.
Wow.
Brought it to Disney.
How?
See how just because they heard that he
was getting this big fat deal from
Disney and they were like,
fuck this guy is cause pd pie doesn't
play ball with them.
Does he say ball and how so?
He's not a progressive but oh he's a
liberal.
He doesn't sit there going,
oh well you know feminism's good idea
guys.
And he's not,
he's red pilling the the new generation
about feminism.
He makes anti-feminism fuzzy videos
every now and again.
And they're actually quite funny.
You'd people should check him out.
He's just bragging on this cause it's
stupid shit.
You know,
it's the sort of stupid shit like we've
been talking about and rightly so.
This is bollocks and it's good that he's
telling kids,
look,
this is crap t just treat people well.
You know,
like just treat people as an individual.
Ma Ma say madame,
of course it is crap,
but I don't even think it's being sort
of like it's eroding the same way male
feminism is eroding.
That term is a very derogatory term.
We call someone a male feminist.
Most people just go,
Ugh,
if you call someone a social justice
warrior,
I mean that is a term now that term is
not something that someone carries.
There was a while where people were
like,
I read quotes like,
yeah,
we are warriors.
Like what?
Yeah,
like I mean the beginning,
they were like embracing it.
Yeah.
I mean it's not a an sjw on the Joe
Rogan podcast,
don't you let the number one podcast in
the world.
It's probably up there.
Yeah.
It's not an sjw sign.
Hey telling me,
listen,
let me tell you.
Let me tell you how to check your
privilege show.
No,
I haven't had one of those on.
I would be,
I would be fascinated.
You should get one on just to pick the
brain.
No worries.
Studio is,
and you have to talk to them for an
hour.
Yeah.
But I mean,
I can tell you what they think.
So I've spoken to him.
I mean,
so pete,
that's a cop out because the people who
have looked,
you're your bird show bolts was your
boss was like,
no,
actually I shouldn't.
I should just talk.
I'm just not interested in you.
Yeah.
Well you're creepy and weird and you've
probably harass someone.
So there's some,
there's some merit to having these
volatile discussions with people that
you disagree with.
Oh yeah.
I like it.
It's also people keep asking me to
Richard Spencer,
so,
yeah.
But I've told her stay wes already.
I know what the identitarian is
thinking.
I mean,
whenever every time,
like someone that camp black is that
they're going,
oh,
let me tell you about my blackness.
It's,
he's a youtuber called cab black.
Oh,
you're deep in the youtube world.
Oh yeah,
of course I am.
If you refer to him like we all know who
you're talking about.
Yeah.
Sorry.
But she,
she's actually really good talking about
call row.
Yeah.
She's like,
she's black transits you,
but she's actually great and people are
going to be surprised to hear me say
that,
but I've never done a video,
a bouncer because she's not full of
Shit.
She's just an identity.
Tarian but that doesn't mean that she's
bad or anything like this.
That just means she talks about herself
a lot.
Um,
but she's actually got this really great
streak in her that's really fair.
And so when the,
I mean,
these people run like lemmings off cliff
when they get an idea in their head
that,
oh my God,
yes,
we should all,
you know,
jump on.
Yeah.
You know,
like Lacy Green,
when she abandons their community or
something,
you know,
there was a lacy green,
she's another youtube on,
so she is Christ church,
right?
You're in youtube.
You should allegedly,
um,
who is a lacy green,
what does she's,
she's a feminist who realized how toxic
the community that she was part of
millions of subscribers.
Oh,
wait a minute.
Is she the girl that was it turned out
was dating some sort of Reagan,
some guy.
Who is he Indian?
Rj?
No.
Are you joking around?
But he,
yeah,
he's probably,
well,
okay,
well I don't give a fuck if he's
watching it,
but try to follow this up.
I'm going to talk to him later.
Yeah.
No,
he's not in the end Nazi on pc.
Jesus Christ.
What was his deal though?
They start dating like a,
he's just an anti,
he's NCSD WWII cheap.
Let me,
Oh,
he's,
he's pretty liberal.
Yeah.
That's what it is.
Okay.
So he's an anti s j w person.
That's what he is.
Yeah.
So what basically disaffected liberals
mostly.
And so anti identity people got mad at
her because she was dating this guy who
they don't agree with.
Yeah.
Because he's against feminism and black
lives matter.
Why does it,
why do people give a fuck who people
date?
Why is that a pause then?
Controlling psycho cultists.
Mm.
And they dragged her all across social
media.
I mean,
some of the worst things I've,
I've seen.
Really?
Oh yeah,
yeah,
absolutely.
And what did they talk about?
Oh,
like,
just so you know,
I mean like one thing that annoys me is
that like,
you know,
six months ago everyone was like,
yeah,
we love Lisa Green,
she's great,
she's a feminist,
she's a sex Ed,
stuff's brilliant,
blah,
blah.
And then as soon as she's like,
you know,
I kind of,
I met this guy,
I like this guy and he's actually making
some really good points that like your
sex ed stuff sucked.
You suck everything you've ever done,
suck.
Get out of [inaudible].
And then,
I mean she gets death threats and things
like that and she used to get them from
like,
I guess like I'll write a types who were
in the basements or something who hate,
but now again,
she gets it from stw Thomas.
I with people would just not send
threats and shit.
It doesn't do anything.
It just makes,
it's just nasty for people.
Well definitely is that,
but it's just,
it's so sad that someone can't just date
someone that they don't agree with.
Yes.
Fuck me.
Like she obviously likes the guy of
course is you can't change your opinion
either.
You're cleaning can't evolve.
It can't be a flip flopper yeah.
In like can you even control what you
believe?
I believe that you could,
but then and what did I just say?
Believe that I believe that I could
control what I believe.
Yeah,
exactly.
So now you don't believe it,
right?
Cause you've just decided,
I don't believe that.
Now I'm going to believe I can change
now.
Well I believe that people do change for
sure,
but none of their ideas is all like a,
it's not like a conscious choice to say,
you know what,
one day,
I mean I'm an atheist so one day I'm
going to be like,
actually yeah,
I'm going to choose to believe in God.
Do you either believe or you don't
believe in?
I don't think it's a choice.
Well I could see what you're saying,
but I think that when you're,
when you're going over the possibilities
of any subject in your mind you are,
you're influenced by a host of factors
as well.
How you physically feel,
where you are in your life,
what,
what kind of relationship you have with
your family,
like where your job is right now.
Like where are you?
I know a lot of people that hit the
fucking bottom and then all of a sudden
they became religious.
Do you think that that's a,
it's not a coincidence.
No.
It's like at that stage in your life you
needed to believe something and that
helped you and helped you to believe
that thing.
And maybe,
I mean,
how many dudes find Jesus where they're
getting their dick sucked and the
Jacuzzi.
Yeah,
exactly.
That's probably pretty low.
Yeah.
Right?
Unless it's like really bad blow job and
you just feel sad and you actually could
cause terrible at everywhere.
Anytime Jesus help me,
help me,
Jesus.
But you know,
people find,
they find love and happiness in weird
places.
They find depression weird places.
So it's really a lot of like what you
believe depends on where you're at in
your life.
It can very well be influenced where you
go one way or the other.
And then once someone has an opinion,
whether it's God is real,
our God is fake,
they fucking fight that to the death.
Like that is their stance and they can't
change it.
They can't move it around.
And if you do,
you're off flip flopper if he didn't
resign yourself into it,
then you can be reasoned out to it.
It's true.
Well that term flip flopper so fight,
it's so stupid because it's a more
chronic political term and really only
existed because politicians did not have
a forum to defend the evolution of their
ideas before.
Now they can go online.
Bernie Sanders as a fucking podcast,
you know,
now let's see.
Yeah,
he does listen to,
they can go on youtube or facebook.
They don't need to be in some sort of a,
um,
you know,
political forum,
some sort of a formal debate.
Yeah,
they don't,
they can just talk about their idea was
like,
this is what I used to believe and this
is why I changed my mind.
And they could do that over the course
of an hour and a youtube video.
And it's clearly as the mind could
decipher,
state their opinions on things,
but because people couldn't in the past,
like he used to be tough on crime,
now he's a flip flopper yeah,
you'll politics,
you know,
it might not be what happened.
He might used to be tough on crime,
but then he was given evidence of
systematic racism that he realized how
corrupt the police department is.
And then he realized that they have
mandated quotas where they have to
arrest a certain amount of people and
this is probably the best place to do it
because those people don't have the
money for legal representation and like,
so that's why my opinion evolve.
But you couldn't do that in the past.
So someone would just call you a flip
flopper yeah,
the Internet has changed everything and
for the better,
by a long shot,
I mean like we,
by the way,
this is not discrediting real flip
flopping.
Right.
Obviously if something,
if someone,
if someone's,
you know,
it doesn't really hold a position and
they're just doing it because it's a
popular thing to do.
Like Hillary Clinton,
for example.
Perfect example.
Clinton and trump own gay marriage.
Yeah.
That's the best.
Trump has been consistent on that for
decades now.
Hillary Clinton 2008 was like,
well I believe it's men and a woman
until 2013 it wasn't until 2013 she
finally came clean and when,
when?
When gay marriage,
right.
I didn't even know that there's not 2017
I believe that in this video of her from
2013 in fact saying that marriage is
between a man and a woman.
Of course she would.
And then suddenly,
oh no,
you've got to change the position that,
and she's like,
yeah,
whatever.
I didn't give a shit cause I'm Hillary
Clinton.
I'm here for the money.
Yes.
You know,
I'm here.
I'm a careerist.
I'm,
I'm going to be the first woman
president because I have to fuck Bill
Clinton.
All right.
I would love to read what the crazy shit
she said to those bankers.
And those quarter million dollar
speeches.
I would love to know the transcripts
that she won't release.
New wiki leaks is released.
The of,
I did not know that.
Really?
You want to do this?
She goes,
oh dude,
she wants some crazy stuff.
Like she wants some,
this is a hemispheric open borders where
like one hemisphere is just,
you know,
free and open and another one is free
and open and t to eventually get like a
united globalized world.
And you know the Anderson,
there's loads of stuff in there that's
just,
and she's saying how she holds a public.
The bankers,
she said that in the speech that she
holds a public and a private position.
Yeah.
Okay.
I did not know that.
They can't,
that Bernie Sanders ever discussed that
it was pretty since he's,
I don't know.
He's done.
No,
don't even a cook.
Oh No.
He's not considered Bernie Sanders.
Seems like a very nice man,
but he's a cook.
He's a bit of,
well,
I mean you saw black lives matter take
over stage,
right?
Oh yeah,
I did.
That was sad.
It was fucking sad.
Bernie a man.
These little bullies have got no right
to your platform and they're literally
squeezing him.
We are being reasonable screaming in his
face.
I Bernie.
Yeah.
As soon as some of the minus side,
it doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter.
That lost me.
I didn't approve of I,
you know,
I was,
I was at that point,
a supporter of Bernie.
I like Bernie.
I thought,
okay,
he's maybe maybe a little further left.
I'd be like,
I'd have to.
Good.
He took a chance and having them go up
there and then I liked that though.
I liked it.
He took the chance to let them,
todd and I,
I don't think they should be able to do
it,
but I think it does give you a sense of
who he is that he's like,
all right,
tell me what you want.
Tell me what you're looking at.
Then he's just like standing at the side
like,
Tony,
you're not a leader.
Me.
Well,
if he moves his hands there.
Microaggression.
Exactly.
We've learned that.
Not,
you know,
you should've had your boundaries.
I mean,
you didn't immediately capitulate,
so that was your boundaries.
You didn't stick to it.
Ah,
that's a good point.
You should,
you should've said,
listen,
no,
I'm going to call security.
You're going to be a school to the way
maybe we could discuss it in future.
If someone comes up to you and stuff
screeching your face that they're being
reasonable.
You draw the line and you stick to it.
You do not let that person bully you out
of your podium.
It's yours,
not theirs.
They've got no right to it.
Tell them to get fucked.
He's being investigated now they're
going after I heard,
but I haven't looked into it.
Financial dealings with his wife and him
and a small university where,
uh,
she made some decisions that ultimately
didn't pan out financially and it caused
the university to go under.
Oh Damn.
They acquired a bunch of new land and
they were going to expand the university
and they got a lot of loans and they
started construction,
all this jazz.
And apparently it just wasn't
sustainable.
And so now,
um,
I think there's allegations,
which of course whenever something fails
like that,
there's allegations that someone ms
handle something.
So they've been forced her to this
lawyer dump.
Um,
I do not know it's been the news,
you know,
I haven't really deeply gone into the
story,
but the,
the,
the basics of the story are she worked
for this university.
She wanted it to expand.
They got spend a lot of money expanding.
It didn't work out so it doesn't sound
on the face of it.
And like malfeasance was necessarily
involved.
The worry is that he used his influence
to make some certain things happen.
The allowed to take place perhaps while
I,
that's the allegation I believe.
I still think Rome,
polk and wind to be honest.
He might,
he's old.
Yeah,
he's waiting to open.
He's way too old.
They're always talking about if you're a
politician.
So old days because it takes that long
for trust.
You,
it's sad though,
isn't there like some guy in his forties
he's basically saying the same thing as
Bernie Sanders who hasn't liked any
stills still gets bonners.
We don't trust him.
Great.
He gives a shit.
We fuck.
Is this the thing that Bill Clinton,
man,
it really pissed me off site.
I don't think shit people do.
It's weird if it's because they can find
out about it and they couldn't find out
about it before.
So you got a guy like jfk was a total
pussy hound who people revere is a
great,
yeah,
we'll push the hand.
Supposedly.
Yeah,
he was smoking hot fire.
Who called?
Who knows the thing like why do we care
under a question?
And that's a problem with him and his
wife.
You know,
that's nothing to do with writing,
you know?
And it doesn't surprise me.
It's all great.
Men always get women flinging themselves
at them and okay,
there are many human,
if you've got some really attractive
woman flinging herself out,
you're going to go and we can just,
nothing's going to go wrong.
And that'll be great.
No one died.
No fucking surprise.
Right.
It's not a judgment on their character
either.
That's just them being a bit weak in the
moment,
you know?
I know.
They know it's wrong.
They know they shouldn't have done it.
All right,
well,
the culture is very,
very different and the culture of
politics was very different back then.
People knew about the president's
affairs.
Like what was that?
Uh,
who is the president that had polio?
who's the president had polio and other
one.
You had a wheelchair.
What does it,
was it Roosevelt?
He is he the guy who he's got the
little,
little round glasses and smile.
It was a roosevelt had polio.
I'd have to look it up.
Um,
anyway.
Yeah,
he was,
yeah.
Teddy Franklin,
Franklin,
Franklin Delano Roosevelt.
Um,
he had polio and um,
the press knew it and they hid it from
everybody.
They just,
uh,
no one.
Yeah,
it's weird,
isn't it?
Yeah.
I mean that was the thing with JFK.
That was the thing of Lyndon Johnson
famously held a press conference while
he was taking a shit.
He was literally taking a shit with the
door open in the stall when he's talking
to the press because there was like
boundaries,
you know,
they couldn't say,
it's kind of code of honor.
Yeah.
This guy was taking a horrible student
and Shit.
No,
no,
no.
Well,
I also think that once Watergate broke,
once you realize that,
hey,
it's pretty obvious this president is a
fucking liar.
And a crook and we need,
if we have any responsibility,
we need to expose this.
Well,
once you expose that man,
you open up that door.
Whoa.
People find out the genie's out of the
bottle and then they want to know
everything you'd want to know.
As soon as it becomes permissible,
whether they're saying it's up to
people,
not to camp,
it's up to people to understand that
look,
at the end of the day,
you are the person who is making the
difference and it's a small difference.
But if we all agree that we're all
making small difference than when you're
working,
I'm going to act in a way that I find
personally responsible.
If we will say,
right,
well we're going to act in ways that we
fund pestering responsible,
they'll just end up with the best of
worlds without having to change
anything,
right?
Yeah.
No heads.
Don't you think that today is probably
harder than ever the to manage like what
you're paying attention to and what
you're not?
Oh yeah,
we'll,
if,
yeah.
If you're thinking about like fake news
and like pots and I mean that,
that's a real problem.
The social media is like,
there've been
studies done that showed like,
and it's,
it's more on the left,
but it's also very much on the right,
you know,
like,
they're like 70,
60 or something like that,
you know,
but it's slightly more on the left where
people just essentially,
essentially get one political viewpoint.
And so that the,
the social media is just a stream of
content that's all telling you the same
thing.
What was the story that just came out
about a fake news story that costs some
company,
some untold millions of dollars.
Might've been even been,
they might've even said be $1 billion in
stock.
And it just came out today like that
sound that,
uh,
a company was extremely devalued because
of a fake news story that is a danger.
Yeah.
Oh,
it's a big danger.
Especially if you trade in the stock
market and then all of a sudden it
causes a cascade of panic and people
just start dumping their stock and
you're fucked.
It's all turns colby face.
So,
I mean,
the idea would be that it would balance
out eventually,
but if it was a fragile company,
who knows what this will damage that
could have done to them.
Did you find it?
It's a really recent news story.
It just came out like this,
the today or yesterday.
It's the flip side of like being able to
hold people accountable.
You know,
it's it.
Yeah.
You can't hold,
the Internet's fantastic in social media
is fantastic.
Youtube,
fantastic.
And you can,
I mean,
I think you could make real arguments
that these things are now,
but like critical to free speech.
I agree.
I mean land and there should be like,
this should be understood,
but on the flip side,
someone could say something that's not
true.
That's free speech.
Yeah.
Well that's,
it's unfortunate,
but it's amazing when you really think
about it,
how rare it is.
I mean,
even though it's fairly common,
you're talking about 7 billion people.
Even phony happened once a day.
That's still only one thing a day.
That's nothing.
But I mean it is up to everyone.
I mean like the,
they'll probably have to educate kids in
school.
We need,
right?
When you see something going around the
social media,
you're going to have to fact check it.
I think there's going to be much more
sophisticated ways of understanding
whether or not someone's being honest.
And I think what we're looking at now is
just like when people started reading
books that were written,
they never imagined that someone was
going to have a printing press.
And when people had a printing press,
no one was ever going to imagine that
you're going to put that on the
Internet.
So I think there's probably something
around the band right now for us that
it's going to radically change the
factual interpretation of information.
Like you're going to know what's real
and what's not.
And it's probably going to be something
that you're not even going to understand
what it's about now.
Like that as technology evolves and it's
bizarre,
an exponential way,
they're going to reach some new critical
way of distributing information and then
things are going to get very strange.
Just the way they're strange now where
we have this radical new ability to put
out content like you do or I do.
Yeah.
I think in the future there's going to
be another change that's just as
monumental and justice huge and it's
probably going to deal with how we
interface with that data.
Like some sort of uh,
uh,
but wearable thing or a mind thing where
you can recognize patterns
as being true or untrue.
Recognize humans is being honest or
dishonest.
Like you're going to be able to see,
you're going to find it,
man.
You could,
we're going to get to,
you know what people are really worried
about the lack of privacy now I feel
like that is just step one,
tell this ultimate,
very bizarre symbiotic relationship
we're going to have with each other and,
and technology where we're going to beat
inside each other's heads in a very
simple way.
It comes back.
It's kind of what I was saying about
racism.
Uh,
let me the sjws and like the evergreen
college students king,
Hey,
if you do this,
you're a racist.
I mentioned the SCA.
Yeah,
I'm a racist.
They'll just say it and it can then be
like,
yeah,
but you're a racing them.
But yeah,
I know what's next.
And they'll be like,
yeah,
but you're supposed to do something
because otherwise I'll call you a
racist.
Yeah,
cal just be a racist then it doesn't
mean anything anymore.
Final racing,
all you have to get consent to give that
power.
And if I don't consent,
like you know,
if you like what was a key I can wold or
whatever.
Who would the tentacle porn.
He should've just done it.
But yeah,
fuck you.
You probably watched him shit stuff too.
But they say,
oh my God,
he looks at tens,
couple and he's like,
yeah.
And you look at wall,
go on,
tell me what you'll pull them.
Watching habits are gone.
And tell me about your puritan
puritanical porn watching you just
watched two people in missionary for 20
minutes and then that gets you off.
Does it shut up?
Even if it doesn't get you off and you
can watch it,
you know,
like what if he just like,
what the fuck?
Like if you looked through my youtube
lists or the,
you looked at my,
uh,
history online,
you'd be like,
is that something you like?
No,
I was gonna to it.
The fuck it,
let's see what it was.
Yeah.
I don't like car accidents,
but I watched that motorcycle kicked
that car and the car spins out and hits
the barrier.
Then flips that other car.
Yeah,
I saw it.
Everybody saw it.
Does it mean I liked it?
No,
ain't no,
but you know,
a lot of it's technical.
Yeah.
Well there's something about that makes
me skeptical.
Wow.
He should've just done and it is such a
silly,
who is he?
I don't even know who you're talking
about.
This guy like a mold.
I think it is.
Who is he?
I didn't know this.
I think he's a right wing journalist or
something.
I don't.
Oh,
nick caught him.
Ended up tentacle porn.
Does that wouldn't,
I guess it was in his search history or
something.
Did you find that story about,
well,
there's someone that I know,
I know I have that devalued story.
Like someone said,
it was definitely something,
but uh,
but it didn't not,
you know,
but the thing is this,
this is the point in like if we got into
a future where literally everyone's
going to know everything about everyone,
then nothing's really going to matter
about any person.
I mean,
they seem like,
well,
yeah,
everyone does this,
you know,
you know exactly who does this.
So it's not gonna be shameful.
Nothing to be shameful,
nothing and be shocking.
Everyone would just know.
Everyone knows everything about everyone
all the time.
Yeah.
That's the real worry.
Right.
And they were going to become okay here.
Right here.
Okay.
The fake news.
Here it is.
I'll tell you,
I found it so easy,
Jamie.
So sad at your skills.
Um,
it says fake news of fatal car crash
wiped out 4 billion in,
here's the company,
e three m a.
E.
T.
H.
No,
that's Bitcoin coin.
That's like a cryptocurrency.
Uh,
that's,
you didn't find it.
Yeah,
I didn't know what that was.
That's a new one.
Yeah.
Oh God.
Okay.
So fake news of fatal.
It's on courts.
Um,
qz.com
yeah.
Wiped out that $4 billion in their
market value yesterday.
How the fuck they at $4 billion in
market value of a Crypto coin that I've
never even heard of.
No idea.
So cryptic.
I'd see what x.
So that's,
I mean it's still I guess as legitimate
as stock Jesus Christ and if there's $4
billion in value to it,
that's as legitimate as a company about
it.
Some legitimacy point being that a fake
news story wiped out the value of it,
but maybe now's the time to buy.
All right.
Well yeah,
if it's got no value and it's probably
going to go back up cause this wasn't a
real thing about it again in ground pool
dive in,
take a chance.
I didn't make it well that you got it.
What does it take story about the guy
that created it died in a car crash.
Oh everybody panel.
Then everyone panicked because the
creator,
God,
it's controlling the money in the market
of it supposedly died.
Well that didn't happen.
Oh,
okay.
But still hot attack for him though.
Oh,
by the way,
you'll stuff's going down $4 billion.
Watson.
I know,
right?
Can you even imagine the other weird
part?
It's not stock.
It's a,
Oh,
what's the value of marketing?
That's another one of my favorite
stories of the last year.
The Fan,
oh story.
That woman who was a pretending to be
the news female Steve Jobs and she had
the look,
so everybody went with it and she had
this blood testing procedure that
totally didn't work.
Didn't look into it.
It's a great story.
She was,
she was touted as being the next genius.
She dressed exactly like Steve Jobs.
She wore black turtlenecks and was
really hilarious and she gave this
speech to like women in something or
another,
but the speech was so like jumbled and
shitty and there's so much poverty of
words in our sentences,
like the,
the content was just so bad.
I was like,
this is a genius.
Like,
maybe she's like super awkward and
nervous and maybe she just didn't
prepare this speech at all,
but no,
turns out choosing massive fraud things
at massive fraud and her $34 billion
company vanished.
So the company had a product that they
were using where they were doing these
blood tests and a whistle blower from
inside the company said,
this person,
they're ignoring all the bad data.
They were ignoring all the failed tasks
that they're pretending it's much more
efficient than it is.
Right.
I'll do it.
Not only did,
did not work,
hundreds of thousands of people who took
these tests,
oh,
we're exposed to potential health
threats because they thought,
well,
this is Heston.
They know what I know where my blood is
now.
So you could have gone,
you know,
a more cautious or less cautious based
on this or got treatment that you didn't
need based on this or didn't get
treatment that you probably did need
based on this.
So,
uh,
they imagined the kind of person who
does that though.
She's standing there bullshitting.
I'm sociopath was at risk sociopath in,
in some sort of a way.
Um,
some or unless she was lied to too.
I mean,
who knows exactly what the actual story
is you've got.
But the,
the,
the whistleblower saying no,
she's absolutely aware of it.
And so now she's,
she went from being like the number one
self made female entrepreneur ever where
she was worth like $34 billion or
something crazy to massive debt.
Now our company is worth nothing.
It doesn't work.
So she fired a shit load of people and
the company still exists as an entity,
but it's,
it's like one of those really tortured
things.
There's lawsuits are flying around left
and right now,
but the whole story is a cautionary tale
and like what,
what we're looking for,
we're looking for this thing,
this new image.
You know,
here's this woman,
she's fitting the part.
She's got a black turtleneck on.
She con artist came along and played,
you dropped out of college at 19 to
start this business.
I mean,
she doesn't know.
She doesn't even have a background in
medical science.
She's not like,
she doesn't have a degree.
It's not like she's a phd and some sort
of bioengineering or blood testing or
whatever the fuck it would be.
Yeah,
it's a,
it's a crazy story because she was
saying,
hey,
exactly as drastic part.
Look,
the part said the right words,
confidence,
tricks to comes along and says,
Hey,
you're interested in a woman doing this.
I'm a woman.
I'm doing this.
I remember before she get exposed,
watching that video of her talking
going,
this not seem like a smart,
yeah.
If she's just like rambling along and
kind of disjointed or something.
It was just clunky.
Yeah.
Like pull up CV.
You could find Elizabeth.
Is that her name?
Stan knows what the fuck was her name.
I forgot what her name is.
Theranose was the,
what was her name?
Looking at pictures ever.
It doesn't say her name anywhere,
but you know I did.
I did hear about it,
but I'll,
I'll have to check it out some of the
time.
Yeah,
but it's,
look again,
this is,
what's that?
Elizabeth Holmes?
Yeah.
Okay,
so not,
it's not discrediting women.
This is not discrediting the idea of a
genius woman.
genius entrepreneurial woman.
What this is fascinating to me is a
person who fits all of these categories
that people are clearly looking for.
Yeah.
Right.
And they just boil into x is what the
answer is.
Identity politics.
Because confirmation bias,
and we love the fact that it's strong
woman is doing this.
It's amazing.
It's just true.
I'm with her Hashtag they went with the
Marine Le Pen though.
Where they,
who's that?
Oh,
the French woman.
that's right.
Yeah.
Well that's the thing,
isn't it?
Oh,
well you know,
I mean,
I know that she's the woman,
but I'm filling for Alexander macron.
Yeah,
but Yo,
I'm with her on you,
right?
Oh,
you know,
I'm with her when she thinks wrong.
So it's not that she's a woman,
it's the way she fucking thinks.
Why can't we just be honest about this?
You know that Merck hell ladies a trip
to,
oh,
Michael's cancer.
She's,
I can't believe the judge Germany get
rid of Merkel.
Well,
what are you doing?
What are you doing?
She's a trip.
When I know about her,
if I know who's running Germany,
the gentleman's just can't help
themselves.
What are they doing over there?
Uh,
with wall with her.
That's an Ma Ma Merkel's I speak to you
again.
My friend crowd,
he tells me about these things.
She's famous for her and I don't want to
say flip flopping,
but I would like,
I would actually be a little more
charitable than say her.
Um,
her navigation of the political wins.
Hillary in that way,
I guess why she uses is an opportunist.
Another one.
I think it's unfair to call opportunists
cause that's sailors really,
really,
it's being a smart politician,
isn't it?
It's saying well,
okay.
What,
I mean,
where are people going that's important,
that smarter anymore?
Well,
no,
I think it,
I think it means you lack credibility.
It makes you look like you don't stand
for anything.
Well look,
as much as trump lies and he's,
he lied all the 600 plus times in the
hundred plus times that he was in
office.
They did a count of all the times he
said things that weren't true publicly.
As much as he does that.
Everybody knows that's what he does.
Like they know who he is.
They know what he does.
They know he tweets all the time.
So even if he tweets something
ridiculous,
they know who that is.
That's that guy.
That's him.
That's what he really thinks.
That's why he's saying it.
You never got that with Hillary Clinton,
which you got is these weird boiled down
messages.
It seemed like they were put together in
some sort of a of a writer's room.
Yeah,
it was.
I mean,
she doesn't control its twitter account.
No.
Doubtedly but trump undoubtedly is in
control of his and 200% it's so
hilarious.
I thought it was hilarious.
She wrote to him,
delete your account.
Yes.
That's nice.
Legit banter.
It's good.
That was good.
Got to give it up to her there,
but I don't know who wrote that was
probably some 20 year old kid somewhere.
She probably wrote it.
Yeah.
Gursky's work at four 12 guys.
Who knows?
Yeah.
She for the social media manager at
Wendy's tweeted out,
pepe the of the Wendy's icon as a peppy
oh no,
shit.
Stolen,
absolute shit on.
They were forced to delete it.
And who knows what?
That person still has a job,
but people who think that pepe is
outright and you're saying Pepsi's not
outright.
They all right,
use pam pay.
But everyone uses pepe.
Pepe is a ubiquitous internet symbol,
sort of dissonance and chaos.
More importantly,
um,
disrespect,
but isn't keck like the god of chaos or
sensate up,
uh,
this little made up,
made up.
What I think is makeup.
It's like,
what if you die and you meet Keck?
Would you be feeling bad?
Cause you said he was made up.
I'll be quite surprised.
I'd be like,
okay,
you're going to have to work with me
here because let's be honest.
Would you have believed it?
No.
No,
but yeah,
that would be so shocked if he let her
gold robe.
It was a frog and you got to have an
oncology and there's,
there's,
it literally looks like pepe then that
he's got a gold robe on.
Can I piss off?
Like literally everyone who believes in
a religion,
why would you want to?
Because what about hope?
Doesn't it just struck you as in this
childish fucking thing that depends on
what I'm going to go somewhere.
Is Nino not scientology that that's
starting to make sense to me.
I can tell actually,
but I,
like I said up,
been watching but said no,
seriously.
It's obviously wishful thinking and it's
obvious because you're afraid of dying
and it's obviously that you just want to
believe it.
It's not true.
You fucking might just want that gold
metal and that is not true.
I want that scientology gold medal that
gave Tom cruise the big one,
like a laptop.
It looks like flavor flavor up there
with that fucking gold medal on.
Isn't it so arrogant to think that
humans are so important that they're
going to go to an afterlife?
It might be right.
You know the,
the afterlife isn't that arrogant to me
because it's the idea is that like
you're trying to just pass on life,
right?
And the mind understands that this is
sort of a few tile effort.
You're temporary.
You have a finite life,
you know,
like what,
what are you doing?
Why,
why even bother?
I just end this now you're constantly
suffering.
Just jump off a building.
So no,
no,
no.
We can't do that because there's a
greater good waiting for us.
There's a greater thing.
There's another level of the video game
that doesn't make sense if,
if,
if you're going to go to heaven when you
dunk,
kill yourself,
but you can't.
That's a loophole.
So you can't go to heaven.
Yeah,
kill yourself.
You make the people around you that
loved you suffer.
So you don't go to heaven when you kill
yourself.
That's convenient.
Or it's God's plan.
They kill you.
What?
Where's your part of the Colt,
Richard?
And I'm like,
you know,
we'll just gonna drink the Koolaid,
the prism cooling and kill cells.
Well,
they answered that with Jesus.
Jesus on the cross.
That's why we still do this.
We literally make the,
make the cross sign that the thing that
killed him.
B Bill Hicks had a great joke about
that.
He goes,
it's like going up to Jackie on the
assets with a rifle on.
He was just thinking of John Jackson.
Imagine if you'd like a pagan or
something back in like the seventh
century or whatever and you're,
you're,
you know,
northern European Lithuanian or
something and then these Germans coming
in and go,
hey,
we've got this religion about dead guy.
We think you should join it.
We blog.
Why?
Well it's,
it's really sad.
It's really sad story.
But he died for your sins.
But yeah,
every way you go.
This guy just being killed on the cross.
He was like,
you know,
my religion is way more fun than that.
Yeah.
You have the original sin too.
That's the great thing that you brought
up earlier about being white.
I mean it's sort of like just being a
human.
The original sin,
the only way they can have complete
total control over you is to say that
you are guilty no matter what.
Just by virtue of being born believing
of guilty if then it works.
Yeah.
It starts from that,
that this all knowing infinite thing
that looks over the universe is
incredibly petty.
Very jealous if you,
if you,
yeah.
If you go well that's worship.
Anything else,
any other false idols?
DEF You wear two different types of
clothes.
Death.
Yeah.
You know,
it's,
it's um,
really interesting cause there there've
been religions in the past that thought
that that was an evil God,
the crate to the earth and everything in
the F is created by an evil God and
there is a loving God beyond it,
but you can't pray to it and has no
interaction.
Yeah.
The Yoni,
you got to get past earth yet basically
you have to live a good life.
And eventually Ocala,
well maybe it's true.
Maybe it's like this is a level of the
video
game,
right?
Maybe you get past those.
No.
What if it did you get through and
that's awesome.
I'll put money on it.
It's not worth anything in the
afterlife,
sir.
Okay.
Okay,
well I'll put whatever you want on it.
Right.
And in the US I say,
and if it's true in the afterlife,
all blue,
but the absolute no one has in the
afterlife.
But you're like in a few real being,
you're like 70 failure.
I know Matt Dude,
Dude,
dude,
I do.
Now I've had,
I've had a near death experience,
man,
I've been there,
man.
It's obviously such wishful thinking
that says they know as soon as someone
says,
yeah,
I know what happens.
Even if you say I know that you die and
there's nothing,
well you definitely don't.
You definitely don't know.
Don't know.
But if I'm going to put money on it,
I mean like I would definitely wouldn't
put money on it because the money's
useless when your dad,
but I mean like now you know?
Yeah but tomorrow,
no,
it's not for me.
Tomorrow they might be able to prove it.
The amazing tomorrow if you get to a
betting agency it's like,
well actually scientists have discovered
the God is real and it turns out that
there are 72 virgins waiting in heaven.
So maybe you just convert to Islam now.
You know you blow shit.
Okay.
And low walk.
Did you ever see that priest that got in
trouble because he took photos of him in
heaven and he was selling photos of him
and heaven is wonderful.
It's him like waving and he's in this
pure white background and he said,
I put it on my toy,
it's on my,
my instagram account from a while back
as such.
But you could find a jamie.
It's hilarious.
He's funny.
He's,
I mean he's,
it's,
it's adorable because he's so fucking
stupid.
Like the thing is so fucking stupid that
it makes you just go.
It's like that.
Um,
I just found out about this too the
other day drawn Horton,
uh,
told me about the 18 year old kid that,
was running a medical practice and he
did not have a,
any medicine was chiropractor basically,
but they,
they busted him and he sat down and gave
interviews and said that he's being
persecuted.
And so all of the true facts will come
to light,
but it's the way it's edited is so
funny.
I mean,
it's really,
really funny.
I mean,
this guy has a loon,
this kid like sounds it.
Yeah.
Did you find the photo of the guy in
heaven?
There he is.
He's got his hand up.
This is a full version of it where you
could see like more of them with,
yeah,
it's like that,
but it's all just,
it's not that it's white.
It's not a fake one.
Oh,
it's whatsapp.
$5,000
for one.
Yeah.
He was charging people for the photo of
him in heaven and he was,
I guess he was going to sign it.
You mentioned what kind of more on you'd
have to be.
Yes.
Look at this.
Look at the quote.
I just want to bless everyone with the
experience.
I had talked with Jesus.
He's a great guy.
Showed me a lot of love.
I can't wait to get back up there with
him.
That's it.
You met the king of kings.
You met the son of God.
You met her and this is what he says.
He says he's a great guy.
He showed me a lot of love.
Oh,
well for sure.
It sounds like you had a real
transcendent experience with Jesus.
He's a great guy.
He pictures on his galaxy smartphone.
He brought his fucking Samsung up into
heaven was Paul.
That's,
that's basically [inaudible] stories
based on a lot of the time,
you know,
so someone was,
like Enoch was taken up into the crystal
ship of God or Holy Shit,
it's just whole shit made up by idiots
thousands of years ago.
I don't know what's going on.
They can't explain what's going on,
but they are kind of scared of getting
killed.
And that's because it might really
happen really fucking soon.
Let's get rid of us.
You know,
they're talking about an oral tradition.
Like those todd talked for thousands of
years and then by the time someone wrote
it down,
yeah.
It wasn't the original Bible like a
thousand years old by the time anybody
wrote it down a well and validly that
was,
I mean we don't know how old,
cause there was an old,
I don't even know.
Right.
Come from anybody,
you know,
will also,
when you hear like the similarities
between like the Sumerian tech stories
like oh yeah,
the epic of Gilgamesh is smear.
Yeah.
Really similar to Noah's Ark.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
The pitched him who,
uh,
you know,
survived the flood and whatnot.
And in fact,
it's like really so similar.
It's like the,
the,
it's almost the same words,
just replacing God with gods while they
oversee from by God's with God.
And uh,
I'm the things we can even pinpoint the
sort of time there's likely to have been
adopted into the religion during the
Babylonian Exxon.
When the Assyrians conquered the nation
of Israel and left Judah,
they undoubtedly that they took them
back to all the series of Babylonians
under Nebuchadnezzar,
took them back to Babylon and then
they're the,
they're the smart Jews were the elite,
the educated people.
And unsurprisingly,
suddenly the myths includes loads of
Mesopotamia.
My ideas.
Well,
what did that come from?
Genius.
You know?
And then they go back and so all of a
sudden,
okay,
it's cool incorporated.
Okay.
Yeah.
It's,
this is a whole shit.
It's all bull shit and there's no
benefit into really trying to include
the older stuff that they find each
other and try to like figure out whether
or not these are connected.
Stupid.
It's just like,
I mean it's just like,
there are so many golds.
Why that one?
You don't know,
probably cause you grew up with it,
right.
You weren't reasoned until that ability
you went,
you,
you weren't reasonable and positioning,
you didn't send anything.
You know,
I've had a think and I think it's
melodic.
That's,
I was thinking about it.
I was thinking Tmr yeah,
it was wild.
It tame amount you couldn't really have,
cause that's like a primordial God.
But that's how I like,
I like the old ones.
Yeah.
But they don't then,
you know,
you couldn't pray Tim outside Krom No
pray to crime.
He doesn't listen.
He doesn't.
But no,
I mean I like Asher to be honest.
You know,
wished her.
But um,
you know,
it's just like,
it's nonsense.
It's all nonsense.
It's all a myth.
And it's fascinating.
And what's interesting to me is the
historical idea that these people were
living by these stories like thousands
of years ago.
And like what?
Like you try to put it in context.
Imagine what it would be like living
thousands of years ago with no science,
with no education and limited
understanding of the world around you.
And then there you are abiding by these
ancient stories.
And it's a fascinating thing,
like the Dead Sea Scrolls.
That's really fascinating stuff because
they've been dave and deciphering that
forever.
But they don't incorporate it into the
Christian doctrine.
No,
it's not.
It's not a party to codify to Kong
revisit it.
What did they do about that?
Because if they know that that's ancient
religious text and it's as old as
anything that they've found,
right.
It's the oldest version of the Bible.
It's old as fuck.
Yeah.
And these,
you know,
they don't use it.
Yeah,
exactly.
Weird.
But let's,
cause they'd have to change the beliefs
and they went reasoned into these
beliefs.
So they're gonna be like,
no,
I don't have,
they just ignore it.
They've got a narrative.
They just ignore it.
I wonder what they did,
what the official position of like the
Catholic church is about.
Like the Dead Sea Scrolls.
I don't give a shit with the Catholic
Church says I'm fascinating.
Well,
yeah,
but one thing that,
um,
oh,
I was gonna say,
one thing that bugs me about fit is,
um,
I'll come up.
I was gonna say answering,
how does this pull,
you brought the Catholic church.
You got to,
we blew a fuse and my brother Catholic
churches,
I,
yeah,
just,
just super bummed out about them.
They say the Catholic church,
his whole shit.
Oh,
it certainly is this,
this is my problem with,
and it's just like,
I mean,
if someone wants to believe in stuff,
that's fine.
This is one.
Secularism is important,
you know,
it's,
I butts,
it's like identitarian politics,
you know?
It's just a tender mass to get.
But let me tell you about my ex,
you know,
but you're just talking about yourself,
right?
You know,
you don't talking about a problem that's
external to you.
You're saying I have a problem.
I believe something.
I believe in God.
I believe that black people are this.
I believe that white people this,
I mean,
yeah,
but I didn't,
we can't,
you know,
tell me,
tell me about the things that are
external to you that actually are
affecting things you know in you rather
than things that are in you that are
coming out.
I don't care about that.
You've got this the wrong way round.
I just find it fascinating that there's
like a certain level of like when you go
back in time,
there's a certain level of history,
like they way you just ignore those
ideas.
Like when you get past 4,000
years old,
like an epic of Gilgamesh is no one just
trying to live by the Sumerian texts.
There's no one as treating that as a
religion.
Right?
Yeah.
The ancient Mesopotamian stories are
basically thought of is purely myths.
Yeah.
Just like Odin and thor and zoom,
that's all abandoned.
But at one point in time,
that was the ideology to live.
I liked the way that God's never really
get resurrected and I,
I don't really believe the neo pagans
and stuff like this,
so I actually believe in this night.
Don't you just think it's cool?
They think it's cool.
Yeah.
Weekend.
And not wicked.
Wicked.
It is not like old either.
That's like a knee.
That was like 19th century or something
to allow that was invented.
Oh,
that's even dumber.
Yeah,
I know.
Isn't there,
it's like the oldest version of the
Mormons.
Yeah.
Oh,
I love them all.
And this was it Joseph Smith,
is it?
Yeah.
Dies in a gun fight or something like in
a prison
as like,
that's my kind of profit.
Well,
you know,
he's thinks it out when he was 14.
Yeah.
There's golden place and no one got
sauce.
Good stuff.
I mean,
who do you know that's 14 that isn't
full of shit.
Have you ever had a 14 year old tells
you the truth and they were like this
little lying all the time,
but know things.
Yeah.
This boy has wisdom.
Where did you learn this wisdom?
A golden tablet.
Come with me.
I'll show you where it is.
The angels knew we were coming and they
took it away.
Well,
I'm persuaded.
Um,
what do you have your magic caesarstone
Oh no,
they took that as well.
God,
it's so close.
So close.
Yeah.
But they did tell me before they left
that I could have nine whys when you
pitch just once,
getting lost.
You know,
one of my favorite thing about the Quran
and the Hadith says is a Mohammed
basically,
he used to pull these fucking dictates
from God,
abs us.
And at one point his child bride turn
around to him and said,
you know,
paraphrasing,
but uh,
you know,
these are coming at surprisingly
convenient times for you,
ma'am.
It's like,
oh,
he got called out by your child bride
magnet because it's obvious you pulling
this shit out of your ass for your own
convenience.
It's just like,
and there were some really gross things
about Mohammed as well.
I better not go and took some will
probably kill me.
Isn't that amazing?
That you believe would have to worry
about that?
Yeah.
Legit.
I mean,
people who have a mocked since we've got
some time anyway,
we were on the subject of Islam.
I think it's worth talking about.
Wahhabism I've been learning about that
a lot.
Okay.
Um,
it's crazy and Muslims hate it.
It's like the sjws of the Muslim world.
Imagine if the country was taken over by
rabid sjws who had access to weaponry
me.
Scary,
right?
Yeah.
Imagine if they had in every city like
sjw,
police,
he went around saying,
right,
blacks over here,
whites over there,
men over here,
women over here.
And if you were even caught fraternizing
with the opposite race or sex,
that's it.
You're going to get the lash or maybe
you get your hand chopped off for me,
you know,
whatever punishment in sexual social
justice would meet out if given the
option.
That's basically what it was like in
Saudi Arabia that under isis.
So it really is in a lot of ways,
a lot of things that we've been talking
about today,
they're very similar.
And if these were deep grooves that are
human to,
and I imagine the kind of person who
wants to be the person who enforces that
right piece of shit.
That's why these social justice
warriors,
a piece of shit that's control freaks,
a control,
fixed moral busybodies.
I've got no real morals at all.
And people who lack a certain amount of
objectivity,
which is why that certain lady you kept
talking about earlier feels like she can
say those terrible things about you.
But she caught herself.
Yeah.
Yup.
And I wrote ugly.
Everything they're saying is projection.
I mean,
who's who's doing the abusing,
who's doing all of this?
It's not me.
You know,
it's,
none of this is really true.
But um,
yeah,
the,
the Islamic world,
the well hobbies.
It was really,
I've read a fulsome fanaticism by Sunday
Ross Valentine and English professor who
went and lived down Saudi Arabia for
three years to learn about the
radiology.
Really,
really,
really fascinating.
Um,
one of the,
one of the most fascinating things is
how much other Muslims don't like the
hobbies.
And I'm using the term a hobby,
but it's,
it's a school of Islamic thought called
Salafism and it can best be described as
autistic screeching.
It's like taking a really hard line
interpretation,
ignoring other arguments against this
line interpretation and going,
you know what,
just no,
not even listening.
And then just carrying on and seeing
where that train of logic guests you and
suddenly it gets to religious police
Sunday guess to throwing gays off
buildings and stuff on the regular
Muslims don't need to do because
[inaudible] you know,
they'll be like,
well,
not pro gay.
I mean,
this is another ent,
but Mohammed says,
don't kill people,
you know,
at one point,
at some point in the Koran he says,
and so they,
they kind of say,
right,
okay,
well I'm not going to kill someone.
You know,
I mean,
okay,
maybe the gay thing was wrong.
So a lot of Muslims [inaudible] pro
death centers for sexuality,
but you know,
the,
you know,
they'll have,
I mean,
everything's reasoned.
Everything is argumentation,
right?
And so the important thing is to
understand that they are persuaded into
becoming jehad jihadis.
And it's not,
and this is one thing the West has to
understand.
It is not that we're at war with them,
right?
You can go to isis is like they,
they produce magazines.
Uh,
there was one called Dabiq,
which was a city,
they owned a but they lost it.
So they created a new one called
[inaudible],
which is Rome,
what they,
Arabic for Rome that they have conquered
before and not isis,
but Islam and want to conquer again.
And then,
then they literally say in,
I can't really think it was like
[inaudible] or something.
They literally turn around and say,
we do not fight you because your bond,
the Middle East,
we fight you because you are not Muslims
and no,
it's not because you bombed the Middle
East.
Even if you stopped bombing Middle East,
we will fight you until we become
Muslims.
This is why we do it.
Don't get me wrong,
you bombing the Middle East isn't making
us like you anymore.
You know we're going to keep doing it.
We find you because you insult Muhammad,
we find you because you don't believe in
allowing.
There's profit in the last day.
This is why we fight.
You do not misunderstand and they
literally address the liberal or the
progressive's or you know,
whatever you'd like to call them.
They're literally talking to these
people saying,
don't think that we're crazy and we
don't know.
We just,
this is what we believe.
You are cancer and we want to
exterminate you basically,
and you get the sjws going.
Wow.
I mean,
it's kind of went bowling.
The music man,
American foreign policy knows nothing to
do with that.
It's all about the argumentation.
Even if we will just peaceful peace
loving people who did nothing,
they would still be like,
well I lost,
told me to cut your head off.
I mean,
but again,
this is a small minority who are widely
despised by other Muslims.
I mean the like for example,
if you went to a Christian school and
everyone would probably be fairly chill,
you know,
you still going to like,
Catholic school or something and most
people you talk to,
they'll be fairly chill.
But in every group of people you'd have
a couple people who would be the sort of
people watching you and if you start
doing something,
they'd go and get the nuns and,
and they,
and they get whack,
you know,
a day,
you know that they are those people.
It's just for Islam.
They ended up going and killing things
because in Islam you told right,
if you,
if you die,
and this is another thing that drives me
crazy,
they're like,
oh,
the nine 11 hijackers with drinking and
carousing and,
and doing drugs,
they're obviously not real Muslims now.
You fucking idiots.
They think they're having all of their
sins expunged the second they die in the
surface of a lot.
This is what martyrdom is.
No matter what you've done,
you go to heaven and get your virgin.
So why wouldn't you do whatever the fuck
you like?
They have a free pass because they know
they've got a day.
Exactly.
So that's what they do.
And so when they're like,
oh,
isis aren't ready,
Islamic cause look at they're doing at
least on his long things.
No,
they know they're going to die and they,
well yeah,
in the logic of the theology that they
live under,
um,
they think they get,
they're going to die and that they're
going to get out of rescinded Alyson
remission of sins.
Isn't that the most fascinating?
Part of it is just the things that
people are willing to believe
[inaudible] had been rezoned into it by.
If you take like say,
right,
I believe that the crime is the word of
God and I believe that her deaths in the
center of the actual sayings and doings
of the habit and you believe these
things true then then you're building
from certain base and you need to,
and basically it's how you construct
arguments and if you start leaving out
parts of what otherwise is like a
regular Muslim sort of theological
argument,
um,
then you ended up building like a weird
tower over here.
This starts going off.
You know,
the arguments are constructing
themselves off to the left rather than
staying reasonably central.
I mean,
like most Muslims are never going to
become terrorists because they don't
artistically believe that a bunch of
things just aren't true just because
they don't want them to be true.
You know,
they don't,
they're not cherry picking from the
Koran as much as the way to the extent
that the wahabiists or Salafis and they
will build it in general.
Do y'all know they,
they hate,
do you know what the watchword is,
is the dumbest thing in the world?
There'll be no more innovations wide.
No more innovations.
Mohammed was the perfect man.
We must live like Mohammed.
Therefore,
I mean like you,
you would not believe how dumb this is.
You,
this is really part of their doctrine.
Yes.
It's called Bita.
He'd be bid a,
I think it might have an h on it.
I'm not sure.
Uh,
but I don't speak Arabic.
And the idea is that there are no
vacation,
not have any innovation.
No.
What about the innovation that they
already use?
Like Toyota trucks?
Yeah,
the,
the like for example,
the King King of sound had a hell of a
time.
Right?
Okay.
So Saudi Arabia was founded by the even
sowed family in conjunction with Abdul
Hub.
It was a known in light,
the late 18th century.
Uh,
he was unknown a theologian and he was,
he was a brilliant man,
but he was,
I come from a better way of putting it
in an autistic because he,
he was,
he was very focused,
hyper focused on a single sort of stress
strand of thought and everything that he
thought was either black or white,
there was no gray in between.
Right.
I know I'm,
I mean,
I literally mean he may well have had
autism,
right?
Just use it as an insult.
He may well have literally had awesome
zero those,
either this or nothing at all.
You know?
And so he ends up building this theology
and it's not,
it's not bad.
Well,
I met,
and I know that's a little wrong with
some of those not,
there's not bad.
It's not that,
it's not like,
it's not that there isn't an argument
there.
There obviously must be an argument
there,
otherwise people wouldn't believe it.
Right.
But you're getting me really confused.
Okay.
What might be an argument otherwise
people won't believe what he's saying
and the,
his interpretation of the Koran and
Islam and you know,
all of this,
he's got a particular interpretation and
he says to someone,
Hey,
you should follow my interpretation of
Islam cause I'm actually got the right
interpretation of Islam.
Okay.
And,
uh,
and most people were like,
no,
you know,
you're,
you're ignoring almost everything,
you know,
and that's fine,
but what does that have to do with
innovation?
Right.
Well,
that's the thing like Beeda is ha,
you know,
harmful innovations and but they don't
run harmful innovations are bad by
definition.
But there were also good innovations.
So the telephone,
you know,
the cars,
all that sort of stuff,
these kids are good innovations are so
the Muslims are free to use them.
The hobbies,
I imagine now this point,
they've been persuaded that they are
okay.
But um,
when like for example,
uh,
even salad first tried to explain to
them,
look,
we need guns.
And you know,
we ended up at a maximum gun.
We planes we need when he bombs and
bullets and cars,
all of these now televisions and
satellite dishes and all the sorts of
thing.
They were actively resistant to this
because of the whole,
Mohammed didn't have this and he had
these things called I warriors.
I'm probably pronouncing that horribly.
So apologies.
Anyone who knows how to pronounce these
words cause I haven't ever seen written
down.
Um,
but these guys were like Isis,
the,
I mean,
the way Saudi Arabia was formed is
exactly the same way as isis has been.
The Islamic state has been formed now.
Exactly the same.
These guys were the most brutal man
you've ever seen.
And they would just go in and murder
entire villages,
right.
He had 150,000
of these people,
you know,
like that.
He used to conquer what is now Saudi
Arabia.
And eventually he was like,
I want a car.
I think planes,
good idea.
And they were like,
no,
no.
And so they revolted against him.
And the British seeing him as a useful
client decided to help him out with a
few macs and guns and if you'd like,
you know,
biplanes or something.
So they revolted against him because he
wanted a car.
Yeah,
because it's on Islamic Ma'am and
Nevada.
A,
uh,
the British killed mill,
which was probably,
honestly,
it was probably a good thing for the
world.
Don't get me wrong,
because these guys were nuts.
They would regularly just,
I mean,
and this is the thing that,
it's another thing they've got is the
tech theory doctrine.
You're not a real Muslim.
That's an interesting thing,
isn't it?
And it's,
it's interesting how we do that to them.
We tack fear them.
You're not a real must be the wind on a
position to tell anyone who's a real
Muslim or not.
You know,
if they consider themselves Muslims and
Muslim and let me,
they like literally they are the most
Muslim in their opinion and their
opinion.
Nobody else's a real Muslim and
therefore it's okay to kill them.
You can only,
you only have to give a shit about
actual Muslims under this doctrine.
Again,
this is not what most Muslims think.
This is the antithesis of what most
Muslims actually think.
And so these guys used to like in a huge
rating that you have to qualify that.
Like you have to stand up and say,
I know,
you know the other nutty shit is not as
naughty as this nutty shit.
Yeah.
And,
and just just while we're on the
subject,
right?
Islam is Towsley in liberal,
a Western liberal country should never
defend Islam in it's,
this sounds very islamophobic of you.
Exactly.
And it's been used a lot.
Phobic comps and Louis,
I would never,
I would hate you would hate to live in
Sharia law.
Well,
you might not want,
not you personally,
but as a man you would to an entirely
benefit from living on the shelf for
real.
How so?
The girls have to walk around like
beekeepers,
right?
Not always that.
That's actually not,
how do you know what they really look?
That's actually,
that's actually not in the Koran.
It just says be modest.
Right.
You know,
you could just wear a headscarf,
isn't it?
If you like an internet,
Ho monist is like chance shorts.
Yeah.
And if you're,
if you're an autistic isis member that's
full on burger with a grill of your
face.
So this,
what's interesting about this
conversation,
the,
the thing would be like for example,
in the legal system,
directly out to the Quran,
women,
a woman's testimony is worth half of a
man's in the legal system,
in the legal,
so that they use that legal system like
they use the Koran forced the losses.
It's based on sharia.
So if a woman says something like,
Oh,
Sargon raped me and you'd be like,
pitch and we need a female witness.
Yeah,
he has two point you didn't,
you'd need more than one.
You know,
we did another female witness to testify
it.
Yeah.
And even then it was pop by,
she had a half a woman for the west of
that.
This is entirely,
entirely possible that the judge would
punish her for tempting me.
Yeah.
Because like if she has a half an
opinion and then the other chickens that
half an opinion,
that's still only like one person.
One person's a woman.
Yeah.
This one's for the whole thing.
I mean about women are entitled to half
of the inheritance money managers and
title.
That was the other half go to the any
brothers will,
you know anything like that.
If you're a lone sibling then you,
okay.
That was my only child then.
Yeah,
you're fine obviously.
But like if you've got a male sibling,
you'll get half of what he goes.
Pretty horrible isn't it?
But yeah.
And this is just like the most moral
thing.
And like the legal system is basically
about a bounce as useful as Hammurabi's
code of laws where you know,
an eye for an eye tooth for a tooth.
I mean that was outdated 2000 years ago
in West,
you know with the infant Jesus.
It's been,
no,
it is.
Let me see.
It's,
it's really brutal stuff and it's just
like,
okay,
well I mean any progressive,
whoever advocates for anything positive
about Islam is an idiot and doesn't
understand Islam.
They've got,
I mean I've,
I've seen them going Islams,
ms feminist religion.
Yeah.
If you want to be made a second class
citizen,
it is absolutely.
If that's what you want feminism to be,
the installation of a systemic
oppression against women.
Sure.
That can be feminism if you like.
And that really is revealing about
feminism,
isn't it?
What is going lately with this
weird sort of acceptance of,
how do you say,
Hey job,
how do you say that the head gear head,
you know,
offends me more than anything.
Right.
But what's going on with that?
There's this weird thing where women are
like being empowered.
They're pretend I'm the fuck up,
but they're pretending they're empowered
by this and that this is their own
choice.
This is a feminist value.
Unbelievably stupid,
but very common.
If you seen it.
One thing that I,
I've never,
I never really saw myself as sole person
who gets offended,
but when I see an American flag,
his job,
I find that offense come on.
They have those.
Oh yeah,
I know.
I let you look at and get,
no,
this is the antithesis of what these
files.
That seems like something a biker would
wear.
It sounds like.
It sounds like a parody,
but then American,
that's really what it is.
Maybe like one of them duck dynasty
phase.
Maybe.
I've been fooled.
Oh my God is not just the symbol of
liberty.
Cover yourself up.
Wow.
Cover your fucking hair up.
You.
So she,
she wearing that to show that she's very
American when trump is saying that he
wants to shut down mosques.
Yeah.
Did you see that whole Megan Kelly thing
with Alex Jones?
I saw that a,
he scooped a,
but to be fair,
I mean Alex probably did say a lot of
crazy shit and he'd probably say they
live by a little crazy shit,
didn't they?
Well,
he's in the past.
He said definitely some crazy shit about
sandy hook and,
but she was saying he never expected to
ever be famous.
Uh,
I've known Alex A.
Long time.
It's not that,
it's just that he's just the build a
budget,
always looking for conspiracies.
Like when you think you know for sure
that some things for sure that some a
conspiracy when you don't really know
for sure.
You're just saying it and then you just
run with it.
When you're talking about children's
lives,
it's very dangerous.
It's a horrible,
you better have some bloody convincing
proof and he's abandoned.
Abandoned that.
Yeah.
But he hasn't abandoned it and apologize
for saying it.
He's like the,
what he's done is like made this sort of
like,
uh,
he's,
he's sort of like made some,
some,
some video where he's talking to the
parents directly and saying that he
couldn't imagine he feels their pain and
I'm terrible for,
I feel very sorry for your loss,
but it doesn't go saying,
I'm sorry I supported a hoax.
That's not true.
That says you were liars and your
children were never killed.
Yeah.
You know,
there was a really crazy story that I
read about a guy who was a conspiracy
theorist and then his own son was
murdered and then he realized,
Holy Shit,
in Sandy Hook,
he realized like,
Oh my God,
this is how insane these conspiracy
theories are.
There's people that are,
that are,
there's a whole movement right now where
they think that polio was a massive
hopes and that what polio was,
was them injecting people with the polio
vaccine because there was no polio and
then injecting with as the vaccine,
they hurt all these people.
As someone who has been fooled before,
I can tell you the,
any solution is education.
You've got.
Yeah.
You can't just,
you can't just tell these people that
are idiots and never told to them cause
they'll just think,
well you don't have anything to rebut me
with Flatiron,
right?
Yeah,
exactly.
The floods,
you've got engaged with these people.
I mean,
that's way it'd be popular these days.
It's like what the fuck do you think the
satellites are for?
Why put that Elan Musk thing up and they
seen that Ilan Mustang I put on
instagram.
Should check this out,
pull this up.
Elon musk posted something about space x
and now they're there.
They're shooting.
They can shoot something in the space
now and then land it on a pad and
figured out how to do that.
And so they sped up a sped up version.
So instead of taking an hour or whatever
it takes to get up there and get back.
But check this out.
Like look how beautiful that looks when
they come in down in the earth,
but then go watch.
But why doesn't the world full of joy?
I don't know,
but check this out the water.
It does.
So watch how this thing lands.
This is really kind of crazy.
Boom.
From that nuts fucking out,
right?
Yeah.
That's incredible dude.
Elon Musk for president.
Wow.
I didn't know about his politics but I
mean that's,
you know,
must've built shit.
It's amazing.
But look at that fucking video of the
earth.
So all these dip shits in the comments.
I knew I was going to put it up cause
it's awesome.
It's awesome.
I'm going to put it up,
whether or not dipshits think the earth
is flat or not,
but it's,
you clearly see the fucking circle these
to the curve of the earth and um,
there's so many people in the comments
so you could see George Foods really
believed that.
Bro,
you're such a solo show out,
bro.
Why do we have satellites?
What's the point?
I mean there's no salary.
They don't think their satellites,
but you can see them loans you've done?
No,
no,
no.
They're flying around in planes.
Okay.
Why can't you see the sun at anytime of
the day or night?
Why can't you?
Yeah,
because the sun goes around behind the
flat earth.
No,
it doesn't make any sense.
Why are you saying it like,
like you were looking for a rational
explanation,
but that's the thing,
isn't it?
Because if let's say,
you know,
this is the flood,
the ice wall,
they say about it like it's like a under
like a fucking,
like a spotlight.
Right?
And it's for some reason rotating around
it,
but it's like,
well,
at any point I should be able to put it
in.
Got to look at this.
The Sun is just shining downwards.
You know,
you have a poor understanding of flat
earth theory,
sir.
I think I probably do.
It's all that is.
You're absolutely right.
But yeah,
the only way to,
any way to get rid of these things,
just to educate people you can't
ridicule because they're not,
they're not necessarily being
irrational,
that just dumb.
But it's like everything else.
We've talked about what people have an
idea in their head and then they dig
their heels in the sand.
And here's the thing.
Once you've publicly said you think the
earth is flat,
and once you've said that,
like you have to sort of stick with your
guns.
Well,
cause if you come out and say,
I'm sorry,
I'm so stupid.
I really did believe these fucking
idiots on youtube.
Instead of believing actual
astrophysicist,
actual people who were involved in the
fields of cartography,
airline travel,
shipping routes.
I mean Jesus fucking Christ.
You can go on and on and on about
satellites,
aerospace,
engineering,
all the different people that probably
would have to be in cahoots.
And let me tell you about the wall of
ice.
The walls,
there's a photo of it.
Someone sent to me.
You fucking idiot.
There's the wall.
It's like it's 10 feet high.
That's a good piece of shit.
I watched the video by some,
by some of the Youtube App and uh,
some here too.
Like the problem man,
fucking youtubers is a law.
It is a part of the bone.
But when he,
he was like,
why do we believe in a flat earth?
And I was great.
I want to know,
you know,
that was legitimately exact scenes.
One Chem trails.
Actually it was the hope big.
It was like this.
It gives us,
I remember we'll talk about big foot.
It's a hope.
They get it home.
It gives them hope,
like hope beyond the,
the ice wall that are better land
exists.
And it's like,
why would it be any better than what
we've got now?
Don't you have a photo?
You'd dump cons.
It's not one guy leaked to fucking
camera over to that ice wall.
You piece of shit.
Can we fly a drone over?
Show me that edge.
Showing the outside.
It's why,
why it looks a conspiracy to keep
hidden.
No can was what it is.
People love to know things that other
people don't know.
They love when they uncovered truth.
When there's a secret that someone is
hiding about something as monumental as
the shape of the earth.
People love to be the people in the
know.
They love to be Hashtag woke that's what
happens.
And they don't like to read books.
No,
no,
they don't.
And I think for some of them though,
like it,
I mean this guy who was saying that it
gives us hope and he's like,
that's because you don't have any hope.
You need something and you're honestly
not a religious person.
And so you take on this as kind of a
religious belief.
You,
no,
you're wrong.
Listen,
a lot of them are religious.
That's part of the thing.
Part of the whole thing is that
evolution is a lie.
That's one of the big parts of flat
earth theory is that the earth is flat.
The firmament breaking the conditioning
today.
Yeah,
man.
Listen is a big religious part of this
whole thing.
Evolution.
This is a lie.
It's a huge part of the flat earth
movement is a belief in creationism.
I believe that whole space is not real
and then above us is heaven.
That we live in a dome now.
This is,
there's a lot of different factions to
the flat earth movement.
I'm sure that since,
Oh yes,
I have,
but no,
this is a big,
a big part of this is a deep belief in,
in creationism.
Oh,
so it's like it's an American Christine
thing.
Oh yeah.
The ones who believe in it also don't
believe in dinosaurs.
I think dinosaurs are fake.
This is wonderful,
right?
The main guy believes that dinosaurs are
fixed by the way.
Oh,
thanks.
Nuclear bombs or hoax.
Yes.
Nuclear bombs or,
oh,
what did we drop?
Bom,
Bom Bom.
Not a big deal.
It's just a really a bomb.
Nuclear.
It's a hoax.
Yeah.
But this massive hoax,
they spent a lot of money.
It's just,
just really big.
Dinosaurs are hooks to bro.
Chem trails are real though.
Of course there probably could be real
jail engineering is a thing.
Oh yeah.
Like,
and so it could actually be right.
And I could see the rationale from the
government's point of view if they're
like,
well,
a global warming is happening and if we
like put extra
clouds in the sky,
then it'll deflect an excessive amount
of the sun's rays and coolio if done
well.
It does do that.
Yeah,
exactly.
So,
but it doesn't mean it was a conspiracy
to do that.
That's why they're stupid.
But yeah,
it's no,
it's not the,
they're not trying to,
cause they,
you know,
I've seen the capture thing.
They think what they're trying to like
poison people do.
So from our stand that that's what
happens when a jet engine goes through.
Condensation in the air creates these
fake clouds.
And yes,
these fake clouds can cool the earth
down a little bit.
And in fact they've put them out on
purpose,
but they're not putting them out on
purpose.
It just a side effect of air travel.
Like they're,
they're making these assumptions based
on seeing something that sky and
thinking someone's spraying something.
I wasn't there actually like a Geo
engineering thing that was actually
something they're doing or planning to
do.
There is definitely the possibility of
one day us having no real protection
what no ozone layer there is a
possibility.
And one of the things that scientists
have speculated is that suspending some
sort of reflective particles in our
atmosphere,
like satellites that would somehow or
another protect us from solar radiation.
So there's something that people thought
of him,
but for the doing it well for sure
someone has thought about doing it.
If that's the issue,
if we're missing some sort of atmosphere
and like,
oh,
can we create an atmosphere?
Yes we can.
How would we do it?
We'd spray chemicals in the sky.
Okay,
but that's not what you're seeing when
you see those clouds behind jets.
It's really simple science.
The heat of the jet engine.
Yeah.
Craig on blocks with a constant.
The condensation in the atmosphere.
It creates a vape.
The these artificial clouds,
they look like clouds because they are a
cloud.
Makes perfect sense.
But to the armchair conspiracy theorist,
it looks up.
They like,
they're spraying us,
man.
Yes.
Spray.
Nice Guy,
man.
Come on and defend Alex turns for a
minute.
I love Alex Jones.
Yeah,
I mean in a,
defend them about sandy hook.
No,
no.
I'm going to defend about the frogs.
What about the frogs?
It's true.
They telling me folks.
Okay.
Oh,
they turned frogs.
You know,
it was really ironic as well.
The globalists are telling the frogs
gay.
Well,
there is a,
I mean,
I'm,
I'm actually being literally serious
when I say,
well,
this pollution.
Yeah.
Pollution actually does make the fries.
It's corporate malfeasance and it's any,
a certain kind of frog and a certain
kind of pesticide.
I actually read through the study and
you played my video on his channel
before I have,
my video was on my old trying to look
and taken down by a metal channel.
Got taken down.
It was just a little ship hosty channel
Dory.
But I,
but I'm the shit post each channel.
We mean just put bullshit on the,
Oh bullshit.
I found funny and one of the lovely
thing was looking into this study,
Alex Jones's sighting.
So I thought I'd go and get the study
actually read it.
And he's right kind of right here for
example,
these people aren't actually globalist.
It's like a multinational corporation.
People who are actually open borders,
they are pro open borders.
They're pro pro,
you know,
corporate influence around the world
because they run a giant corporation.
The chemicals they're putting in the
water technically where actually he
wasn't even going far enough.
These chemicals were making frogs trans
like they would for 90% of the frogs.
And it was only a certain chemical,
a certain pesticide and it was affecting
a certain kind of frog.
So,
and it,
it doesn't,
it hasn't made them trans.
Well I identify the process.
Obviously,
I'm
not a scientist,
but like,
um,
but I mean if 90 days of finding one and
it literally for 90% of the frogs that
were touched,
some of the,
I'll have to check the numbers,
but for a large,
from the majority of the folks touched
it would make them behave in like the
soft feminine wave male frogs and make
them behave in a feminine way.
And for 10% of the frogs touched by this
chemical,
it would actually send through a process
to transform into a fertile female frog.
Holy Shit.
So it wouldn't be making gay,
it was lucy thinking trends.
Right.
That's not even trans.
But that's literally like changing your
shoes,
your actual sex.
Yeah.
It's literally like transitioning into
an actual female.
That's actually first I'll say it's
better than we can do for human beings.
Um,
but this,
this,
this was actually a real thing.
It wasn't like an intentional plan to
try and turn people into gays or trans
or whatever though.
And it wasn't,
it was done by people who are globalists
probably,
but it wasn't done as part of a
nefarious plot.
It was dumb because it was cheaper to
just dump the chemicals,
you know,
office.
And it was just an unintended,
it's just,
it's just ironic going Alex.
Alex Jones says,
you know,
the,
the globalist supporting chemicals into
the water than make friends gay.
Well,
he ease,
right.
Well you know,
during Desert Storm there was a project
that they put together where they were
trying to figure out a gay bomb.
Yeah.
Do you know about that?
I had about like the soldiers were about
starting like you,
well,
okay,
I'm not feeling very horny.
But now I've decided,
I like men.
They would,
they would blow this stuff in the air,
blow it up,
and it would land down on them and it
would transfer them into gay people and
they'd be so ashamed that they would
stop fighting and lose morale.
This was a real consideration they
spent,
came about the Greeks,
didn't they?
Yeah,
exactly.
Cause these guys have fearsomely gay.
In fact,
with that was a super power to
Thebesians scientists develop gay bomb
to make enemy soldiers stop fighting.
Make love,
dude,
dude.
Two scientists at right laboratory in
Dayton,
Ohio working to make America's military
even mightier made the discovery in 1994
according to the detailed page papers on
our,
through a freedom of information request
and last night they were finally
rewarded within what does that Igg,
iga or LG ignoble awards.
Nobel prize for peace.
A spoof of the Nobel prize.
Okay.
Due to be announced next week,
Marc Abrahams,
a editor of the animals of the
improbable research and the man behind
the ignoble awards explained,
we don't know if this document was the
start and end of it or whatever.
In fact,
this project continued and perhaps
continues to this day.
Dot.
Duh.
So to this day they might be working on
the gay bomb.
Do you think trump puts a stop to that?
He doesn't waste per necessarily
spending.
He's pro gay then.
Yeah,
but he doesn't want to be too
complicated change people.
What if a regular guy like him gets
bitten by that spider I radioactive gay
spider?
Do you know about how that tick that
turns people into vegans?
Count down was a tick bite.
This tick bites you and you develop a
meat allergy.
Oh really?
Yep.
Well it's called the lone star tick.
Whether they,
where they live,
probably taxes cause it's called the
lone star tick actually guesser but I
think they're spreading.
But it would be ironic if it was in like
the meat eating capital of the world and
lone star tick making people allergic to
red meat that eat the fuck out of some
chicken.
Now I'll tell you that Jack.
And it was engineered by the government.
Uh,
I just think it's just nature deciding
we're tired of their bullshit.
Look,
it's been recorded as far north as Maine
and all the way to central Texas and
Oklahoma.
Wow.
The ticks are found in the dense
undergrowth and wooded areas as well as
around animal resting areas.
You know,
I've been thinking about this man
because I run in the hills where this
ticks.
I saw tick like Ari and I did a podcast
the other day that we will release on
July 18th,
which is the day that Ariz Netflix
special comes out.
But we did a podcast where we went on a
hike and I put on a weighted vest and we
went through the woods and did the whole
thing that I do when I run and I'm a
tick landed on Ari and we knocked it off
and then we started talking about it and
like go on.
Like is there a way to stop ticks from
coming on you?
Is there like an effective,
did they have a spray?
Like ticks are not like mosquitoes,
right?
No.
Is there an effective tick spray?
Do you should know?
Do you're so smart,
but I don't know that ticks and I'm the
last month there's Tikrit Pelham.
Other is how effective it is though.
Hmm.
Yeah.
Mosquito repellent doesn't always work.
I get bit of a fucking works.
I can't bullshit.
You know what works?
Thermacell you're used the thermacell.
Oh Man.
I don't know if it's bad for you,
but it's amazing.
I didn't even know that his thermos
cells in a,
a piece of equipment that people take on
hikes and camping and hunting it.
Um,
it's,
there's this chemical that screws into
the bottom and then it has an element.
You Click it and heats on and it makes
it's fine.
Mist through this element and this fine
mist.
It doesn't smell bad to people,
but mosquitoes cannot fuck with it.
They just,
they just vanish like,
well,
is it,
it's not poisonous to let alone the time
or I don't know,
man.
That's a problem.
Yeah.
I don't want to be saying doing this.
And then five years later you got
dementia and I heard you.
I'm thinking,
yeah,
I'm panicking now.
Shit.
Some things I can't remember.
So it'd be good for them.
Yeah.
What about him?
I've seen him.
Oh No,
I definitely have it.
But I went looking.
Did Ya?
Yeah,
I did a whole TV show about it.
Yeah.
Did you?
Well,
I did this,
a show that I used to do on the Scifi
channel that made me,
this is get made a lot of people mad at
me and it also made me realize what
conspiracy theories really we're all
about.
And the show's called Joe Rogan
questions,
everything.
So it would go and I would embed myself
with these people and hang out with them
and I embedded myself with these big
foot people.
And what I said at the end of it was,
here's one thing that you don't find
when you go looking for bigfoot black
people,
you're more likely to find big foot than
you are black people looking for
bigfoot.
It's a bunch of unfuckable white guys
out camping.
It's true black people to want to have
nothing to do with it.
It's a goofy white obsession and it's
also,
um,
there's no one that I talked to her.
This is like one lady that had a pretty
good story.
She believed that she was saying,
but here's the thing,
black bears are huge and they,
the,
you know,
you can get a black beard seven feet
tall easily and they walk on their hind
legs.
Sometimes they just do,
everybody knows they do.
There's video of them.
It's not a mystery.
Black bears walking through the woods on
hind legs are seven feet tall.
You would think that's big for us.
It's really just telling him our shops
like that.
I mean there's,
if there's no big foot,
but the earth is flat,
we'll do,
I believe,
well,
I don't think the earth is flat either.
I think it's just everything's aligned,
man.
This is all psy ops thing.
It's,
there are so many,
like really convincing stories.
That's the thing.
The third one,
sorry,
I haven't heard one of them.
Well,
convincing stories of big foot.
No.
Oh,
I've had loads.
Whether like,
you know,
I was,
I was like,
you know,
five feet away from this.
Like,
you know,
he's saying and it didn't have like,
he didn't have the best price and a
man's face and they'll,
they'll be like,
you know,
and it was,
it was looking at me and stuff with
this.
Is that okay?
But nobody's ever gold.
Good picture of any of these things,
you know?
Yeah.
Nobody really goes to the woods on a
regular other than Les Stroud Survivor.
Man.
He believes that you thinks one,
but there,
there are never any bodies.
There's never any feces.
I've heard bears makeup fucking monkey
noise too.
I heard him say that.
He's like,
it made it sound.
there's clearly a primate sound,
but I've heard,
I've seen in my own eyes in the woods a
bear do that with another bear.
Yeah.
They make that when they fight with each
other.
Yeah.
It must be bad as it must be like
hopping percents.
Cause I mean you can't have like,
you can't have like a species of
Australia pithy kiss or whatever it,
it's supposed to be gigantic.
Sorry.
Yeah.
Drag it into piff kiss whatever is
supposed to be.
And just like [inaudible] is America's a
huge place.
You would find,
you would find something,
you find a dead one or something after a
while.
There's enough people looking.
But the thing is when they found out
that like that about that Hobbit Guy,
do you know the hollow Homo Floresiensis
for instances?
For instance,
I know the thing you talking about,
it was in the island of Flores.
Yeah.
And Indonesia they found within the last
14,000
years there was absolutely a little
person that was like two and a half,
three feet tall look like,
uh,
yeah.
But they look 100% human.
Oh,
this thing is did not look 100% human.
It was a new car.
It was another type or an offshoot of
Homo sapiens.
Yeah,
I mean,
I don't know if they classified it.
I don't know if they have DNA on it.
It's,
it's,
it's a relation of hume that yes,
it's a type of human,
but it's not neanderthal tall and it's
not homosapien.
And this thing was 14,000
years ago.
So they know that gigantic [inaudible]
was a real animal in the net.
It lived on hundred per 100% alongside
human beings as recently as 100,000
years ago.
But this,
uh,
this is just nonsense.
I was big for thing.
Well,
that Orang pen deck is much more
interesting.
The orange pen deck is a small Hobbit,
like man that lived,
uh,
I think that might've been Indonesia as
well.
Right.
But what is the Vietnam?
Vietnam,
well,
I think it's these,
some of these tropical jungle climates
where there might have been as recently
as,
you know,
a hundred years ago or whatever,
that might have been a few of those
fuckers remaining.
They don't know.
I mean when someone dies in the woods,
man,
do you know how many people we lose in
the United States?
Loads thousands.
Every year.
Thousands.
I watched David polite all the time on
like art bell and stuff.
I think he's great and he's,
I,
I love that.
He's like such clean coal American guy
and he never goes into like the wild
conspiracy theory angle to it.
But it's,
it's,
it's always hinting that,
uh,
it's probably painful.
So Santiago,
well that was a book,
a movie wrapped.
Never is.
It's like Bobcat Goldthwait made a movie
about big foot eating people.
Oh Wow.
It's a great move.
They're fine.
It's called Willow Creek.
It's a horror movie.
And you liked bobcat bolt golf.
Wade made a horror movie dude.
He made a great horror movie.
It's like a sort of like one of those
Blair witch project type movies about a
couple that go up looking for bigfoot,
you know,
and just a film like where are they?
Original Patterson footage was taken
place.
It's a person in a suit.
People love,
they want to believe that person that
fucking say bobcat ones bleed.
But why?
But why did they put tits on the seat?
Because it's a girl get up.
Why would they make terrible anybody who
looks at it,
it looks like a person.
A suit as well.
Another part of my bit,
I said,
whenever you see something that looks
like a person in a suit,
it's a person in a suit.
There's not a fucking animal.
A lot lose a person in a suit.
Yeah.
I just,
I just wanna know the conversation was,
I look if we,
if we get mail,
so it means he's going to look like
person to suit,
but if we get a female so they can be
like,
why would they,
why would they put tits on it?
Well,
he was can a real big,
they did a female because the female
would be smaller than male.
So instead of it being an eight foot
tall thing,
you get a six foot tall thing and it's
like a regular size dude with some nice
tits and you're like,
it's chick bro.
Meanwhile,
it's a big guy,
like a big seven foot.
I mean,
I love the big food.
Like I live the breakdown videos will
live youtube the grade and it's always
like done.
Let's do it in a suit.
It was a Wiki leaks that was just
released today about NASA knowing about
aliens.
Railey yes.
Pull it up.
Jamie.
NASA knows about aliens.
They have information on Wiki leaks,
knows if they're going to spill the
beans.
I tell you when it comes out somewhere
so that it really is true.
And then there's like an alien
ambassador on the White House lawn or
something.
You gotta be like,
Oh,
okay.
I was in a unit like a prowling.
Oh,
it's anonymous.
I thought it was much more likely to be
pranksters.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Much more likely.
That's anonymous.
A global hacking collected the leads
that alien life exists and thanks.
NASA is about to confirm it.
The shadowy group.
Oh yeah.
I love that.
It's a shadowy group of artists and you
can be in,
you could join.
Oh,
I have,
you know,
I'm not,
I mean I'm in to exactly.
Uh,
in a 12 and a half minute video
publishing an unofficial youtube channel
on Tuesday,
the video centers around recent findings
by the American space organization,
including the discovery of 219 new
planet candidates,
10 of which present similar conditions
to Earth by NASA's Kepler space
telescope team in June,
as well as comments made by a senior
NASA official.
But here's the real thing,
right?
You believe in,
I believe as well that it's entirely
possible that some life exists somewhere
in the infinite universe.
Can't believe it doesn't.
Of course.
I mean we're on the same page.
Why are we so skeptical about skeptical
about it visiting us?
Because it's very difficult to visit us,
right?
But if it's like way more advanced than
us,
shouldn't it be able to figure it out?
Just like we could figure out how to get
a probe to Jupiter,
but why can't it figure out how to
visit?
But then we've got a government
conspiracy and cover.
Do we or are they just people and they
don't know any more than you are?
I like,
we don't know shit.
Why would the,
what if aliens came here?
Do you think they would like go,
oh that's an elected official.
Clearly that guy's the mayor.
Let me talk to him.
No,
they'd look at this fucking ant hill and
they'd be like,
which one of these dip should we tell?
I Dunno it just pick that guy up.
Just stick some stuff up his ass and do
some run some tests on him.
That's bullocks though cause we,
and listen to it.
I've gotten really offended and we've
got a friends online forever and this is
just a call the counselor.
I'll give it to this.
We can,
we can distinguish between from one end
to another.
Yeah,
we can see the workers,
we can see the soldiers,
we can see the queen.
They can,
they can tell.
They would surely be smart.
But does the queen or physically shaped
different?
Hmm.
They're different things.
Like this big one makes all the babies.
It's pretty obvious that a queen bee,
she's,
she has a giant Stinger that doesn't
detach and she goes and kills all the
baby bees,
which is trying to kill the women.
They speak English.
They probably can,
but if they say Mr President,
we have to think that if something is
alien that it could be so alien that all
of our concepts of culture are so
bizarre that there's no context for it
to relate to send a language.
They've just know what we're saying.
They know what we're saying based on the
fact that it's fairly simple.
If they can understand the language then
they must have real relatable or similar
concepts in their own board.
Not necessarily.
It'd be able to translate,
not necessarily then the continents
language.
That's not necessarily true.
That's putting them into a limitation
that we currently have.
Like we don't understand dolphin
language,
but we know they have a language we can,
we can appreciate the dolphins probably
have a concept for eating.
Right?
Right.
So like if,
if the dolphins,
I didn't,
I didn't know what dolphin temperature
in terms of like who's the queen,
who's the mayor hierarchical,
you know,
they don't have like an Alpha Dolphin
and people,
the dolphins will have some like clicks
that mean the person in charge.
I mean they must have some concept of
hierarchy because they have a concept
for see them operate under.
Right.
But you know,
if we could don't really understand
dolphin language will know.
But I mean we can surely pick out like
the
concepts themselves.
I mean they must be the concept of the
Leda.
I though they just count on send the
concept of labor.
I don't think it is widely understood
what dolphins are saying.
I think it's,
when I translate dolphin to humans,
we can't even recreate it.
No,
no,
I'm sure what I mean,
we can't recreate their,
sounds like we don't know what their
sounds mean.
Like if we set a bunch of shit to a
dolphin,
I'm not saying we can talk to dolphins
or anything,
but like,
like with a,
with a dog,
you know,
you can,
they,
the dogs would go sit in kinds of very,
very primitive methods of communication.
But like a dog whimpers you know,
it's in pain,
right?
You know it.
And so I have to have a concept of
being,
uh,
being in pain to understand the dog's
going.
I know that that means the dog hurt.
I must understand that the concept of
hurts.
Right.
And so if the aliens,
if they can end standing diced and they
must understand the concept of what
president is or they must have,
they must have some sort of,
they must have a clean way of analyzing
it.
Surely they for sure,
if they can take taking all [inaudible]
superior to us.
I'll be saying,
well if not superior technologically far
more advanced in in that there've been
alive longer.
But when you consider the possibility of
all sorts of different weather
conditions,
different life conditions,
maybe different solar systems where they
have zero concern about being hit by an
asteroid is bipedal.
Yeah.
And it's like,
fine.
Well that's because they're supposed to
represent us in the future cause easier.
Is that what it is?
Surely.
Because we were called the funny too.
I think it's a relatable thing.
It'd be that too,
but that was my point is that I think
that aliens could potentially be so
alien that they can't even relate to the
concept of our ability to communicate
with noises.
Like they might be.
Emily,
Katie Fair with smells.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
They might be using some telekinesis or
some shit.
Psychics,
man.
Yeah,
maybe.
I mean,
so he's,
do you think if you had a bet all of
your youtube money very much.
I have aliens.
Have aliens been here or no?
I probably been no,
no.
Yeah,
but skeptic,
I mean all of the ancient alien stuff.
It's total horse shit.
Yes.
Total Horse Shit.
That stuff is really fits more time.
Graham Hancock,
Randall Carlson mode of there being an
ancient,
very advanced civilization that probably
was wiped out.
Just like we know there have been
civilizations that were wiped out.
It's much more likely that someone like
say in Machu Picchu,
someone was able to construct things,
you know,
that were like really confusing cause
today,
yeah,
it wouldn't come from the new world.
Um,
it's really interesting because as soon
as you start going down this line you
think,
okay,
well do you need to have high
civilization?
You need sudden series of things and
there are a bunch of books you can it
to.
Abundance of food,
agriculture.
It's like you need a little more than
that as well.
But like he's,
you can,
you can
read a ton of solar things,
wealth,
power or poverty in politics,
come up with the title is,
um,
and uh,
why nations fail and,
uh,
what's the guns,
germs and steel red and we these books.
And then suddenly you understand what,
what populations need three quarters of
it.
I should be honest,
it's really good.
I bailed on it,
but it,
you know,
there's a whole slew of things you need
as a civilization for humans to develop
to high sort of standards,
population density and all this sort of
thing.
And so,
um,
but it's not just population densities,
lots of other places that have high
population densities.
So in Africa for example,
you've got very few areas that have high
population density.
And so you don't have great
civilizations like in sort of sub
Saharan Africa because there just aren't
great cities,
dense cities to trade with.
And then,
and then you go,
okay,
well what they had,
it's difficult tree cause in Africa and
this is something that Thomas soul goes
into is a look the rivers a Humphrey
navigable,
you know,
they've got lots of rapids and some
rocks and not very deep.
You can't carry huge barges done.
They're not like,
they're not like the Danube.
You know this thing goes for,
you know,
hundreds of miles and his deep and you
can get barges all up and down it and
stuff like this.
I mean,
and traveling,
traveling goods by water is so much more
fashion,
like you know,
like 20 times more efficient than trying
to take them over the land.
And so if you don't have,
especially in three large machines and
so you'd need that innovation or to
create the large machines in the first
place.
Exactly.
And,
and you need somewhere to take it.
You're not trading with anyone.
If there's,
if you're the one like Atlantean
civilization,
no one else is buying your gifts.
Like it's,
it's,
it's all horse shit.
It just couldn't happen based on what
you need for this thing to actually end
up exist.
Right.
In order for an Atlanta is to exist,
you really have to have a bunch of
Atlanta lenses.
Yeah.
Which is more likely that there were
some sophisticated civilizations that
were hit by asteroids.
Well,
not have evidence for that.
It's a lot of iridium.
Yeah.
There's a lot of actual physical
evidence.
Yeah.
There's also the stuff,
it's kind of clear glass.
Well it's the best evidence cause
iridium comes from space.
Iridium radium,
when you find it in large quantities
indicates and asteroid impact.
Um,
iridium is very common in space and
extremely rare on earth.
So when there's a whole sediment layer
of iridium,
it's almost entirely provable.
That's when it was hit by something,
wouldn't it be some sort of ruins
underneath thisone yeah.
They're found a lot of ruins.
And this is what I was really
fascinating about how old go Beckley
tapis 12,000
plus years old.
Yeah.
But that didn't get,
that didn't die because it was hit by an
asteroid.
Well they,
this is what Graham Hancock and Randall
commensalism.
It's speculating.
That was really primitive.
Okay.
You don't know that.
But before we go into a massive,
huge stone columns that are 92 feet
tall,
they're carved out of stone by people
that are hunters and gatherers.
It's pretty impressive.
But the point being you're hero Tiramisu
for this,
you know,
for the thing,
but it's not like a technological
achievement.
Well,
okay,
what is a PR impressive?
Machu Picchu?
Impressive.
It's pretty impressive,
right?
That's not ulta.
Well,
it's thousands.
A couple thousand years old.
It's 100 1400 something.
Okay.
I don't think that's true.
And I don't think they know that for a
fact.
And this is one of the speculations that
Graham Hancock and Randall Cros that
have presented is that the evidence of
this nuclear glass,
which only exists on impact sites before
you go to your phone,
listen to maybe so you can understand
what I'm saying,
impact sites,
um,
where meteors hit or where they've done
nuclear tests.
So they found this stuff and micro
diamonds,
evidence of massive impacts.
But when they do core samples,
they founded at 10 and 12,000
years,
which is essentially the same time
period as the end of the ice age did a
huge podcast on it with geologists.
They don't know though.
Here's the thing,
when you talk to an expert,
this is pure speculation.
There's no carbon dated evidence that
points to that age where as there is
with the Sphinx.
So with the Sphinx,
or excuse me with the Great Pyramids,
the Great Pyramid of Giza,
they've done some tests on some of the
sediment and some of the stuff in
between the stones and they brought it
to about 2,500
BC.
Crazy specifically.
Yeah.
They found a bunch of stuff that shows
without,
with a very high,
uh,
high degree of possibility or
probability that it's around 2,500
BC.
Yeah.
What they've done with this [inaudible]
name of the massive impacts.
Well,
there's,
yeah.
With Geezer,
right?
Yeah.
But there's a,
with,
um,
rather,
uh,
the great pyramid,
but there's,
there's plenty of evidence that there
was some sort of a massive event around
10,000
and 12,000
years ago.
And what their belief is that this is
where all the stories of Atlanta has
come from.
This is where all these stories of these
great civilizations that were wiped out
come from is that most likely we
experienced a big die off and a lot of
people were affected by these disasters
and catastrophes.
That coincided with asteroidal impacts.
Maybe.
But I mean we know where the stories of
Atlantis come from Plato.
Right?
But,
and he had gone to Egypt and,
and been told us,
but it's all,
I mean it's not looking real thing.
It's not,
I mean he,
he said yeah 9,000
years before the present and that they
built the thing then he was,
that's what's crazy is that this is
Alex.
But it does coincide with the time of
the impact.
For example,
9,000
years ago there wasn't an Egypt,
you know,
from Plato Plato's,
from like 2,500
years ago,
from now,
like 500 BC,
like 9,000
years pulled out that will's new Egypt.
There was no efforts.
And yet the story involves,
that's not necessarily true either.
Robert Schoch cause the geologists that
have a Boston University has done a lot
of um,
investigation on the,
the,
the temple that the Sphinx was carved
out of,
like where the,
the Sphinx is the walls of the temple
and he believes it's from water erosion.
There's this,
these fissures and he's deep,
uh,
erosion marks that they believe indicate
that the temple of Sphinx or the area
that's carved out of is far older than
the same.
Like they know that the Great Pyramid of
Giza is two,
500 BC,
but they fail,
always attribute the Sphinx of being the
same timeline.
Dr Robert Schoch from Boston University,
he says,
that's not the case.
He said,
what you're looking at is thousands of
years of rainfall and they have hundreds
of geologists that have signed off on
this.
This is not like,
and there's,
he goes over the physical evidence of
these fissures and how they're made.
He's like,
as a geologist,
I can tell you,
you are looking at thousands of years a
rainfall.
The last time there was series rainfall
in the Nile Valley was about 7,000
BC.
So what he's saying is it's entirely
possible that there have been many
different civilizations that lived in
this area and that Egypt is a
civilization that might have gone back
many,
many thousands of years longer than just
the construction of the Great Pyramid of
Giza.
Uh,
I wasn't talking about the Great Pyramid
of Giza really,
but that's Egypt will live us just a
monument in Egypt.
Right.
But Egypt is a place that did exist
10,000
years ago.
12,000
50,000
years.
Because I like cars,
but don't say it.
No it didn't.
Cause you don't really know well,
but you're saying no it didn't.
I'll tell you,
are you in Egyptologist do you you had
boots on the ground and talk to the
people over there?
We don't really know.
Right.
Well he doesn't know what I'm about say,
but you said no it didn't.
Well yeah,
but the,
the state of Egypt.
Okay.
Like as I'm not saying they weren't
people living in the area.
There aren't,
daddy would've been people living in the
area.
Right.
But calling it Egypt are saying,
yeah,
they wouldn't know co when did they
start calling it Egypt.
Oh,
I'd have to look that up.
Put it in there.
But um,
the like we can tell I'll kill,
just can tell like,
um,
like when the,
when of grains with first domesticated
and things like this and you're never
going to have a state without farming,
you're never going to happen.
You're not going to have like a hunter
gatherer,
a state where they have a government and
you need a surplus of food to be able to
support,
um,
uh,
pre uh,
preached the cloths in the US a
bureaucratic class.
Right,
right.
And to get something built,
you need these things.
Right.
Which I mean,
not necessarily calling off stone.
Like if you're going to build a pyramid,
yes,
you need these things.
Maybe calling us thinks that's something
tribesmen could do.
It ain't even cold cocked bell tappy out
of it's pronounced go back clean.
Yeah.
Correctly.
Uh,
that,
that can easily believe that like,
you know,
nomadic a hunter gatherers,
they could,
they could have crossed the that cause
you just,
just basically sanding and chipping.
It's done.
Well.
They've moved them to it.
These are huge chunks of stone that were
done back when they didn't have a
surplus of resources.
The hunters and gatherers and you've
done it wrong.
I'm not saying it wasn't like a
monumental achievement for the time and
the resources obviously was,
but we know that they weren't farming
well.
It might be right about that,
but we might not be right.
You're talking about an incredibly long
time ago.
12,000
years ago is a long time and whatever
evidence would be left is really
probably been absorbed by the earth by
though.
Oh,
maybe.
But I mean we can't sit here and
speculate about something that might've
happened if we've gotten a weapon.
But that's exactly what we're doing.
If we're saying that they were
definitely hunter and gatherers,
we don't know assumption,
but we do know is they were capable of
making these incredibly massive,
complicated structures 12,000
years ago for sure is the Sphinx.
And infant.
We mess up.
We're now talking about that.
We're talking about gold Beckley tappy
but yeah,
they had the space isn't big.
It's fucking huge and for you to say
that it's very disturbing because
they've only uncovered 5% of it or 10%
it's massive for further than
comparable.
Not Quite big studies,
but this is the problem.
You don't know a lot about it,
but you're automatically jumping to this
skeptical but you haven't.
If you didn't think it was big.
I just can't remember off the top of my
head exact the problem.
But you're so convinced in your
argument,
but you're not really ever really spent
a whole lot of time thinking about a
carving stone man that's not very
advanced.
Just carving stone.
They're carving stern with three
dimensional objects in the stone,
meaning like lizards that are on the
outside of it.
19 foot hauls,
tall stone columns and concentric
circles.
Is this,
is there a huge structure,
look at the hiring,
any particular the technology today it
does to move those things?
Look,
we'll look at the image on the far
right.
That's what they have figured out so
far.
By using radar underground,
we look at the size of this room.
That is huge.
It's fucking shiny,
primitive.
It's just stone.
It's not that primitive for someone to
make something out of stone that Dave,
it's really impressive.
Right?
It must've been primitive and turn,
but like they don't have a TV.
Is that what you mean?
It isn't like the like for example,
I'm sure if they,
I'm sure if they went and did some sort
of like super high resolution scans on
it or something like that,
they'd be like,
right,
okay.
This has been coughed with other stone
tools.
You know,
they can tell these be called Capa
tools,
whatever.
This wouldn't have been carved by a
couple of tools.
You know,
he knows.
He don't even know that when it comes to
the great pyramid.
In fact,
there's a lot of people that speculate,
they figured out a way to make some sort
of a diamond tipped late drill in order
to make the,
uh,
the king's chamber.
And some of the sarcophagus is if they
look at us not fringe,
they don't really know how they carved
out some of the stone in the,
there's,
there's a simple thought,
two pages.
There's a simple vase in Egypt they
don't understand because it's carved
completely at a one piece of stone,
but it's so intricate and so hard that
they've made this incredibly thin lip on
this vase and they've gone deep inside
of it and the whole thing is entirely
smooth.
They really don't know how the fuck they
did it.
Probably some paper.
I'm rubbing it patients,
they can't get your fingers inside of
this thing.
I'm talking about an actual vas.
Yeah.
It's very,
very confusing to modern archeologists.
This is not a got engine.
Anyway,
I don't know about that.
I was talking about what I'm saying.
What is an ancient advanced civilization
like?
Don't you agree that the Parthenon,
the Acropolis,
that's an advanced civilization?
Not particularly for the time for what
they,
for what they accomplished is amazing.
They said none of great massive stones
that are cut in place.
The beautiful columns,
fifth century.
Okay.
Well then what pays in advance
civilization if that's not advance?
That's the point,
isn't it?
Can you talk calling your vans pathogen
to as a,
the glorification of athletes over its
empire,
right,
right.
It was not that these things didn't
already exist.
It's he wanted to make Athens look
special in the eyes of the rest of the
world.
This is what I'm confused.
Like what year did this happen and when
do you consider people to be fans of out
on the full 60 be seals?
I should know that.
Advanced civilization.
No.
Come on,
man.
If that didn't exist anywhere and then
all of a sudden may send 1000 years ago,
then yeah,
but if 10,000
years ago,
something like something like,
uh,
the Parthenon and the Acropolis,
if we could prove that 10,000
years before anybody had done anything
else that that existed,
you'd be blown away by that,
right?
Yeah,
but shocking.
Yeah.
No,
the,
the [inaudible] may be 10,000
BC.
That would be incredible.
Right?
Right.
It would be right.
But a bunch of upright stones that have
been nicely carved to have animals on
them and stuff like that,
that just that massive stones in 19 feet
tall and concentric circles all in this
huge structure hens in Britain.
We know how they made it and we know
where the students came from.
You know,
having gotten the,
you're one of those dudes,
well you're one of those dudes that
history that,
no,
not just read history cause you don't
know anything about go back.
They tempe and yet you're so,
so you just your throat to me.
But I'm trying to tell you what,
Oh I interrupt you.
You're adorable.
You keep going with these things.
You really don't even know anything
about this area and yet your money by
hunters and gatherers,
there's a lot of argument one way or the
other about it.
It's entirely possible that they had
discovered farming.
I guess.
I mean that,
that's the area that farming was a
originally,
originally as part of the problem,
right?
When you get to 12,000
years ago,
who knows what the fuck isn't it?
And we think they knew things and then
we find out that they knew more.
I mean this is mostly covered in ice.
How could you get an advanced
civilization?
Heart of the earth?
Yeah.
Yes.
Mostly covered in Nice,
like when you're dealing with North
America,
right?
North America 12,000
hours ago.
Big parts of it.
But on the south to felt like a band in
the middle of this.
Yeah.
I mean we're was posted.
What do they think Turkey was like back
then?
Because this is where it go.
Beckley cafes in Turkey,
what they think Turkey was like 12,000
years ago.
And the problem is if that,
if they can carbon date it absolutely to
12,000
years ago,
they know it was covered up.
It was intentionally covered 12,000
years ago.
This is the story of,
go back to Cathy.
Um,
when was it constructed that they don't
know because stone you can't carbon
date,
like the way they did it with the
Egyptian pyramids,
they got the material in between each
stone.
So I can kind of think they know,
you know,
like say 30,000
years ago,
20,000
I could,
I could believe in a certain area of the
world,
the,
a bunch of tribesmen who hunter
gathering maybe,
maybe seasonally nomadic,
um,
you know,
for a hundred years,
maybe it was a,
you know,
as a religious duty.
They considered it to be,
I mean,
this thing,
stonehenge was built over a period of
like,
look thousand years.
I mean,
it took a long time to just put these
fucking stones.
So,
I mean,
we don't know how long this would have
taken,
but to have a bunch of carved stones up,
right.
Even if they're big,
they'll just requires more people that
that's not great technological
feat.
That's the thing.
It's not a blood is a technological
feat.
If Marlene,
the Acropolis,
there's not a technological feat.
It was a technological feat,
but it wasn't particularly unique to the
world at the time.
In fact,
the Persians in the Babylonians and
Syrians,
they've been done of thousands years
before that.
The Greeks were catching up when the,
doesn't that then support the idea that
go Beckley Tapi is even more unique
because it was incredible as a name.
No,
no.
That's all right.
It's that is an advanced civilization
then.
Well,
no.
yeah.
I mean it's advanced for the rest of the
world,
but it's,
it's pretty advanced for today.
If we wanted to build something like
that today would take massive resources.
It would take huge machines.
It would take a gigantic group of
engineers.
That's how convenient project.
That's out of convenience.
What do you mean out of convenience?
Why that's missing that?
How was it out of convenience when you
get 19 foot tall stones that are,
because you don't really get loads in
there.
He pulls him in a circle.
I mean,
it's a lot of work.
Of course it is.
Yeah.
That's why would you use machines?
Because it'd just be a lot of work.
It's not as simple as you just use
machines,
like you'd have to get very specific
massive machines that are incredibly
difficult to engineerings and these
people did that without any of that
shit.
Yeah,
they did the ropes and pretty easily
logs,
prob probably prominent police actually,
but the ropes in logs,
who knows how the fuck they did it,
but that's what we're supposed to be.
There was no wheel back then.
They'll probably wasn't,
I mean it's pretty spectacular.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
no,
it's okay.
Yeah.
Right.
Okay.
So let me,
so I'm not trying to take away the
amount of effort involved in building
this thing and the willpower to do it
and the manpower to do it.
What are you trying to say and not
indicative of an advanced civilization?
What,
when I think,
I think he's a definition of advanced.
For example,
like I would consider an advanced
civilization have writing.
I would consider them to have
metallurgy.
I would consider,
I wouldn't even call this advanced this,
I mean this is,
this is,
this puts them,
this puts them where we were 4,000
years ago,
you know,
as a species.
So advanced is like,
uh,
it's all,
it's all well,
yeah.
Well,
I mean it's all relative,
isn't it?
So it's like,
I mean what I mean,
yeah,
I mean if,
if,
if you want to speculate,
they might have been a civilization like
pre ice age or during the ice age that
had writing and metallurgy and you know,
great cities and international trade
agriculture also all this sort of stuff
that we would look,
if you look at the Roman Empire,
we see if we take them as the model of
an advanced civilization.
Right.
And when I say advanced,
we mean not as advanced as we are now.
[inaudible] right.
Well that's what everyone speculates
about.
Atlanta says,
well no one ever thinks that Atlanta was
like today.
They think some crazy things.
Some people really,
some people,
I mean,
yeah,
but um,
this is,
we should should've been more specific.
Um,
but yeah,
I mean,
don't,
don't get me wrong.
I'm sure that for the time,
like when a run around and tribe came
over the hill and they saw go back to
the teepee and it was incredible,
it was like,
ah,
the gods have built this,
you know,
that's what they would have thought.
I'm sure you know,
to them it would have relatively been
incredible,
you know,
am I'm doing wrong?
I know I don't want to take away the
achievement for the people who made it
cause it's unbelievably good.
And you know,
especially for the time,
but like if,
if they didn't have white mel tools then
have writing,
they didn't have agriculture,
I wouldn't call that advance.
I'd just call that a loss of work for a
premise of civilization.
And the same with this stone henge would
have been the real problem is we don't
really know what they had.
And until more evidence gets uncovered,
they,
they're just guessing.
They have some carbon dating.
They know that the stones exist.
They don't even know.
I mean they didn't even know about this
until 1990 something.
I mean they found it in the 90s but me
know all of northern Europe,
you know,
stone circles hinges me or whatever.
Well they find more of those now than
ever before with satellites.
Right?
Yeah.
Seen the ones that they're finding now
in the Amazon and they're like,
what the fuck is this?
They're finding all these structures,
the channels,
and you send me the link to that because
that sounds interesting.
Well that's the lost city of z.
You know about that right now there's a,
there was a guy who went looking,
he was an explorer,
went looking for the loss series,
city of z in the Amazon.
It was like a mythical lost city and he
got eaten by cannibals.
Apparently there's some movie that's
coming out about him right now that's
racist.
No,
they were white counts.
I'm about that.
Um,
but I'll post privilege.
It was,
um,
yeah,
it was speculated that before the Ama,
well that's the other thing that came
out recently.
The Amazon was covered in the ocean
somewhere around 10 million years ago or
something.
But they think that these people had
some sort of,
you know,
for the time again,
what is an advanced civilization?
Yeah.
It probably needs to be defined.
I think that that's the first step.
But yeah,
I mean it's interesting to say love
isn't the path for them to invest
saying,
no,
not really.
You know,
it,
it was a beautiful thing.
It a great construct.
And it costs the Athenians a lot of
money and they did it to beautify the
city and make it the jewel of Greece.
Um,
but it wasn't like,
I mean,
what's more impressive is it's more that
they did for political reasons.
The Parthenon is built on the crop.
They did it.
The Acropolis is what's a really a trip.
What it was cause this giant fucking
chunks of stone.
They have no idea how big they are open.
They're huge and they're like,
what?
They don't even know why they're there,
but they weren't even built at the same
time.
The Acropolis is just a natural stone
formation.
Not necessarily there's stones under
that natural stone,
like the,
the actual platform that the parthenon
was built on existed before the
Parthenon.
Right.
I,
I'm not sure I follow what you're saying
that because as far as I'm aware,
the Acropolis,
the Acropolis just lost the
inflammation.
Then they,
I guess they must have leveled it off as
something something,
but then there's actual physical stones,
actual monstrous physical stones that
are involved in construction molter and
see the same sort of pull up photos,
see if he could find that.
There's a bunch of that.
Yeah.
The old ones.
And what's the thing in Multa where they
thought there was like bill by side
collapses or something?
Giant.
Giant size,
like 3000 years BC.
Is that ball back now?
That's in Lebanon?
Yeah.
No,
this ball back in Lebanon,
they found these enormous stone carved
things.
Yeah.
See those stones?
Which ones?
The uh,
the,
there's,
there's some stuff.
See if you could find some images of
the,
yeah,
some of it does.
It does.
From that side.
I'm pretty sure that just a natural
stone out.
I mean the,
on the,
this sort of like fortifications around
it,
you know,
you can probably just google that and
find out when we put up it probably like
16th century or something,
you know,
there's nothing mystical about the path
or not.
It's just a really useful defensive
fortification or not missed a call.
I'm just saying ancient.
I think they,
uh,
the speculation was that the,
the Acropolis,
which one's the Acropolis?
That's bottom.
The Parthenon is the top.
Now the powerful though is on the
Acropolis.
The Parthenon is on the top and the
Acropolis is on the bottom.
That's what I'm saying.
That they,
the,
the thing that they think is the ancient
stones.
Okay.
Altogether.
Yeah.
And the Parthenon is just the building.
Right.
Okay.
The papillon was a temple.
And so when you say the Acropolis,
the Parthenon is the,
most cities have necropolis,
which is just a raised rocky bit that
they'd build defensive right then.
But you know,
they'd put the temple's on and stuff
like,
so find out what,
where,
where I read that,
see if you could google a man made
stones in the Acropolis.
There was some sort of weird speculation
that the Acropolis was a part of some
structure that was far older than the
Parthenon.
Not,
uh,
not,
not persuaded by all of that sort of,
that was a bit fringe stuff for me.
You're not in the friendship.
Not when it comes to history.
I like to know accurate stuff,
you know?
Yeah.
No,
it makes sense.
It's just fringe is always more
attractive though.
It's interesting,
isn't it?
Because you never know and there's the
like,
oh,
you might be able to find out for
yourself,
but it's also like undeniably it has
gravity.
Yeah.
Towards me.
At least I am.
I love the old stuff.
They're like,
no,
no.
You know what they found out,
man,
they were werewolves.
You know,
there's always like something that you
find out.
Yeah.
I went through all of this and my
twenties I went through literally all of
these fucking,
I'm a late bloomer.
They really,
all right.
You'll end up eventually where I am.
Oh,
I definitely want wake end up where you
are.
You will,
you know,
it's,
it's a good place to be.
It's um,
you go through all of these ferries and
you'll immediately dismiss things.
No,
you don't immediately dismiss things.
Then you have to start reading about why
things happened.
That's the thing.
You have to start reading the,
the source material.
That's why I know who built the bill,
the Parthenon.
Right.
But that's also why you just just
flippantly decided that [inaudible] was
small.
Yeah.
Well,
no,
it's not that the size of,
it's irrelevant.
It's the sort of technological
advancement,
you know,
it doesn't take much to Co coff stone.
They used to,
you know,
let you know they just other stone to
break against it and then it's smooth at
the hands of sand.
You know,
it just took a lot of work for a long
time and I mean wrong,
it must've been fucking with,
you know,
get a hide the leather put sand in it.
He spent ages smoothing up stone.
Do it yourself if you'd like.
It's fucking boring,
you know?
But I guess if you've got nothing else
to do all day because you're just right
here,
Jamie,
but that's not carved,
that's like,
uh,
this is bass relief I believe is it says
what most of the art,
and we'll go back with tippy was it was
like,
ah,
yeah,
it's a three d and moved away and not
carved into,
yeah,
that's what was interesting about.
It's more difficult.
Yeah.
It doesn't really,
I mean,
I don't want to take anything away from
the artist because that must've been a
lot of work.
What was the a man made stones and the
Acropolis to finding
there was evidence of these enormous
chunks of rock that were moved.
Maybe I might be conflating chunks of
rock a ball back in Lebanon with the
Acropolis.
It's all fascinating to me because we
don't know.
We just don't know what these people
were up to and we see what they left
behind and we pieced it together and
people have studied it for thousands of
years and it's just,
it's amazing.
Just,
I mean,
I'm sure you've been to Rome,
right?
You haven't,
it's on my list to me,
man.
The coliseums fairly recent,
right?
One of the century ideal something.
Yeah.
I mean in terms of like ancient
civilization,
the very recent,
but it's,
it's so crazy when they show you the
history of it.
How they used to that whole thing was
like Nero's backyard.
I mean that's really what,
and then they decided to,
once they,
it's a bad,
yeah.
Well then then decided to build this,
this thing to sort of entertain the
masses.
And this thing has gone through all
these different,
various stages.
And when they show you all the different
things they used to do,
they're like,
have these boat fights where they would
fill it up with water and they would
raise these lions and all these animals
through the bottom of the cage and they
would fight against him.
Like you're fucking crazy.
And not that long ago.
Yeah.
I mean like,
people used to be brutal.
Let's think people forget.
It's like,
well,
we were talking about Isis.
They still are.
Yeah,
well they,
uh,
but now,
I mean not that shocks and his whole
unit to most people,
but like,
I mean,
like in,
in the 15th century,
16th century kids used to do coke
fighting.
You know,
they,
they do it here in Mexican and Mexican
neighborhoods.
Yeah.
I can just watching these chickens
killing one of my old dumb,
this guy that he's to use as a gardener,
like six,
seven years ago,
he used to cockfight no,
no something,
no compassion for anything that wasn't
human.
Basically.
It was like,
oh,
definitely not for chickens.
Yeah.
They put razor blades on them.
Live with spurs on them.
They fight each other.
Yeah.
It's fucking crazy.
They,
I went to this guys,
you already had like a hundred a
roosters in these like pens and they
would have this carved out area and a
pit it let the roosters go.
It's super common.
It's super common in many parts of the
world.
In fact,
it's really common in the south of
America,
not South America,
but south of the United States.
It's a,
it's real common,
like cockfights sort of not thought of
the same way.
It's like dog fights,
like dog fights.
Horrify people.
Yeah,
but chicken fights.
People like,
Hey,
he's cutting the dog.
Well,
it's still,
they still do bull fights in Spain.
Should I do all the amazing,
it's pretty controversial these days.
They just lost another matador a couple
of days ago.
He got fucked.
Doug.
I stepped over his own cape.
Tripped over the Cape.
Got Jacked.
Yeah.
He'd get torn apart.
No sympathy whatsoever.
No,
no.
It's a foolish way to do.
You wanted it to die and risk your life.
The whole thing is crazy ex.
But Spain is an advanced civilization.
Well,
I've known too many Spaniards.
Ah,
how dare you.
But didn't anything that I think in
general there are modern Western
civilization and they have bull
fighting.
Do you know what's really funny about
spine?
Explain that.
Cause I mean like a,
in America you've got a terrible
history,
right?
We have a terrible history of being
terrible is what you're saying.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Okay.
So the Spanish,
Spanish,
Spanish history is,
I'm highly Islamophobic obviously.
And I went out and spent a few years ago
and um,
everything everywhere.
It's a white guy killing him,
Muslim on every poultry,
on every undergo.
Oh yeah.
Cause they spent 800 years kicking the
Muslims out of Spain because the Muslims
came along and conquered Spain.
And so everything is Towsley
Islamophobic because that is their
history.
They can't get away from it that they
wouldn't be a Spain because the malls
came over and conquered it and they were
like,
right,
everyone's a Muslim now or you're going
to have to pay the Gza.
Ah,
you're going to be a DHIMMI.
And they were like,
no.
And they spent emgs,
his letter,
whatever,
loss,
resistance or whatever,
they're the Spanish.
Before it would be like,
you know,
just the reconquista and it took several
crusades.
It took hundreds of years and gallons of
blood.
But eventually Spain became Christine
again and the,
and the Muslims and they're like the,
the Islam of files.
He'll sit there and go,
oh well you know,
I'll under loose.
Yeah it was stolen from someone else and
these people took it back.
I've got no fucking sympathy for these
people.
Got kicked out.
Who came in originally?
I wasn't even supposed to be there.
And I'll tell you what,
the Muslims are fucking lucky that
Columbus discovered the new world
because the Spanish were basically
functional roll up all of North Africa.
That was gonna.
They were piling to take it all fucking
back cause this was all Christian.
It really annoys me that people are
like,
oh no that's Muslim.
No it wasn't.
And it's because they took it and so if
the Spanish is going to take it back,
that's just as valid.
You don't have an argument against them
doing it and it's something that's been
established though.
We don't want you to take it back to
know,
Oh yeah,
I'm not just saying it now.
I'll be suggesting it,
but it's still,
yeah,
it does.
I put like,
you know when we're,
when we're looking back at history
through the lens of having a moral
judgment about it and they go,
oh,
the Spanish kicked the Muslims.
I've Spain.
Yeah,
good for them.
They have every right to,
he can't really have moral judgments
about history when people do this full
time.
I mean like the Crusades,
Jimmy Dale,
this,
there's nothing less than the crew said,
shut the fuck up Jimmy.
You do not know what you're talking
about.
Just shutup cenk stopped talking at the
Crusades.
Oh,
unless I tell you what,
you're right.
Let's call them back.
Bring back the crusading armies.
It's called a Baldwin Baldwin of
Jerusalem.
Come on.
You're going to have to come home.
He'd come on Baldwin.
This is wrong.
We shouldn't be crusading.
Oh well that ended 800 years ago,
but done conversation over.
I pisses me off,
man.
They keep bringing up the shit.
Absolute Shit.
But what about the Crusades?
What about the fucking crusades?
Where are the crusaders Jank you know,
where are the fucking crusaders?
Are you talking to Janky Yogurt,
Jimmy?
Any here?
You're talking about Yo?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Some people do,
but most people don't.
Fucking nose.
I saw him at vidcon.
I'm sure he knows there's,
you're talking about and when you say
his name,
but I'm saying you're saying it too,
a large audience that people know just
because you don't know peanut.
Oh,
a lot of people don't,
but I do keep though.
I do know other people don't find for
people.
How do we get out of bullfighting to
this cultural relativism?
Basically?
I think it was what it is and what we're
talking about.
Advanced civilizations.
He's sick of the apologists.
It's like look like look,
things that happened in the past,
we didn't have to apologize for,
you know,
these things just happened.
We don't need to do things.
Why people should apologize for all the,
all the horrible things that we've done.
What about to native Americans?
Should we apologize to them?
I think that if they're prepared to
apologize to the people they genocide
it.
Wow,
that's,
you're going a little too far.
But that doesn't exist anymore.
No,
you go too far back.
That's a problem.
Well,
who decided once we have done that,
we've trespassed on their land.
You don't bring up them doing it cause
that hour that would be native American.
A phobic.
It's not our place.
Our place.
Yeah.
See this the whole thing.
It's all bollocks.
And this whole relativism is pissing me
off and he read it really actually makes
me angry and none of them will ever
listen to the like the counter
arguments.
It's really annoying.
And so it's just like,
no.
Like,
you know,
nobody's got any respect for you when
you turn around and say portable
crusades.
That's the,
I mean,
what a boundary is the dumbest damn
thing anyway because you never
addressing the point.
It's like,
yeah,
but he didn't even give a context about
Islam basically.
You know,
there's,
you know,
they,
they for some reason to think that
Christianity is as bad as Islam as a
nurse,
not,
I mean like the Crusades were distinctly
and,
and I spoke to his story and Tom Holland
about this and I was like,
look,
how did they come to the conclusion that
they shouldn't have a crusade?
And he was like,
well they didn't get it from
Christianity and the Orthodox,
uh,
the Orthodox patriarch in Constantinople
was just completely against the idea
because there's nothing in the Bible
that justifies it in the new testament.
You know,
Jason,
man of peace,
he turns her on the cheek,
he lets his enemies strike him.
So you can't pick up a sword and say I'm
going to kill someone for Jesus.
It doesn't make sense when people have
massive amounts of power.
And then,
I mean,
it went,
it's weird with the Aztecs,
it goes weird with everybody.
It was entirely Tempura.
It was about like,
you know,
concrete and Middle East.
But it was also about like making sure
that they could get to Jerusalem is
like,
like an ideological thing.
Cause the,
the Turks were basically preventing
pilgrims from getting to Jerusalem
because Muslims don't Jerusalem's for
like 400 years and everything was okay
because the pilgrims could travel along
a pill and trail and you know,
people make money doing this,
you know,
they'd sell things.
And then the text came in and were like,
hey,
we're Muslims and fuck everyone cause
with the Turks and that was it.
The pilgrims couldn't go to Jerusalem
and they'd put the pope,
I think it was,
it was an innocent,
the second urban,
the second,
I can never remember which one it was,
which of the pope was he tell him I
said,
hey,
I could create a spiritual kingdom or
empire,
an empire of faith on.
And he's like,
why don't you all rather than fighting
each other in Europe,
I mean Europeans were not very advanced,
but they were very,
very warlike and wanting to get to the
Middle East.
And they did.
And the crusade was actually,
it means a real thrilling thing to read
about.
Now what,
you know,
you see like historical films like all
the time,
it's always the Roman empire.
Which one?
Just every historical fucking right.
Okay.
And it's just someone needs to do a film
by the first crusade.
Cause the first crusade is one of the
most thrilling things you can ever read
about.
It's just the most,
it's insane what these men did,
you know,
marching.
I mean they must like a thousand miles
from northern Europe and just the master
and just,
it's so much stuff.
Like the pope first calls a crusade and
it goes kind of wrong for him cause
everyone's like the page or the emperor
in Constantinople,
the [inaudible],
he says the,
uh,
the pope,
look,
do me a favor.
I'm getting thrashed by the Turks.
I need about 4,000
nights professional soldiers,
good fighters so I can beat them back.
And the posts like,
hey,
great idea.
Why don't we all go over there and beat
up the Tux for Christianity and loads of
patents when I call.
And that's a good idea.
And so like 70,000
peasants led by Peter,
the hermit turn up on the,
the emperor is dose and he's like,
what the fuck is this?
You know,
why have you sent me the scum of Europe
to come and fight the Turks?
So he just gets them across into
Anatolia and they go on and they just
get massacred by the text.
Absolutely butchered.
And then the crusading armies actually
arrive a piece.
The home actually manages to survive,
but then the Crusades,
the army's arrive and the Turks think,
well this would be fine.
And the emperor is like,
Shit,
look at all these really.
And these guys were totally
disrespectful.
It gets them across and they ended up
smashing the texts and the Turks were
just expecting another bunch of passes
and they're not expecting what they
called the men of iron,
which couldn't be broken.
And that's why they both fight in Paris,
Spain,
we fucked out.
But it's,
it's,
you know,
this,
this is a really interesting thing and
no one ever talks about it,
but it's the history of human beings as
fast as we have learned and how long
it's taken us to get to this point.
The regressive left,
they'll always talk to you like this is
like a one sided.
Oh,
the Kristine's side.
Just bullying them out of the blue one
day.
It's like,
no.
There was an established order.
There were things going on.
Those is really detailed political
landscape,
and you'll get someone to Jimmy Dore
Goes,
wow,
there's nothing worth increase age.
Just shut up.
Just you don't know you're talking
about.
Just be quiet.
All right fella.
I'm glad you got that African angry.
I've had that on my capital a long time.
Listen,
we did an extra hour pass the idea.
Oh,
I could do,
it's two now.
This is when your flight,
so let's get you another flight.
Yeah.
And uh,
thank you brother.
I really appreciate you coming on and
thanks to have,
it was very fun.
It was,
it's fine.
It's nice that I can a bit some people
out who need to be bitched out and they
see that there's a,
if we get that.
All right folks,
thank you.
So back tomorrow with crystal,
AEA,
cea.